devops and cloud computing are two of
the most in demand technologies in the
industry these days for developing
applications and managing data safely
hello everyone welcome to this full
course video on devops and cloud
computing
this video will help you understand
about the different tools and frameworks
and devops and also make you learn about
the different cloud providers
our experienced trainers will take you
through this course and will make you
learn each topic with hands-on
demonstrations
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to the simply loan channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update
so we will start by watching a short
animated video to understand the basics
of devops and then learn the lifecycle
of devops followed by its advantages
we will look at what cloud computing is
the benefits of cloud computing and the
different cloud providers
moving ahead we will learn the important
devops tools and frameworks such as git
jenkins maven selenium docker and others
then we will focus on learning about the
different cloud providers and explore
more about them so you will learn about
amazon web services microsoft azure and
google cloud platform in detail with
hands-on demonstrations
so let's get started
meet tim
tim builds a robot in his lab
a climate controlled and pollution-free
environment
once he's done he drops the robot off at
his project partner mia's house mia
takes it out to her backyard to ensure
that the robot meets the requirements
but here is where the problem arises the
change in the environment causes the
robot to malfunction
mia is now really annoyed and she has a
lot to correct and it seems to her as
though tim didn't really do much
this wall between them leaves a poor
robot to bite the dust
well what if we broke this wall tim and
miana work together in a common space
tim develops each block of functionality
of the robot which is then immediately
checked by mia both are now working
simultaneously
instead of waiting on the other to
finish their task as and when a feature
is ready for use they are put together
to build the final product they develop
a common mindset and share ideas to
further speed up the process they use
several tools which can automate every
stage this means that the robot is now
ready sooner with less iterations and
manual work from an organization
perspective tim would be the developer
while mia the operations their union is
the core of the devops approach devops
has several stages and set of tools to
automate each of these stages let's have
a look at these tim first puts down a
plan
in terms of software this could mean
deciding on the modules and the
algorithms to use
once he has the plan he now codes the
plan with tools such as git tim has a
repository for storing all the codes and
their different versions this is called
version control
next this code is fetched and made
executable this is the build stage tools
such as gradle and maven will sort this
out now before deployment the product is
tested to catch any bugs the most
popular tool automating testing is
selenium once the products are tested
mia must deploy it the deployed product
is then continuously configured to the
desired state
ansible puppet and docker are some of
the most common tools used that automate
these stages
now every product is continuously
monitored in its working environment
nagios is one such tool that automates
this space and the feedback is fed back
to the planning stage
and finally we have the core of the
devops life cycle the integration stage
tools such as jenkins is responsible for
sending the code for build and test if
the code passes the tests it's further
sent for deployment
this is called continuous integration
let's now have a look at an organization
that has adopted the devops approach
which of the below sequence of steps
would they follow to develop a software
leave your answers in the comment
section
keep an eye out for the right answer on
the comment section or our youtube
community
giants such as amazon netflix target xc
and walmart have all adopted devops and
seen a considerable increase in delivery
and quality
in 2014 an hour of downtime for netflix
would cost 200 000
it became absolutely crucial that
netflix prepared themselves for any sort
of failure and so they took to the
devops approach and implemented it in
the most unique way they developed a
tool called simeon army this tool
created failures and automatically
deployed them in an environment that did
not affect the users
the team would troubleshoot these
failures and this gave them enough
experience to deal with any degree of
collapse with everything being automated
and happening simultaneously
organizations can now deliver at a much
faster pace so considering the benefits
of devops and its divergence from the
traditional methods would devops be the
future
let us know what you think in the
comment section below hello this is
matthew with simply learn and today
we're going to introduce you to devops
so let's go through waterfall so
waterfall is a traditional delivery
model that's been used for many decades
for delivering solutions not just it
solutions and digital solutions but even
way before that it has its history that
goes back to world war ii so waterfall
is a model that is used to capture
requirements and then cascade each key
deliverable through a series of
different stage gates that is used for
building out the solution so let's take
you through each of those stage gates
the first that you may have done is
requirements analysis and this is where
you sit down with the actual client and
you understand specifically what they
actually do and what they're looking for
in the software that you're going to
build and then from that requirements
analysis you'll build out a project
planning so you have an understanding of
what the level of work is needed to be
able to be successful in delivering the
solution after that you've got your plan
then you start doing the development and
that means that the programmers start
coding out their solution they build out
their applications to build out the
websites and this can take weeks or even
months to actually do all the work when
you've done your coding and development
then you send it to another group that
does testing and they'll do full
regression testing of your application
against the systems and databases that
integrate with your application you'll
test it against the actual code you'll
do manual testing you do ui testing and
then after you've delivered the solution
you go into maintenance mode which is
just kind of making sure that the
application keeps working there's any
security risks that you address those
security risks the problem you have
though is that there are some challenges
however that you have with the waterfall
model the cascading deliveries and those
complete and separated stage gates means
that it's very difficult for any new
requirements from the client to be
integrated into the project so if a
client comes back and if the project has
been running for six months and they've
gone hey we need to change something
that means that we have to almost
restart the whole project it's very
expensive and it's very time consuming
also if you spend weeks and months away
from your clients and you deliver a
solution that they are only just going
to see after you spend a lot of time
working on it they could be pointing out
things that are in the actual final
application that they don't want or are
not implemented correctly or lead to
just general unhappiness the challenge
you then have is if you want to add back
in the client's feedback to restart the
whole waterfall cycle again so the
client will come back to you with a list
of changes and then you go back and you
have to start your programming and you
have to then start your testing process
again and just you're really adding in
lots of additional time into the project
so using the waterfall model companies
have soon come to realize that you know
the clients just aren't able to get
their feedback in quickly effectively
it's very expensive to make changes once
the teams have started working and the
requirement in today's digital world is
that solutions simply must be delivered
faster and this has led for a specific
change in agile and we start
implementing the agile model so the
agile model allows programmers to create
prototypes and get those prototypes to
the client with the requirements faster
and the client is able to then send the
requirements back to the programmer with
feedback this allows us to create what
we call a feedback loop we're able to
get information to the client and the
client can get back to the development
team much faster typically when we're
actually going through this process
we're looking at the engagement cycle
being about two weeks and so it's much
faster than the traditional waterfall
approach and so we can look at each
feedback loop as comprising of four key
elements we have the planning where we
actually sit down with the client to
understand what they're looking for we
then have coding and testing that is
building out the code and the solution
that is needed for the client and then
we review with the client the changes
that have happened but we do all this in
a much tighter cycle that we call a
sprint and that typically a sprint will
last for about two weeks some companies
run sprints every week some run every
four weeks it's up to you as a team to
decide how long you want to actually run
a sprint but typically it's two weeks
and so every two weeks the client is
able to provide feedback into that loop
and so you were able to move quickly
through iterations and so if we get to
the end of sprint two and the client
says hey you know what we need to make a
change you can make those changes
quickly and effectively for sprint three
what we have here is a breakdown of the
ceremonies and the approach that you
bring to agile so typically what will
happen is that a product leader will
build out a backlog of products and what
we call a product backlog and this will
be just a whole bunch of different
features and they may be small features
or bug fixes all the way up to large
features that may actually span over
multiple sprints but when you go through
the sprint planning you want to actually
break out the work that you're doing so
the team has a mixture of small medium
and large solutions that they can
actually implement successfully into
their sprint plan and then once you
actually start running your sprint again
it's a two-week activity you meet every
single day to with the actual sprint
team to ensure that everybody is staying
on track and if there's any blockers
that those blockers are being addressed
effectively and immediately the goal at
the end of the two weeks is to have a
deliverable product that you can put in
front of the customer and the customer
can then do a review the key advantages
you have of running a sprint with agile
is that the client requirements are
better understood because the client is
really integrated into the scrum team
they're there all the time and the
product is delivered much faster than
with a traditional waterfall model
you're delivering features at the end of
each sprint versus waiting weeks months
or in some cases years for a waterfall
project to be completed however there
are also some distinct disadvantages the
product itself really doesn't get tested
in a production environment it's only
been tested on the developer computers
and it's really hard when you're
actually running agile for the sprint
team to actually build out a solution
easily and effectively on their
computers to mimic the production
environment and the developers and the
operations team are running in separate
silos so you have your development team
running their sprint and actually
working to build out the features but
then when they're done at the end of
their sprint and they want to do a
release they kind of fling it over the
wall at the operations team and then
it's the operations team job to actually
install the software and make sure that
the environment is running in a stable
fashion that is really difficult to do
when you have the two teams really not
working together so here we have is a
breakdown of that process with the
developers submitting their work to the
operations team for deployment and then
the operations team may submit their
work to the production servers but what
if there is an error what if there was a
setup configuration error with the
developers test environment that doesn't
match the production environment there
may be a dependency that isn't there
there may be a link to an api that
doesn't exist in production and so you
have these challenges that the
operations team are constantly faced
with and their challenge is that they
don't know how the code works so this is
where devops really comes in and let's
dig into how devops which is developers
and operators working together is the
key for successful continuous delivery
so devops is as an evolution of the
agile model the agile model really is
great for gathering requirements and for
developing and testing out your
solutions and what we want to be able to
do is kind of address that challenge and
that gap between the ops team and the
dev team and so with devops what we're
doing is bringing together the
operations team and the development team
into a single team and they are able to
then work more seamlessly together
because they are integrated to be able
to build out solutions that are being
tested in a production-like environment
so that when we actually deploy we know
that the code itself will work the
operations team is then able to focus on
what they're really good at which is
analyzing the production environment and
being able to provide feedback to the
developers on what is being successful
so we're able to make adjustments in our
code that it's based on data so let's
step through the different phases of a
devops team so typically you'll see that
the devops team will actually have eight
phases now this is somewhat similar to
agile and what i'd like to point out at
time is that again agile and devops are
very closely related that agile
[Music]
phase is planning and this is where we
actually sit down with a business team
and we go through and understand what
their goals are the second stage is as
you can imagine and this is where it's
all very similar to agile is that the
coders actually start coding but they
typically they'll start using tools such
as git which is a distributed version
control software it makes it easier for
developers to all be working on the same
code base rather than bits of the code
that is rather than them working on bits
of the code that they are responsible
for so the goal with using tools such as
git is that each developer always has
the current and latest version of the
code you then use tools such as maven
and gradle as a way to consistently
build out your environment and then we
also use tools to actually automate our
testing now what's interesting is when
we use tools like selenium and junit is
that we're moving into a world where our
testing is scripted the same as our
build environment and the same as using
our get environment we can start
scripting out these environments and so
we actually have scripted production
environments that we're moving towards
jenkins is the integration phase that we
use for our tools and another pointer
here is that the tools that we're
listing here these are all open source
tools these are tools that any team can
start using we want to have tools that
control and manage the deployment of
code into the production environments
and then finally tools such as ansible
and chef will actually operate and
manage those production environments so
that when code comes to them that that
code is compliant with the production
environment so that when the code is
then deployed to the many different
production servers that the expected
results of those servers which is you
want them to continue running is
received and then finally you monitor
the entire environment so you can
actually zero in on spikes and issues
that are relevant to either the code or
changing consumer habits on the site
imagine you're the owner of a small
software development firm and you want
to scale your business up
however a small team size the
unpredictability of demand and limited
resources are roadblocks for this
expansion
that's when you hear about cloud
computing but before investing money
into it you decide to draw up the
differences between on-premise and
cloud-based computing to make a better
decision
when it comes to scalability you pay
more for an on-premise setup and get
lesser options too
once you've scaled up it is difficult to
scale down
and often leads to heavy losses in terms
of infrastructure and maintenance costs
cloud computing on the other hand allows
you to pay only for how much you use
with much easier and faster provisions
for scaling up or down
next let's talk about server storage
on-premise systems need a lot of space
for their servers notwithstanding the
power and maintenance hassles that come
with them
on the other hand cloud computing
solutions are offered by cloud service
providers who manage and maintain the
servers saving you both money and space
then we have data security on-premise
systems offer less data security thanks
to a complicated combination of physical
and traditional i.t security measures
whereas cloud computing systems offer
much better security and lets you avoid
having to constantly monitor and manage
security protocols
in the event that a data loss does occur
the chance for data recovery with
on-premise setups are very small
in contrast cloud computing systems have
robust disaster recovery measures in
place to ensure faster and easier data
recovery
finally we have maintenance
on-premises systems also require
additional teams for hardware and
software maintenance loading up the
costs by a considerable degree
cloud computing systems on the other
hand are maintained by the cloud service
providers reducing your costs and
resource allocation substantially
so now thinking that cloud computing is
a better option you decide to take a
closer look at what exactly cloud
computing is
cloud computing refers to the delivery
of on-demand computing services over the
internet on a pay-as-you-go basis
in simpler words rather than managing
files and services on a local storage
device you'll be doing the same over the
internet in a cost efficient manner
cloud computing has two types of models
deployment model and service model
there are three types of deployment
models public private and hybrid cloud
imagine you're traveling to work you've
got three options to choose from
one you have buses which represent
public clouds in this case the cloud
infrastructure is available to the
public over the internet
these are owned by cloud service
providers
two then you have the option of using
your own car
this represents the private cloud with
the private cloud the cloud
infrastructure is exclusively operated
by a single organization this can be
managed by the organization or a third
party and finally you have the option to
hell a cab
this represents the hybrid cloud
a hybrid cloud is a combination of the
functionalities of both public and
private clouds
next let's have a look at the service
models
there are three major service models
available es pass and sas
compared to on-premise models where
you'll need to manage and maintain every
component including applications data
virtualization and middleware cloud
computing service models are hassle-free
is refers to infrastructure as a service
it is a cloud service model where users
get access to basic computing
infrastructure they are commonly used by
it administrators
if your organization requires resources
like storage or virtual machines is is
the model for you you only have to
manage the data runtime middleware
applications and the os while the rest
is handled by the cloud providers
next we have pass
pass or platform as a service provides
cloud platforms and runtime environments
for developing testing and managing
applications
this service model enables users to
deploy applications without the need to
acquire manage and maintain the related
architecture
if your organization is in need of a
platform for creating software
applications pass is the model for you
pass only requires you to handle the
applications and the data the rest of
the components like runtime middleware
operating systems servers storage and
others are handled by the cloud service
providers
and finally we have sas
sas or software as a service involves
cloud services for hosting and managing
your software applications
software and hardware requirements are
satisfied by the vendors so you don't
have to manage any of those aspects of
the solution
if you'd rather not worry about the
hassles of owning any it equipment the
sas model would be the one to go with
with sas the cloud service provider
handles all components of the solution
required by the organization
time for a quiz now
in which of the following deployment
models are you as the business
responsible for the application data and
operating system
one is
two
pass
three
sas
four is and pass
let us know your answer in the comment
section below coming back to cloud
computing some of the most popular cloud
computing services in the market are aws
or amazon web services microsoft azure
and google cloud platform
want to learn more about them and how
they differ from each other click on the
top right corner for an analysis of how
these service platforms are different
from each other hi there i'm sam from
simply done and i work as a
multi-platform cloud architect and
trainer and let me welcome you to this
learning video called what is cloud
computing before cloud computing existed
if we need any it servers or application
let's say a basic web server it does not
come easy now here is an owner of a
business and i know you would have
guessed it already that he's running and
successful business by looking at the
hot and fresh brewed coffee in his desk
and lots and lots of paperwork to review
and approve now he had a smart not only
smart looking but a really smart worker
in his office called mark and on one
fine day he called mark and said that he
would like to do business online in
other words he would like to take his
business online and for that he needed
his own website as the first thing and
mark puts all his knowledge together and
comes up with this requirement that his
boss would need lots of servers
databases and softwares to get his
business online which means a lot of
investment and mark also adds that his
boss will need to invest on acquiring
technical expertise to manage the
hardware and software that they will be
purchasing and also to monitor the
infrastructure and after hearing all
this his boss was close to dropping his
plan to go online but before he made a
decision he chose to check if there are
any alternatives where he don't have to
spend a lot of money and don't have to
spend acquiring technical expertise now
that's when mark opened this discussion
with his boss and he explained his boss
about cloud computing and he explained
his boss the same thing that i'm going
to explain to you in some time now about
what is cloud computing what is cloud
computing cloud computing is the use of
a network of remote servers hosted on
the internet to store manage and process
data rather than having all that locally
and using local server for that cloud
computing is also storing our data in
the internet from anywhere and accessing
our data from anywhere throughout the
internet and the companies that offer
those services are called cloud
providers cloud computing is also being
able to deploy and manage our
applications services and network
throughout the globe and manage them
through the web management or
configuration portal in other words
cloud computing service providers give
us the ability to manage our
applications and services through a
global network or internet example of
such providers are amazon web servers
and microsoft azure now that we have
known what cloud computing is let's talk
about the benefits of cloud computing
now i need to tell you the cloud
benefits is what is driving cloud
adoption like anything in the recent
days if you want an it resource or a
service now with cloud it's available
for me almost instantaneously and it's
ready for production almost the same
time now this reduces the go live date
and the product and the service hit the
market almost instantaneously compared
to the legacy environment and because of
this the companies have started to
generate revenue almost the next day if
not the same day planning and buying the
right size hardware has always been a
challenge in legacy environment and if
you're not careful when doing this we
might need to live with the hardware
that's undersized for the rest of our
lives with cloud we do not buy any
hardware but we use the hardware and pay
for the time we use it if that hardware
does not fit our requirement release it
and start using a better configuration
and pay only for the time you use that
new and better configuration in legacy
environments forecasting demand is an
full-time job but with cloud you can let
the monitoring and automation tool to
work for you and to rapidly scale up and
down the resources based on the need of
that are not only that the resources
services data can be accessed from
anywhere as long as we are connected to
the internet and even there are tools
and techniques now available which will
let you to work offline and will sync
whenever the internet is available
making sure the data is stored in
durable storage and in a secure fashion
is the talk of the business and cloud
answers that million dollar question
with cloud the data can be stored in an
highly durable storage and replicated to
multiple regions if you want and the
data that we store is encrypted and
secured in a fashion that's beyond what
we can imagine in local data centers now
let's bleed into the discussion about
the types of cloud computing very lately
there are multiple ways to categorize
cloud computing because it's ever
growing now we have more categories out
of all these six sort of stand out you
know categorizing cloud based on
deployments and categorizing cloud based
on services and again under deployments
categorizing them based on how they have
been implemented
you know is it private is it public or
is it hybrid and again categorizing them
based on the servers it provides is it
infrastructure as a service or is it
platform as a service or is it software
as a service let's look at them one by
one let's talk about the different types
of cloud based on the deployment models
first in public cloud everything is
stored and accessed in and through the
internet and any internet users with
proper permissions can be given access
to some of the applications and
resources and in public cloud we
literally own nothing beat the hardware
or software everything is managed by the
provider aws azure and google are some
examples of public cloud private cloud
on the other hand with private cloud the
infrastructure is exclusively for an
single organization the organizations
can choose to run their own cloud
locally or choose to outsource it to a
public cloud provider as managed
services and when this is done the
service the infrastructure will be
maintained on a private network some
examples are vmware cloud and some of
the aws products are very good example
for private cloud hybrid cloud has taken
things to the whole new level with
hybrid cloud we get the benefit of both
public and private cloud organizations
will choose to keep some of their
applications locally and some of the
application will be present in the cloud
one good example is nasa it uses hybrid
cloud it uses private cloud to store
sensitive data and uses public cloud to
store and share data which are not
sensitive or confidential let's now
discuss about cloud based on service
model
the first and the broader category is
infrastructure as a service here we
would
rent the servers network storage and
we'll pay for them in an hourly basis
but we will have access to the resources
we provision and for some we will have
root level access as well ec2 in aws is
a very good example it's a vm for which
we have root level access to the os and
admin access to the hardware the next
type of service model would be platform
as a service now in this model the
providers will give me a pre-built
platform where we can deploy our codes
and our applications and they will be up
and running we only need to manage the
codes and not the infrastructure here in
software as a service the cloud
providers sell the end product which is
a software or an application and we
directly buy the software on an
subscription basis it's not the infra or
the platform but the end product or the
software or a functioning application
and we pay for the hours we use the
software and in here the client
maintains full control of the software
and does not maintain any equipment
amazon and azure also sell products that
are software as service this chart sort
of explains the difference between the
four models starting from on-premises to
infrastructure as a service to platform
as a service to software as a service
this is self-explanatory that the
resource managed by us are huge in on
premises that towards your left as you
watch and it's little less in
infrastructure as a service as we move
further towards the right and further
reduced in platform as a service and
there's really nothing to manage when it
comes to software as a service because
we buy the software not any
infrastructure component attached to it
there are lots of famous well-known
organization around the world they have
moved or have migrated to the cloud
environment pinterest is one company
which is one of the world's largest
visual book marketing tool with more
than 70 million monthly active users now
pinterest was able to scale its business
because it was all built on amazon web
services with a company with less number
of employees printers decided that they
do not want a dedicated staff time to
manage a data center instead pintyrest
uses aws or they used aws to manage
their high performance social
application and store more than 8
billion objects and 400 terabytes of
data in aws cloud using a service called
amazon simple storage service or in
short amazon s3 and not only that they
are running 2 lakh 25 000 instance hours
a month and they run that on amazon
compute service called amazon ac 2 or
amazon elastic compute cloud spotify is
an another company that got benefited
using aws it's an online music service
offering and it offers instant access to
over 16 million licensed songs spotify
needed a peculiar requirement it needed
a storage solution that could scale very
quickly without incurring long lead
times for upgrades long story short
spotify used amazon s3 which is amazon
simple storage service and amazon s3
gave them the confidence in their
ability and to expand their storage
quickly while also providing high data
durability the third biggest company i
want to mention is netflix it's the
world's largest internet television
network with more than 100 million
members in more than 190 countries
netflix uses amazon web services for
nearly all its computing and storage
needs now that includes database
analytics recommendation engines video
transcoding and a lot more not only that
this company is planning to use aws
lambda to build an automated or an
rule-based self-managing infrastructure
and replace some of their inefficient
process to reduce the rate of errors and
replace inefficient processes to reduce
the rate of errors and save their
valuable time expedia is another famous
company that got benefited by using
cloud xperia provides
travel booking service through its
flagship site called expedia.com and not
only that they also run 200 plus travel
booking sites around the world expedia
is all on aws and by using aws expedia
has become more resilient with an high
scalable infrastructure and better cloud
services because it had offloaded the it
management to the cloud provider itself
in this case aws and because of this
expedia's developers have been able to
innovate faster while saving the company
millions and millions of dollars as next
thing let's talk about the different
cloud providers amazon web services aws
is a cloud computing service provided by
amazon it provides a mix of
infrastructure as a service is platform
as a service pass and package software
as a service called sas offerings
microsoft azure formerly known as
windows assure is a cloud computing
service by microsoft and it sort of
specializes in using cloud for building
testing deploying and managing the
applications through the servers
throughout the global network that
microsoft manages it also provides
software as a service platform as a
service infrastructure as a service and
it supports lots of different
programming languages and tools and
frameworks including both microsoft and
third-party software and systems ibm
cloud is a cloud computing service
offered by ibm ibm cloud includes
infrastructure as a service software as
a service platform as a service now the
difference is here it offers through
public private and hybrid cloud delivery
models vmware on the other hand is a
subsidiary of dell technologies and
provides cloud computing and platform
virtualization software and services it
was the first commercially successful
company to virtualize the x86
architecture google cloud platform on
the other hand is offered by google it's
a suit of cloud computing services that
run on the same infrastructure that
google uses internally for its end user
products such as the google search and
the youtube you're familiar with
alongside a set of managed tools it also
provides cloud services including
computing services data storage services
data analytics and machine learning
services digitalocean on the other hand
is headquartered in new york city with
data centers worldwide digitalocean
provides developers cloud services that
help to deploy and scale applications
that run simultaneously on multiple
computers as of january 2018
digitalocean was the third largest
hosting company in the world in terms of
web phasing computers let's talk about
cloud computing in aws amazon web
services aws is an cloud computing
service provided by amazon and these
services are accessible over the
internet and because aws provides
infrastructure as a service it's a
flagship offering we can create and
deploy any type of application in the
cloud on top of the is that amazon
provides and you know the best part here
is the subscriptions are pay as you go
type you use less and pay less and only
for what you have used you use more pay
more but still less per unit for the
service used attractive isn't it now
let's talk about the life cycle of the
cloud computing solution the very first
thing in the life cycle of a solution or
a cloud solution is to get a proper
understanding of the requirement i
didn't say get the requirement but said
get a proper understanding of the
requirement it is very vital because
only then we will be able to properly
pick the right service offered by the
provider getting a sound understanding
the next thing would be to define the
hardware meaning choose the compute
servers that will provide the right
support where you can resize the compute
capacity in the cloud to run application
programs getting a sound understanding
of the requirement helps in picking the
right hardware one size does not fit all
there are different services and
hardwares for different needs you might
have like ec2 if you're looking for is
and lambda if you're looking for
serverless computing and ecs that
provides containerized service so there
are a lot of hardware's available pick
the right hardware that suits your
requirement the third thing is to define
the storage choose the appropriate
storage service where you can backup
your data and a separate storage service
where you can archive your data locally
within the cloud or from the internet
and choose the appropriate storage there
is one separately for backup called s3
and there is one separately for archival
that's for glacier so you know you
knowing the difference between them
really helps in picking the right
service for the right kind of need
define the network define the network
that securely delivers data video and
applications define and identify the
network services properly for example
vpc for network route 53 for dns and
direct connection for private p2p line
from your office to the aws data center
set up the right security services im
for authentication and authorization and
kms for data encryption at rest so there
are variety of security products
available we got to pick the right one
that suits our need and there are a
variety of deployment and automation and
monitoring tools that you can pick from
for example cloud watch is for
monitoring auto scaling is for being
elastic and cloud formation is define
the management process and tools you can
have complete control of your cloud
environment if you define the management
tools which monitors your aws resources
and or the custom applications running
on aws platform there are variety of
deployment automation and monitoring
tools you can pick from like cloud watch
for monitoring auto scaling for
automation and the cloud formation for a
deployment so knowing them will help you
in defining the life cycle of the cloud
computing solution properly and
similarly there are a lot of tools for
testing a process like code star and
code build and code pipeline these are
tools with which you can build test and
deploy your code quickly and finally
once everything is set and done click
the analytic service for analyzing and
visualizing the data using the analytics
services where we can start querying the
data instantly and get a result now if
you want to visually view the happenings
in your environment you can pick antenna
and other tools for analytics are emr
and which is elastic mapreduce and cloud
search all right enough of theory and
let's have a quick look at how two
services in aws ec2 and s3 work together
and benefits us here are two id
professionals talking to each other one
says i have an application which takes a
lot of storage and works only on linux
system which i do not have at the moment
and the other one is a smart guy and he
immediately replies that he could use s3
to store data and the drive data and use
ec2 for all his compute needs and then
the curious conversation builds up and
the first person wants to know what is
easy to ns3 and the second guy starts to
explain that aws ec2 is a web service
that provides a secure and resizable
compute capacity in the cloud and ec2 it
can also be used to launch as many
virtual servers as we need and about s3
he explains aws s3 is a simple storage
service provided by aws and about s3 he
explains further saying that using
amazon s3 we can store android drive any
amount of data at any time on the web
alright so the very first thing is to
have an aws account so create an aws
account and second thing is to create an
aws s3 bucket and upload the files there
you know the files that ec2 server is
going to pull from will get stored in s3
as first thing all right so the first
thing is to create an s3 bucket so let's
create an s3 bucket and let's call it as
website bucket and these names will have
to be unique so let's see if this bucket
name is available says bucket name
already taken or already exist so let me
top it up with sl meaning simply learn
all right so we were able to create a
bucket and in that bucket let me upload
a content that basically is going to be
my index file that's going to go and sit
in my web server so let me also make it
public and view it all right so this is
the content that i have stored in my s3
and this is the content i'm going to
push to my ec2 server right second step
create an aws s3 bucket and upload files
we're done with that third is to create
an ec2 instance that's in other words
create an virtual machine in the cloud
let's go and create it all right the
third thing is to create an ec2 instance
so let's create an ec2 instance it's
plain and it's very simple i'm going to
keep everything as defaults here all
right so i've launched an ec2 instance
as you see it's running i also have an
ip address public ip address here with
that i have logged into this ec2
instance and i'm in the folder slash war
slash
www.html and as you see there is nothing
in there at the moment and this server
also has apache installed in it as you
can see and now i browse to the ip
address of the ec2 instance and it's
showing a page which is the default
apache page all right if i had any files
in this folder that would get shown as
the web page insert off the default page
our task is to save files in s3 and move
them to the ec2 instance so s3 is going
to act as a storage or a repository or a
source code control in this example all
right so let's do that all right the
third step is to create your ec2
instance and that's what we have done
and the ec2 instance has no files in it
and the fourth step is to synchronize
the source code bucket with the ec2
instance let's do that the actual
command to do that would be aws s3 sync
and then the name of the bucket from
which we're going to pull the code and
the folder in which we're going to put
the code or the data all right so it has
downloaded something look at that and
now if we go back to the test page and
do a refresh there you go it's showing
the page that it pulled from s3 so here
i can use s3 as the source code control
bucket and any information that i put in
there will get reflected in ec2 instance
once i do a sync every day and that's
how i use s3 as my storage for ec2
alright finally we were able to
synchronize s3 bucket and the ec2
instance and we were also able to view
the results in the web browser of the
ec2 instance the data was copied from s3
to the ec2 instance and that we were
able to view from the web browser aws
azure and gcp are three of the world's
largest cloud service providers but how
are they different from each other let's
find out hey guys i'm rahul and i'll be
representing amazon web services i'm
chinmay and i'll be representing
microsoft azure and i am shruti and i'll
be representing google cloud platform
so welcome to this video on aws versus
azure versus gcp talking about market
share amazon web services leads with
around 32 percent of the worldwide
public cloud share azure owns up to 16
of the worldwide market share and gcp
owns around nine percent of the world's
market share let's talk about each of
these service providers in detail aws
provides services that enable users to
create and deploy applications over the
cloud these services are accessible via
the internet aws being the oldest of the
lot was launched in the year 2006. azure
launched in 2010 is a computing platform
that offers a wide range of services to
build manage and deploy applications on
the network using tools and frameworks
launched in the year 2008 gcp offers
application development and integration
services for its end users in addition
to cloud management it also offers
services for big data machine learning
and iot now let's talk about
availability zones these are isolated
locations within data center regions
from which public cloud services
originate and operate talking about aws
they have 69 availability zones within
22 geographical regions this includes
regions in the united states south
america europe and asia pacific they are
also predicted to have 12 more additions
in the future azure available in 140
countries has over 54 regions worldwide
grouped into six geographies these
geographical locations have more than
100 data centers gcp is available in 200
plus countries across the world as of
today gcp is present in 61 zones and 20
regions with osaka and zurich being the
newly added regions now let's talk about
pricing these services follow the
pay-as-you-go approach you pay only for
the individual services you need for as
long as you use them without requiring
long-term contracts or complex licensing
now on screen you can see the pricing
for each of these cloud service
providers with respect to various
instances like general purpose compute
optimized memory optimized and gpu now
let's talk about the compute services
offered first off we have virtual
servers for aws we have ec2 it is a web
service which eliminates the need to
invest in hardware so that you can
develop and deploy applications in a
faster manner it provides virtual
machines in which you can run your
applications azure's virtual machines is
one of the several types of computing
resources that azure offers azure gives
the user the flexibility to deploy and
manage a virtual environment inside a
virtual network gcp's vm service enables
users to build deploy and manage virtual
machines to run workloads on the cloud
now let's talk about the pricing of each
of these services aws cc2 is free to try
it is packaged as part of aws's free
tier that lasts for 12 months and
provides 750 hours per month of both
linux and windows virtual machines azure
virtual machine service is a part of the
free tier that offers this service for
about 750 hours per month for a year the
user gets access to windows and linux
virtual machines gcp's vm service is a
part of a free tier that includes micro
instance per month for up to 12 months
now let's talk about platform as a
service or past services for aws elastic
bean stock is an easy to use service for
deploying and scaling web applications
and services developed with java dot net
node.js python and much more it is used
for maintaining capacity provisioning
load balancing auto scaling and
application health monitoring the pass
backbone utilizes virtualization
techniques where the virtual machine is
independent of the actual hardware that
hosts it hence the user can write
application code without worrying about
the underlying hardware google app
engine is a cloud computing platform as
a service which is used by developers
for hosting and building apps in google
data centers the app engine requires the
apps to be written in java or python and
store data in google bigtable and use
the google query language for this next
let's talk about virtual private server
services aws provides light sale it
provides everything you need to build an
application or a website along with the
cost-effective monthly plan and minimum
number of configurations in simple words
vm image is a more comprehensive image
for microsoft azure virtual machines it
helps the user create many identical
virtual machines in a matter of minutes
unfortunately gcp does not offer any
similar service next up we have
serverless computing services aws has
lambda it is a serverless compute
service that lets you run your code
without facilitating and managing
servers you only pay for the compute
time you use it is used to execute
backend code and scales automatically
when required azure functions is a
serverless compute service that lets you
run even triggered code without having
to explicitly provision or manage
infrastructure this allows the users to
build applications using serverless
simple functions with the programming
language of their choice gcp cloud
functions make it easy for developers to
run and scale code in the cloud and
build image driven serverless
applications it is highly available and
fault tolerant now let's talk about
storage services offered by each of
these service providers first off we
have object storage aws provides s3 it
is an object storage that provides
industry standard scalability data
availability and performance it is
extremely durable and can be used for
storing as well as recovering
information or data from anywhere over
the internet blob storage is an azure
feature that lets developers store
unstructured data in microsoft's cloud
platform along with storage it also
offers scalability it stores the data in
the form of tears depending on how often
data is being accessed google cloud
storage is an online storage web service
for storing and accessing data on google
cloud platform infrastructure unlike the
google drive google cloud storage is
more suitable for enterprises it also
stores objects that are organized into
buckets amazon provides ebs or elastic
block store it provides high performance
block storage and is used along with ec2
instances for workloads that are
transaction or throughput intensive
azure managed disk is a virtual hard
disk you can think of it like a physical
disk in an on-premises server but
virtualized these managed disks allow
the users to create up to 10 000 vm
disks in a single subscription
persistent storage is a data storage
device that retains data after power to
the device is shut off google persistent
disk is durable and high performance
block storage for gcp persistent disk
provides storage which can be attached
to instances running in either google
compute engine or kubernetes engine next
up we have disaster recovery services
aws provides a cloud-based recovery
service that ensures that your it
infrastructure and data are recovered
while minimizing the amount of downtime
that could be experienced site recovery
helps ensure business continuity by
keeping business apps and workloads
running during outages it allows
recovery by orchestrating and automating
the replication process of azure virtual
machines between regions unfortunately
gcp has no disaster recovery service
next let's talk about database services
first off for aws we have rds or
relational database service it is a web
service that's cost effective and
automates administration tasks basically
it simplifies the setup operation and
scaling of a relational database
microsoft azure sql database is a
software as a service platform that
includes built-in intelligence that
learns app patterns and adapts to
maximize performance reliability and
data protection it also eases the
migration of sql server databases
without changing the user's applications
cloud sql is a fully managed database
service which is easy to set up maintain
and administer relational postgresql
mysql and sql server databases in the
cloud hosted on gcp cloud sql provides a
database infrastructure for applications
running anywhere next we have nosql
database services aws provides dynamodb
which is a managed durable database that
provides security backup and restore and
in-memory caching for applications it is
well known for its low latency and
scalable performance azure cosmos db is
microsoft's globally distributed
multi-model database service it natively
supports nosql it natively supports
nosql created for low latency and
scalable applications gcp cloud data
store is a nosql database service
offered by google on the gcp it handles
replication and scales automatically to
your application's load with cloud data
stores interface data can easily be
accessed by any deployment target now
let's talk about the key cloud tools for
each of these service providers for aws
in networking and content delivery we
have aws route 53 and aws cloud front
for management we have aws cloud
cloudwatch in aws cloud formation for
development we have aws code start and
aws code build for security we have iam
and key management service for microsoft
azure networking and content delivery we
have content delivery network and
express root for management tools we
have azure advisor and network watcher
for development tools for management we
for development we have visual studio
ide and azure blob studio for security
we have azure security center and azure
active directory for gcp we have the
following tools for networking and
content delivery we have cloud cdn and
cloud dns for management we have stack
driver and gcp monitoring for
development we have cloud build and
cloud sdk and finally for secure
ebay fujitsu emc and bmw among others
use microsoft azure so as seen on your
screens the companies that use gcp are
spotify hsbc snapchat twitter paypal and
20th century fox let's talk about the
advantages of each of these services
amazon provides enterprise friendly
services you can leverage amazon's 15
years of experience delivering
large-scale global infrastructure and it
still continues to hone and innovate its
infrastructure management skills and
capabilities secondly it provides
instant access to resources aws is
designed to allow application providers
isvs and vendors to quickly and securely
host your applications whether an
existing application or a new sas based
application speed and agility aws
provides you access to its services
within minutes all you need to select is
what you require and you can proceed you
can access each of these applications
anytime you need them and finally it's
secure and reliable amazon enables you
to innovate and scale your application
in a secure environment it secures and
hardens your infrastructure more
importantly it provides security at a
cheaper cost than on-premise
environments now talking about some of
the advantages of azure microsoft azure
offers better development operations it
also provides strong security profile
azure has a strong focus on security
following the standard security model of
detect assess diagnose stabilize and
close azure also provides a
cost-effective solution the cloud
environment allows businesses to launch
both customer applications and internal
apps in the cloud which saves an id
infrastructure costs hence it's opex
friendly let's now look at the
advantages of gcp google builds in
minute level increments so you only pay
for the compute time you use they also
provide discounted prices for
long-running workloads for example you
use the vm for a month and get a
discount gcp also provides live
migration of virtual machines live
migration is the process of moving a
running vm from one physical server to
another without disrupting its
availability to the users this is a very
important differentiator for google
cloud compared to other cloud providers
gcp provides automatic scalability this
allows a size container scale to as many
cpus as needed google cloud storage is
designed for 99.9 durability it creates
server backup and stores them in an user
configured location let's talk about the
disadvantages of each of these services
for aws there's a limitation of the ec2
service aws provides limitations on
resources that vary from region to
region there may be a limit to the
number of instances that can be created
however you can request for these limits
to be increased secondly they have a
technical support fee aws charges you
for immediate support and you can opt
for any of these packages developer
which costs 29 dollars per month
business which costs more than hundred
dollars an enterprise that costs more
than fifteen thousand dollars it has
certain network connectivity issues it
also has general issues when you move to
the cloud like downtime limited control
backup protection and so on however most
of these are temporary issues and can be
handled over time talking about some of
the disadvantages of microsoft azure
code base is different when working
offline and it requires modification
when working on the cloud pass echo
system is not as efficient as iaas azure
management console is frustrating to
work with it is slow to respond and
update and requires far too many clicks
to achieve simple tasks azure backup is
intended for backing up and restoring
data located on your on-premises servers
to the cloud that's a great feature but
it's not really useful for doing bare
metal restores of servers in a remote
data center let's now look into the
disadvantages of gcp so when it comes to
cloud providers the support fee is very
minimal but in the case of gcp it is
quite costly it is around 150 dollars
per month for the most basic service
similar to aws s3 gcp has a complex
pricing schema also it is not very
budget friendly when it comes to
downloading data from google cloud
storage today we're going to delve into
git and what it actually is and how it
fits within your devops stack so a
little scenario before using get one of
the challenges that a lot of developers
and development teams would have had is
developers would be working on different
types of code whether it was database
code whether it was python or whether
it's java or net and they would have a
central server that they'd be pushing
all of their source code in but there
was little or no communication that was
actually going on in between all the
developers you know the challenge you
had with that scenario is that when
people would be checking in code you
could be like you know there'll be
conflicts and you'd have to roll back
different code versions and this is
really kind of the challenge that git
addresses get is a tool that allows all
of the developers no matter what stack
they're working in to have access to all
of the code and it makes it much more
effective at being able to have
development teams work on small medium
or even massive applications and some of
the biggest applications out there are
managed through a get distributed server
environment
so let's jump into what we'll be
covering so you have a clear
understanding of the value that you're
going to get out of watching this
presentation so we're going to go
through devops and the tools have
available for devops we'll talk about
what version control means within a
devops environment and cover the two
different types of version control
centralized and distributed and then
we're going to zero in on git which is a
really fantastic distributed version
control system and we're going to go
through understand the features workflow
branches and commands in git we can give
you a demo and then summarize all the
activities at the end of the the
presentation so what is devops well this
is one of my favorite questions i love
the idea of what devops is so devops
really is a culture of being able to
deliver solutions faster where your
development teams and your operation
teams work effectively together the idea
is to be able to continuously build out
solutions and have testing codes that's
built into your solutions so that no
matter where they are in the stage of
the integration and deployment life
cycle they're always being tested and
you can always have code being ready to
be released out the idea is that instead
of having big releases that you'd have
maybe once every two weeks or once a
month that you would actually have a
continuous stream of releases because
you always have code that is being
tested you have your network that's been
tested you have your environment being
tested and you'll be able to provide
feedback directly to the appropriate
person whether they're in devs or
whether they're in ops to be able to be
successful at being able to deliver
solutions faster the bottom line your
dev team things like operations and your
operations team begin to feel like think
like developers it's really a fantastic
way of being able to speed up delivery
and have your team just think and feel
and act in a different cultural
environment so let's have a look at some
of the tools that are available to you
in devops environments if we look at
devops it's really kind of split into
two areas the dev side you have building
code planning and testing and then on
your upside you have release deployment
operating and monitoring but the tools
really all interact with each other and
what's really great is that the tools
are either open source or very very low
in cost in fact most of the tools you're
seeing in front of you right now are
open source tools which means there's no
licensing to you and you can actually
effectively manage them and implement
them within your team right now so let's
have a look at some of the dev tools
that you have for doing code versioning
and so some of the tools that you may
have used in the past include subversion
team foundation service and git these
are all different types of version
control software that you have out there
one of the oldest ones is subversion
it's a centralized version control
system it's one of the tools i used
years ago it really is good at doing
what it's supposed to do which is just a
very simple version controlled solution
it's open source so it's free and
there's no licensing there are
challenges with working with it because
it is a centralized tool rather than a
distributed tool we'll get into that in
a little bit but for a very basic
version control system you know it does
what you wanted to do team foundation
service solutions something that many of
you in microsoft world may be using for
a long time and the thing that's great
about tfs is it's built right into the
microsoft environment it's the server
side the services side of building out
your solutions with microsoft um just
recently in the last couple of weeks at
the beginning of september 2018.
microsoft actually just rebranded tfs as
azure devops and so you have azure
pipelines and there are five now azure
tools that you replace tfs but these are
all tools that are very similar in
concept the old tfs tools are very
similar to the centralized svn tools
whereas the new tools that are part of
azure are actually much more aligned
with git so what you're seeing is
microsoft moving from the centralized
server to a distributed server with
their new azure devops tools which is
fantastic news for every developer
listening to this and then we have get
and get is a distributed version control
system it is again open source which
means that you can start using it right
now without fear of having to have any
costs or any penalties and the thing
that's really good about it is that it's
really you can use it for almost any
kind of digital project and what it's
good at is being able to create that
historical record and versioning of your
source code whether you're doing a web
application a mobile application or
you're actually building a python script
for a machine learning solution so let's
dig into what version control systems
are and how they can be of value to you
so the role of version control system is
to allow developers to be able to check
in their files into a repository and
here you can actually see how we can
check in three files into a repository
and that repository then becomes a
snapshot or a historical record of the
files that we're working on and you want
to be able to have it so that the
repository is flexible enough so that as
you want to be able to scale and add in
new files or new versions of a file that
you can actually do that easily within
your vcs environment and the goal is to
be able to constantly have each of these
versions available so that anybody wants
to be able to check out the file can
actually have the latest version or see
a history of how that file became what
it is today let's look at centralized
version control systems and then we'll
compare it against distributed version
control systems so a centralized version
control system has a central server
where all the files are stored and
everybody has to check in and check out
from that centralized server and all of
the versions are managed within that
server environment
the problem is is that if that central
server crashes which doesn't happen but
very often but it can happen you end up
losing all of your files and i was
actually on a project where that
actually happened to us and we lost six
months of history of how the application
was created fortunately for us we
actually had a backup but it didn't have
all the historical data so we were able
to at least continue working but we just
lost a lot of files and it took a while
to get back into place so let's now look
at and compare this to a distributed
version control system with a
distributed version control system you
still have a centralized server that
manages the files but the difference is
is that as a developer you check out all
of the files for a project so you can
actually manage the whole project
locally on your develop machine and make
your changes and then you can just check
in and out the changes that you've made
to the centralized server the
opportunity you have here is that the
server itself if it goes down you're not
going to be in a situation where you
lose all of the history because
everybody that's working on the actual
application has all of the versions of
the code locally on their machine
now one of the more popular distributed
version control systems that out there
is git i mean it really is probably the
most popular buyer margin compared to a
system out there so you know let's dig
into you know what actually is git so
git is a version control system for
managing files and as a developer you
have a git client on your machine and
you're able to make changes and create
local repositories of a program on your
computer and then you can sync up with a
remote service such as github or git lab
or the new azure labs environment where
you can actually store files remotely
and then allow remote teams to have
access to
those changes in the actual application
you made so you can track your changes
easily you have it's the the tool is
inherently distributed so it makes it
very easy to manage the code for large
teams and you can bring people in very
quickly and you can have people come in
as specialists and spin them up quickly
and have them work on a piece of the
code and then drop them out of the
project if you want to have a check on
how this works go and start contributing
to any of the the many thousands of open
source projects at github where you can
go in with your get tools and just
contribute to those projects
and then finally one of the things that
i really like with git is that it's not
a linear development approach it's not
starting from a and going to z it's a
non-linear approach which allows you to
have branches that people are working on
in parallel to your master branch where
people are actually doing the delivery
of the production code so let's step
through some of these features
so get as you can imagine the first
thing it does is track history that's
probably the most important part of
having a version control system it's a
free open source you can actually go and
use it right now there are no costs of
actually using it it is a non-linear
environment that allows people to be
able to build out new features in
parallel to the master branch so that
you can be constantly having the master
code out there without and adding in new
features without breaking the code and
you can automatically create backups by
because a developer has a version of the
code remotely it's incredibly scalable
some of the biggest projects out there
now are being managed through git and
because of this scale the collaboration
becomes a byproduct of teams working
together and branching just is so much
easier within git so as you can see this
whole thing leads to a very effective
distributed environment
so let's step through some of the the
workflow that we have available for git
so the way that git works is that
you as an operator as a developer you
have the git client on your local
development machine whether it's a linux
machine a mac or a pc and you connect to
a remote server and you pull down the
latest working copy and then you're able
to make all of your changes uh locally
and you can modify the codes you can
review changes and you can commit those
codes to your get repository that you
have locally and then you can push those
changes back up to the remote server and
as soon as you push them into the remote
server those changes then become
available to everybody else working on
the project so they can be constantly
keeping everybody updated on all the
work that is happening so you know
typically the way that it would work is
you know you would start off with having
the working file working directory that
you have locally then you would stage
those files into a staging area and then
you get those files ready to be
committed to your git repository and
these are all actions that you would do
locally and then connect to a remote
server and then later when you go back
into work on your project the first
thing you should always do is check out
that code so you always have the latest
version of the code and everybody is
kept in sync so let's talk about
branching in git so the way that
branches work is that if you imagine
you're working on a project and projects
always have a tendency of getting bigger
than you imagine and what you want to be
able to do is keep that main product
working and keeping it working
effectively but if you want to be able
to add a feature to that product you may
have two or three different groups that
are working on multiple features
simultaneously and what you want to be
able to do is give them the freedom to
work on those individual features and
the way you do it in git is that you can
create branches off the master and while
you're off the the main branch which is
called the master and so each person
could be working on their own separate
branch and then when they want to they
can then later merge those branches back
into the main master and all this time
the main master still works and still
able to produce the right code for the
customer but at the same time it allows
the developers the freedom to be able to
write in their new features and so we
can look at this in a little bit more
visually with the master branch and we
can put in small features of large
features and we can then merge them back
as we need to so this kind of covers
some of the commands that we have in git
so the first command you'd want to use
is called git init and that's allowing
you to go into a folder on your local pc
and or your local mac and convert that
file that folder into a local git
repository and that creates that
repository then you want to be able to
make changes to that repository and the
commands you'd be using in this instance
would be add commit or status and you
want to be able to sync your
repositories with the remote server so
be able to put the code that you have on
your computer on the remote server you
just push you're going to get the code
from the remote server you'd use pull
and then add origin and then if you want
to do parallel development from the
master branch the main branch you would
use branch merge or rebase as ways to be
able to do parallel development and now
we're going to go through and do a demo
on git so we're going to do a demo on
git so you can feel comfortable running
the commands in the interface and you're
able to get get running correctly in
your environment so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to set
up which version of git that you have
and then we're going to see if we can
establish some global configurations
within your git environment and we're
going to do sandeep.dash as the name the
email address is sandeep.simplyline and
then we're going to do a list of the
different configuration settings we have
so to check the version of git that we
have we do
get dash dash version in our terminal or
command line window you can also use
powershell that'll actually get you
running in the same environment as well
all of these tools are going to be
command line tools and then the next
thing we're going to do is we're going
to assign some global usernames and a
global email address and so that we can
actually access the git account itself
locally on the device and so we're going
to dash and we're going to put in config
dash global user dot name sandeep and
then a git config
global user.email and
sandeep.d
at
simplylearn.net and now we're going to
check the list of usernames and email
ids in our configuration environment
with dash list and you'll see that we
have everything in there correctly here
is our username right here and our name
and our email id so if you need any help
when you're actually doing any of your
work in get all you have to do is to get
help config or get config dash help and
this will allow you to actually get
access to the help screens so let's just
go and type that in git help config
return and this takes us to the help
page that's running locally on your
device and here we have a breakdown of
all the different commands and what
those commands actually do within a git
configuration
and we can go ahead and we can do git
config dash help and that will actually
take us to the same page so two ways of
doing the same thing so we're gonna go
ahead and we're gonna create a test
repository on our local system and we're
gonna do that with make directory called
test and then we're going to move our
cursor within command window terminal
window to the test folder and then we're
going to initialize that folder to
become a get repository so let's go
ahead and do that so we're going to make
a new directory and we're going to call
it test and we're going to move the
cursor so it's actually in the test
folder we do cd change directory to test
and you can see now we're actually in
the test folder and now what we have to
do is initialize this folder as a get
repository and so we're going to do this
as git init and it's now a new git
instance that we can actually now use
for managing our git environment so
we're going to create a new file and
we're going to call it info.txt and
we're going to put some content in it
and we're actually going to put it in
the folder that we've just created so
you can actually see what it's like to
test out the git environment with a file
that hasn't been checked into it yet so
let's go ahead and do that so we open up
our folder directory and here you can
see we have the test folder and we're
just going to go ahead and create a
default test file so right click text
new document info.txt open that and
we'll just you can put really whatever
you want in here we're just going to put
in this information right now name
equals sam registration number
one two
four seven nine and save that file close
it out now if we actually go ahead and
run a get status command you'll see that
the info.txt file is in red that's
because that file has not actually been
checked into the project it's a new file
that we've added but hasn't been
committed yet into the git repository so
let's go ahead and see what it takes to
actually add the file to the git
repository that we just created so we're
going to do that by doing git add
info.txt and then we're going to commit
that into the history of that git
repository so we can do so it now has a
version control and we can start doing
forking and other kind of similar
activities when we connect later to our
github git environment so we do get add
info.txt
and remember we're actually still in the
test folder so it's going to look for
that file in that folder and just add it
in and now if we go ahead and do git
status we'll actually be able to see
that the info.txt file is in
an active color first of all we have to
commit it so we go get commit dash m and
then we're going to commit and we add in
some quick text so you can write
whatever you want committing the text
file is now actually committed into the
git repository and it's all running
locally on your pc so we're gonna go
make some changes to the file and we're
gonna save it and we want to be able to
see how we can use git to compare the
differences between the two files so
let's go over and we're going to make
some changes to the info.txt file here
we are here's info.txt which is going to
add in a new line we're going to add in
the line address and we'll save that
file and now when we go over to get
we're going to be able to review the
difference so we're going to do git diff
and here you actually see that we've
added in a new address file so now you
can actually see this is the difference
and the difference between the two
documents now as you can imagine when
you have code this could become more
elaborate where actually it will show
you code that's been pulled out if
you've reduced any of eliminated code or
if you added any new code really useful
so we're going to go ahead and add our
get username to a remote location so we
can actually start testing out the
file that we've created into a remote
repository in this case we're going to
use github and you'll be able to see how
we can actually then save that file into
a git repository that somebody else
could then access and be able to make
edits to so let's just go ahead and make
those changes so get config dash global
user dot username and we do simply learn
and that will associate it with this uh
git repository that we just created
locally so simply on github so simply
learn github is the username that we use
on github so we're gonna go over to
github here we are in github and then
correct new repository
and then as you can see with simp so
we're in simply learn dash github and
we're going to call the new proprietary
test we're going to make it public so
anybody can access it and you'll see
that it automatically adds a readme file
and we have our test environment set up
correctly so we'll go ahead and copy the
url link which is github.com simply
learn dash github forward slash test.get
copy that and we'll go back over to our
command line window and so now we're
going to add the username to the github
configuration so what we're doing is
we're connecting the local repository to
the remote repository so we type get
remote add origin and then we'll paste
in the address and this then allows us
to connect the local repository that we
created in the test folder with the
remote repository and now we're
connected so now that we've connected we
can actually push the file that you have
in the local repository on your pc or
mac to the remote repository in the
github server environment so let's go
ahead and do that so we do get push and
push is the command to push the
documents from the origin which is the
local file to master and master the
remote file hey and there we are success
so what we have now is the file that we
just created in our local get repository
is actually now in the remote repository
as well so anybody can access it so
let's go have a look at that so we're
going to refresh the github page and hey
there we are there's info.txt
has been uploaded and we're ready to go
that's great that's uh that's what you
should be seeing so refreshing your web
page on the remote github folder and it
could be any gate service which just
happened to be using github because it's
free to use you'll be able to see that
the local file has been installed and is
now part of the get repository in the
remote server so what we're going to do
now is we're going to create three more
files and we're just going to call them
info.txt info 2 and info 3. and then
we're going to push them out to the
remote server and we're going to merge
everything together into a single
environment so let's go ahead and create
those three files and we're just going
to add those into the folder so let's go
ahead create new text document info one
and then we're gonna create info two and
then info
three look at my typing right here okay
here we go there we are
okay i'm opening info three and i'm just
going to enter some text in here and
what we're going to do is illustrate how
we can do branching and each of these
files i'm going to save and then close
out and now i can go over and so let's
create a new branch and we're going to
call this one first underscore branch
there we go git branch first underscore
branch and this will be a new branch of
the code environment that we're creating
and so hit return and that allows us to
create a new branch and so what we do is
we're going to move to the new branch so
we're going to do git check out first
underscore branch and that allows us to
move into that branch and you'll see
that info.txt um is already there which
is good that's what we want to see now
what we need to do is um add in the new
documents so here we have the different
steps we've taken we created a branch we
moved to the new branch and now we're
going to go ahead and add the info three
txt to that branch so you can actually
see everything coming together and we're
going to go it get add info three txt so
we're just adding a file like we were
previously with our initialization our
first initial git folder and that file
has now been added to the first branch
so we're going to go ahead and commit
the file to the first branch and then
we're going to merge the documents into
the master branch so we have everything
together so let's go ahead and do those
steps we're going to do the commit first
and then we're going to merge everything
together all right so we do get
commit dash m and we just put in we're
just going to say uh made changes to
first branch and that's just uh
documentation so that we know what we've
done and there we are we've uh committed
the file so we had
that file info 3 txt committed and now
we're going to go ahead and merge the
files into the main master and
so we can actually have everything
together as one consistent environment
and we do that by typing in so this
lists out what we have in our master
file so we just do ls and that shows
everything in the folder and we have
info.txt
info 1 txt info 2 txt and info 3 txt are
now all in the first branch so let's go
ahead and we're going to merge okay so
actually before we merge we have to
check out the master branch so we do get
checkout master so it gets us into the
master branch and you'll see that we
have just one file on there info.txt so
we're going to list out the files in the
master branch and so so what you'll see
is info.txt info one text and info two
texts are there but
info.info three text isn't there because
that was created in a separate bunch so
let's go ahead and merge the first
branch into the master branch so we do
get merge and we do first underscore
branch and there we are we've merged it
in and
accidentally looks good so let's go
ahead and list out the files that we
have in the master branch and we do ls
and then you'll see that we have four
files including the info three dot text
so we had it in a separate branch now
all in the master branch welcome to good
commands kit is one of the most popular
distributed version control tools of
recent times and like any other
distributed version control tool it
allows us to perform various version
control tasks without really needing a
network connection before i jump into my
demonstration let me spend some time
explaining to you the git client server
working model what does it take for a
couple of users to collaborate and start
working with git the bare minimal thing
that any user would need in order to
start working with kit is something
called as git bash or the git client
this comes as an installer for all
popular operating systems like windows
all flavors of windows linux mac os and
other operating systems so once you
install git bash you get a command line
utility using which you can fire up your
git commands and ensure that you can
bring up repositories you can work with
these repositories by adding files to it
committing changes to it and all those
git commands would work perfectly well
so you can bring up a small repository
and you can work with your repository
using this git bash but what does it
take for you to share this repository
with another user who has also got git
bash installed on his system this is
where you would need something called as
a gig server
so for user one or one user to share his
repository with another user he would
need to collaborate using something
called as a git server so in the present
market there are a bunch of git servers
which are popularly available some of
them are free some of them come with
cost because they are licensed a bunch
of these servers that i can think of are
github which is one of the most popular
kit servers that is around in the market
for a long time now it comes with two
variants one is the cloud hosted one
which is the github.com and then the
other one is an enterprise server which
comes as a black box that can be
installed into your data centers so
typically organizations who don't want
their source code to be put up on the
cloud but go for this github enterprise
servers wherein they buy these servers
and these servers are hosted on their
data centers other popular variant of
the git server is big bucket this is
from the famous atlassian products and
it integrates very well with all other
atlassian products like jira in recent
times there's one other variant of the
git server called gitlab which is
getting very very popular these days
because gitlab not just provides a git
server it also provides something called
as a runner this is a part of the
continuous integration strategy where as
soon as you have a source code check-in
that is going in you have this runner
that kicks up and builds your particular
project so all these are bundled
together in a gitlab and gitlab also
provides you with a community edition
which is almost free of cost having said
that there are a bunch of these tools
available for my demonstration what i'm
going to do is i've already registered
myself on the github.com by providing my
username and my password and i'm going
to use a free account so whatever
repositories that i'm going to put up on
this server is all public by default so
i will register myself by using my
username or my email id and my password
so this set of authentication is also
referred to as https authentication
so in order for me to share my
repository with say user2 the first
thing that i got to do was have an
access to a git server where both user 1
and user 2 are set up so once i have
that i can push my repository onto this
server and provide right kind of access
so that user 2 or the other developer
who wishes to collaborate with me on
this repository can use his credentials
as long as he's registered properly on
the git server he can use his
credentials and pull down this
repository and work with this repository
so this is the https way of
authenticating and sharing repositories
another popular way of sharing
repositories or working with each other
is called as ssh authentication as many
of you would know ssh means nothing but
creation of a private and a public key a
bunch of keys public and private are
created on the client machine while i
create a keys i will be asked for a
passphrase i need to type in a
passphrase and remember my passphrase
and then i take this public key and kind
of post it onto my account within my git
server so that whenever i'm going to
connect next time using my command
prompt or any of the tools it's going to
challenge me for my passphrase as long
as i remember my phrase correctly i can
authenticate myself and get into the
server so both https and ssh are popular
ways of communicating with the git
server having said this let me just get
started by installing the git bash on my
local system and then fire up some of
these git commands and build up some
repositories make some changes in my
repository commit these changes and
later use my github credential to
connect to my github server and push my
repositories out there
let me now go ahead and find my git bash
for my windows so that i can go ahead
and install it so i just type in get
client for
windows open up a browser and type in
for this the first one that i find as a
gui tool i don't need this gui client i
need this one
so this is the git client or the git
bash that i was referring to it's about
40 megs and let me just download this
pause this video for some time so that
the download happens and come back to
you once i have the download the
download seems to be complete when i'm
recording this video the version that i
have the latest version that is there is
2.19.0 and this is a 64-bit version for
windows so i've got that downloaded let
me go ahead and find it and install this
exe
all right i go ahead choosing all the
default options i want it to be
installed in c colon program files under
the git folder
everything looks good for me i'm not
going to make any changes here
get bash from windows yes i may want to
use git from windows command prompt that
sounds good for me open ssh that's fine
good looks good
no i don't want any of these new
features
so what i'm doing is installing the git
bash or the git client so that i can
start using my git commands
the version that i'm using is 2.19.0
which as i record this video this
happens to be the latest version
all right so looks good i don't want to
see the release notes i'll say launch
git bash
so what i get is this window so this is
the git command prompt so let me check
if
everything is looking good say get
version it sounds good say get
help all right a lot of git help
commands
everything looks good so
i ended up installing the git bash i can
go ahead with all other commands
now that i have git bash installed on my
system let me open up a git bash prompt
and start using it but before i do
anything i just need to configure it for
the first time stating what would be the
username and the email id with which i
want the git bash to be configured with
the command to do that is get config
iphone iphone global which means that
this setting that i'm going to set would
be a global setting user dot name and
this the name of the user would need to
be specified within a double quote in my
case i am using the simplylearn account
which is the official account and this
is the particular username of this
account the other setting is nothing but
git config hyphen f1 global this is also
global setting
and this would be the email id
the email id need not contain a double
quote
so in my case this is the email id that
i would be setting up git to work with
all right let me check if the
configurations were set correctly or not
all right if you see this the username
and the email id has been picked up the
way i wanted it to be picked up looks
good so far all right so what do we do
next by default whenever you open up the
git prompt you're placed into your home
directory let me create a folder here
which would be a repository folder from
where i'm going to create all my
multiple git repositories so i will
create a folder called let's say git
underscore demo
all right
there's already a folder called git demo
so let me just delete that in the first
place and let me create this git demo
again
all right let me navigate to this
particular folder
so this is the folder let me open up
that folder using a command prompt
this is my git demo
so this would be a folder so i would use
this folder as a base folder for
creating all other repositories as a
part of this demo so let me create my
first repository a repository is nothing
but a folder so let me create my first
folder called first
repo
and let me
get into this repo all right as of now
this is just an empty folder
if at all i navigate to this you could
see that this folder is empty there's
nothing much in this folder at all at
this moment
okay so let me create a repository out
of this how do i create a repository of
this it's pretty simple i just run and
get init command
when i say git init it means it's going
to initialize a repository as of now
the folder contain nothing on it was an
empty repository so it initialized an
empty repository in this particular
folder if at all i look at my content
you'd see that there's a hidden folder
this would be a hidden folder since i've
configured my explorer to view all
hidden folders i see it otherwise you
wouldn't see it so a folder by name dot
get is created within this first repo
and this was created because we ran the
command kit in it
if i get into this folder i see a bunch
of directories and other configurations
if you see there's something called as a
hooks directory a couple of
configuration files that are here in
this directory all these relate to one
or the other type of a client hook that
can be enabled and this info this
objects
this references a bunch of stuff that is
there
so what is this folder this is a magical
git folder and this is created whenever
a repository is initialized so by
default if at all you get into any git
folder or any git repository you would
see this dot get folder a word of
caution do not get into this folder and
try to modify anything because if you
fiddle around with this and corrupt this
particular folder your whole repository
will go for a toss so let me come out of
this
and let me show you another thing
now if you notice here
when i was in the folder the repository
did not have anything after this now
when i say git in it there is something
called as a master that shows up so
typically what happens is whenever a git
repository is created for the first time
it creates a default branch the name of
the branch is called master and that is
why you would see master within braces
this doesn't mean anything else other
than we have a repository out in this
particular folder and by default there
is a
branch called master and we are
currently on that branch if at all i
create multiple branches in this folder
whenever i navigate to different
branches the branch name within this
brackets would change
all right so far so good so we created a
folder we made it a git repository by
initializing that with the git init and
then i'm not put anything yet in the
repository so let me try to do that let
me create a few files within this
particular repository so i use a touch
command
touch is a linux command it kind of
creates this particular folder if you're
not comfortable with the file creation
by this way you can always use a file
explorer and create some files in this
so i create a file called
touchmaster.txt i'll open up in the
notepad
okay so this is my first file that's
what i'm going to write inside this
i save this and i come out of this all
right now let me do a git status command
so what does this
tell you there's no commit set you're on
the master branch there is an untracked
file and this shows up in red it also
gives you all the commands that is
supposed to be run so if at all you want
to add this file you would say git add
and the name of the file and then you're
going to commit it
so what happened is that when the
repository was initialized it was an
empty repository
now that a git notices that there is a
new file in this repository called
master.txt if at all you want you want
us to let git know that you want to
track this file we need to add this to
the repository so the command to add
that is called git add i can specify
either the name of the file or i can
give a while character saying git add
dot now if i run the git status command
again
it says there's no commits yet
added a file and the file which was
earlier in red now shows up in green and
it says it's a new file master dot text
all right it also gives you something
called git remove command if at all you
want to unstage or undo your changes so
what has happened is the file which was
earlier untracked has been added into
the git index or it is ready for staging
or it's in a staged state now i can go
ahead and commit this file if at all
that's what i want to do so let me do
that
i'll do a git commit minus m and i give
a message that i want i would say this
is my
first
get
commit
all right i run the gate status command
again
and see it says on the branch master
nothing to commit it's all nice and
clean so typically what happened was i
created an empty directory made it into
a git folder by doing a git init i put a
file into it i made some changes to the
file i added that file into the
repository and i committed to the
repository if it error i run the git log
command
it says this was the commit id or the
commit
number or the commit hashtag and this is
the author if you notice this is the
email id and the username that we set
earlier this was done on this date and
this is the
commit message that is there all of it
looks so good let me do one more commit
into this repository so i will touch
master one dot text i'll put in another
file
i'll open up this particular file
write something into this
all right i save this change
let me also open up the older
file make some more change into this
all right so what i did i modified the
older file that existed i also added a
new file to my repository now if i run
the git status command
it says modified this file which is
showing in red and it says you have one
more file which is an untracked file
all right now let me add both these
files because these are the changes that
i want to
incorporate i would say git add dot i
run the git status command again
and it says now this is a modified file
this is a new file looks good to me let
me go ahead and commit this so git
commit with the message that says this
is my second commit
all right
if i do a git log now it shows both the
commits the first command is the one
that that shows up at the bottom and the
topmost one is the latest commit that is
there
so far so good if at all you notice
i'm doing all these git commands without
really connecting it to any git server i
don't need any network connection for
doing any of these things i can keep on
doing more and more git commands and run
git commands the way i want to
without really having any connections to
the git server
now that i have my changes the way i
wanted and i've checked in all the code
changes into my local repository i may
want to share my repository with
somebody else
and work in a collaborative way so the
way to do that is as i mentioned earlier
to host this repository or to push this
repository onto a git server i already
have a github account wherein i've
registered myself using my username and
password so i log into my github account
using my username and credentials and
let me go ahead and create a new
repository
my repository is already there on the
local system so what i essentially need
is just a placeholder for my repository
so that i can link them together and
push the content from my local
repository to the server
if you notice the name of my repository
is this first repo
so let me copy this i will create a
folder structure or a repository
structure on the server with the same
name
so that
when i pushed my repository from my
local box it will go ahead and get
created in the server
so the repository name should be the
same as what i created on my local box
description i would say this is my first
git
hub
repository
on the server
this is just an optional description
that will show up
and if you notice
i can't have any private repositories so
whatever repositories that i'm going to
create here would be a public repository
so i choose public and i don't want to
initialize this with a readme file or
anything of that because i already have
a repository with some content with some
code checked in all that i need is a
placeholder for my repository on the
server
so with this option with just the name
and with an optional description and the
repository being public i go ahead and
click on the create repository button
so if you notice it gives me a bunch of
commands that i would need to run in
order to create a repository and pushed
onto the server
and also important point it shows me two
urls one is the https url and the other
one is the ssh url as of now we do not
have any ssh keys that is set up so let
me use this https url to connect my
local repository with the repository on
the server
so i've done all these things i already
have the repository set up all that i
need is a placeholder for me to connect
my local repository with the server url
so this would be the command that i need
to copy
which essentially links or adds an
origin with the url of the git server i
just copy this command
and run it here
get remote add the name of the remote is
called origin and it points to an https
url which is nothing but the placeholder
that i've created on the server
alright so let me check if it's added
correctly
okay the url looks good i'm all set i've
got two comments in my repository i'm
done with all the changes so let me try
to push my repository onto the server
the command for doing it for the first
time is git push hyphen u this is for
linking the upstream
origin
master
so get push hyphen u upstream linking
origin master link the master
branch of my local repository with the
master branch on the server repository
and where is it going to push it is
going to push by default to an origin
and the origin points to this url
all right let me try doing this
so it essentially opens up an url asking
me the credentials with which i need to
log into my github server so let me just
copy and paste
the username
and the password with which i have
registered
i would say login
okay success
so i'm able to create a repository on
the server and the content seems to be
pushed and it created a new branch
called master it has linked the master
branch from the local repository with
the master branch on the server so let
me go back to my server and refresh this
page
and see if all my commits have come in
master master one dot text if at all i
see the commits there seem to be two
comments this is my first comment this
is my second comment and if at all you
notice each of this commit comes with a
hash key or a hash id which contains the
details of my commits in this commit the
files were added this was a line that
was added if you look at the second
commit
i added these lines
i made this you know one line chain that
was there i also added this new file
which was not existing these are the two
commits that existed
and if you see
the timestamp of the commit
this is the commit which was committed
for 15 minutes ago so what does this
mean is that the commit is the timestamp
when we actually commented the code in
the client the pushing is just after we
have committed the change we pushed it
so there's no time stamp of the push
that happened
this completes the first part of the
tutorial wherein i created repository on
the client and then i pushed it to the
server after creating a repository
skeleton on the server
now let me demonstrate to you the ssh
configuration that is required for
creating a pair of ssh keys and ensuring
that i connect to the github server
using the ssh mechanism so for doing
that i need to first create a pair of
private and public key the command to do
that is ssh keygen
hyphen t i will use the rsa mechanism
for creating my keys capital c and i
need to specify the email id using which
i'm going to connect to or i need to
create the keys for
all right so generating a private and
public key pair it says let me know what
folder should i create the keys in so by
default the keys are created in the user
home directory under a dot ssh folder so
this is pretty good for me so let me go
ahead and say that that's fine enter a
passphrase so let me enter some
passphrase
keep in mind that i would need to
remember my passphrase because when i am
going to authenticate myself using ssh
mechanism it will challenge me for this
particular passphrase i need to enter
the right passphrase so that i get
authenticated
so the key is generated and by default
it is created in this particular folder
so let me go over to that particular
folder
and this is the folder where the keys is
generated you would see a public key and
a private key that is created let me
open up the public key with
a notepad
and then copy the contents of the whole
file
and now i would need to stick it in
on the server so that i can get myself
authenticated using ssh keys so i have
logged in to github using my credentials
and go to my settings
and you will see an ssh and gpg keys let
me click on that as of now there are no
ssh key or gpg keys so i will click on
new ssh key and let me paste my
public key that i've copied
and i would say add ssh key
it prompts me for my password just to
make sure that
i've got the right kind of
authentication to be adding a new key so
this one looks good that means the keys
were added successfully let me check if
my ssh keys are working well
so i do ssh hyphen capital t
i would say git
at
github.com
this is just to double check if my ssh
keys
are authenticated correctly are you sure
you want a connection yes you want to
continue yes
all right now
a check for my passphrase let me enter
my passphrase
i hope i remember it correctly
all right
pretty good i've been successfully
authenticated so that means now my ssh
keys are good and just by using my
passphrase i can connect to my github
server using ssh alright so for the
second use case what i would do is
create a repository on the server
with some content in it and then clone
that repository cloning is nothing but
making a copy of that repository linking
the origin so that i create an exact
replica of the repository which is there
on the server on my local drive so let
me first create a repository on the
server i will create a new repository
let me give a name for my repository and
let me kind of initialize that with the
readme file i would call this my second
repo
give some description
this is my
second repo
that is created
straight
on the git server on the github server
to be precise
it's a public repository this time i'm
going to choose this option the reason
being that i don't want to create just a
skeleton as of now i want to create a
repository with some readme file in it a
random readme file with no content in it
but then i want a repository to be
created on the server all right i say
create a repository
so
a random readme file with some content
in it gets created and i can see there
are two urls to this repository https
and ssh so this time let me copy the ssh
url so that i will use this url to clone
this repository on the server
rather from the server to my local box
all right so let me navigate to my root
folder
the folder that i created for making all
my repositories git repositories if you
see my first deposit is already here so
let me clone my repository the second
repo that i created on the server the
command to do that is get clone the url
of the repository that i want to clone
oops
looks like i didn't copy the url
correctly let me copy that again
copy this url
all right so if you notice there is no
https to it i'm just cloning the url
that is ssh url of the
repository it asks for my passphrase
again
okay
so i just had first repository earlier
now i have something called a second
repo this is an exact replica of
whatever was the repository content that
was created on the server so if i get
into
the repository there is just a simple
readme file that is there let me try to
add a new file out here i would say
notepad
second.txt
some text file i'm going to put in here
yes definitely you will not find that
file there
this is my second
file that
i will push onto the server
i'm going to put in some content out
there
i'm going to save this
and if i do get status
it says this this is a new untracked
file do you want to add this file onto
the repository do you want to track this
file yes i definitely want to track this
file let me also commit my change to the
file
with the message
this is my first commit for the second
repo
i'm giving some particular message
and this time around since i cloned my
repository from a server
the origin is already set for me i don't
really need to
add the origin and all that stuff
because what happened in the first case
was that i was creating a repository
from my local box and then pushing
another server which is why i had to set
up the upstream branches and stuff like
that in this case i have cloned an
existing repository from the server so
when i clone i get the replica along
with all references to my repository so
i don't need to do anything more other
than push the content i will just say
git push to be on the safer side i would
say origin and master
ask me for the passphrase
okay it post the content onto the server
let me see if the contents have come in
here
okay wonderful i had only one comment
now i see my second comment so what was
added as a part of the second comment it
says a new file was added all this line
that never existed got added this is the
second file the content exactly what i
pushed onto the server
now this completes the tutorial
when i create a repository on the server
cloned it made some changes to the
repository and pushed it to the server
using ssh
a quick recap of all the git commands
that we ran till now git init is used to
initialize a repository so if at all
you're creating a local repository you
can get into any of the folder which is
not a git repository and run this
command whenever you run this command a
magical folder by name dot kit gets
created in the folder and from that time
onwards git will start tracking any
changes that happen to that particular
folder it also creates a new repository
and a branch by default the branch that
is created is called the master branch
git add dot is a wildcard character for
adding any number of new files into your
git repository if you have a bunch of
files one file two file ten files a
folder containing multiple files in it
all of them could be added into the
repository using this command so once
you add any number of files into the
repository you can keep on adding more
and more files into the repository once
you're done with that you want to commit
the changes that has happened in the
repository you use the git commit
command git commit hyphen m with a
meaningful message
this will commit all the work items that
you have done in terms of the files that
got changed the files that got added all
this with one particular message git
status will give you the status of all
the files and folders any file that got
added any file that got created any file
that was deleted all the status of the
files will be obtained using the git
status command git log will show you all
the commit history with the latest
history or the latest commit showing up
on top git add remote origin this
command is used whenever you want to
link any local repository to a server
and this is when you want to really push
a repository from the local to the
server for the first time git push
hyphen u origin and master this is the
command that you would use whenever you
want to push contents from the local
repository to the server git clone and
the url of the server this is the
command that you will run whenever you
have an existing repository on the
server and you want to make a fresh
clone or a fresh copy of that particular
repository onto your local box
more than often many developers or gate
users find themselves in situations
where they would want to go back in
history and modify
or change some of the files that they
recently committed or checked into the
repository now from a perspective of
gate this is a very very simple activity
however from a perspective version
control tool you will have to be really
cautious about the change that you're
gonna do in case the changes are pretty
local none of the developers or none of
the other users who are collaborating
with you would be affected by this
change you're good to go ahead and make
this change however if your repository
has been pushed to the server and you're
trying to modify something from history
this would have a very bad or adverse
effect on all the other users who'll be
using it you need to be really cautious
while running these commands in case
your repository contents are local you
have not pushed your changes to your
repository and if at all you made some
changes to the repository maybe to fix a
defect or to include a new feature and
you missed few things you can go ahead
and modify this with some of these
commands let's say i have this simple
repository called undo undo repo and if
at all i look at the logs of these i
have the commit histories which are like
this
i have about five commits that is there
in my repository and in c1 i've added a
file in c2 i've added another file in c3
i've also added some file in c4 i made
some changes to m1 and m3 and in c5 i've
added another file called m4 now this is
my commit history now let's say i made
these two comments but possibly i want
to club them together along with some
other changes because whatever changes i
did did not really fix things the way i
expected it to fix so there is a git
command called git reset this would
allow me to go back in history to go
back to any of the snapshot get rid of
all this commit history on the commit
messages but retain the changes that
were made as a part of these comments so
if at all i need to go back in history
and go back to this particular commit
and however i just want to get rid of
these commits that are there in terms of
the commit messages but i want the
changes that were there as a part of
these commits to still exist i would do
command called get reset
hyphen iphone soft
now this would go back or unwind my
changes back to this particular snapshot
getting rid of all the commit messages
that were there as a part of these two
commits but a soft would ensure that the
file changes that were done as a part of
these two commits would still exist a
full remain so the command for that is
git reset hyphen f and soft which is the
snapshot that i want to get back to if
this is the commit that i want to get
back to i just copy this
and i paste this
all right it doesn't give me any message
but if at all i do a git log pretty one
line
what it says is c1 c2 now the head which
is nothing but the current pointer which
is earlier pointing to c5 it's gone back
to c3 now what happened to the changes
that were there as a part of c4 and c5
if at all you do a git status if you see
the changes that were part of c4 were
some changes to m1 and m2 and c5 a new
file got m4 got added if what i do a git
status
you'll see those changes still exist
however from the git history or the git
commit history c3 is the topmost commit
that exists as of now c4 and c5 have
been gotten rid of but the changes that
were there still exist
all right now i can make some more
changes that i want if as a part of my
commit and possibly go ahead and commit
this whole thing as a new commit
altogether maybe
i'll open up a notepad and possibly
create a new file called m6.txt
and say
one
new file
that was missed out
i make this change
i go to a get status
all these files are still there i would
say git add dot
also get
commit hyphen m
c4
rewriting history
and i do a get
log
pretty
there you go
so c1 c2 c3 still existed and whatever
was a part of c4 and c5 the older ones
i've gotten rid of this along with those
old changes i also added a new file i
made some changes and it was able to
commit it now if you look at my gate
history it's all nice and clean however
do this activity only when you don't
push your git repository to the server
one other most powerful and useful
command while undoing or resetting the
history is something called as revert
this is a safe way of undoing some
things remember what i talked about when
exactly you can do a reset it's only
when your changes are local and is not
being pushed to the repository take this
scenario wherein let's say i have a git
server
and i have the changes
which are c1
c2
c3
and possibly c4
all right so this is a bunch of comments
that has happened this was the oldest
comment and this is the newest comment
and if at all developer1 is the one
who's responsible for pushing these
contents
in the first place so he has got c1 to
c4 on his history
i'm going to jump all these c2 and c3
and get into c4 and has pushed all these
contents out here
and there are a bunch of people from the
server who has pulled this repository
and all of them are at the same level
now imagine a use case where developer 1
then figures out that by mistake he put
in the c3 which was the wrong thing to
do and possibly you know he could have
done a better job of fixing this in a
different way so he wants to get rid of
the c3 or c4 or any one of these
comments
if he's going to do that and push to the
server first of all the git server would
not allow him to go back in history but
assuming that he forcibly pushed
something
what would happen to all these people
who are looking to work ahead from c4
all of them would be affected in adverse
way so
in short never go back in history if at
all you need to undo something go ahead
and put in a new commit to undo
something
let's take this example maybe if at all
developer 1 wants to get rid of c3
better way to do that is by adding a new
commit which is ahead
say let's say c5 and what does this
commit do
this commit possibly gets rid of c3
instead of going back in history it
actually is taking your git history
ahead but as a part of this commit
you're undoing some part of the work
that was done as a part of c3
in short you're removing a commit but to
remove a commit you're adding a new
commit and this is why you're doing it
because there are a bunch of other
people who are
you're using this repository
collaboratively and were planning to get
ahead in terms of history they cannot
afford to go back in history and modify
something in history all right the
command to do this is called the get
revert command
so let me take up this repository which
has got a bunch of commits in it and if
at all i do a git log
pretty one line
i have these bunch of comments
and c1 i've added a file in c2 hour
another file in c3 i've added one more
file and in c4 i made some changes and
this is the latest commit and this is
the oldest commit so if at all i see the
contents of the git
folder it contains m1 m2 m3 and m4
and
let's say looking at the previous use
case that i mentioned i may want to get
rid of this particular commit
i want to get rid of the c3 which is
nothing but i've added a file called
m3.txt but i added it by mistake
i need a better way of fixing it
possibly i'll look at it later on but
for now i don't want this particular
commit and the changes that were made as
a part of that commit to exist so the
better way to do that is using the git
revert command so get revert and the
commit id whatever i want to revert so
if i want to revert this
i copy this particular commit id and
bear in mind that considering reset
revert works on one commit at a time so
i can do one commit revert at a time i
can club bunch of them together and do
one commit but otherwise the reward
always works on one commit at a time so
get revert
paste this
essentially what i'm trying to do i'm
trying to undo this particular commit
while i'm undoing this commit what does
git do it safely adds a new commit and a
part of this new commit it unders
whatever changes that were done as a
part of this comment so if i say git
revert this
all right i forgot to mention the
message which is why this window is
showing up but that message is good for
me i say write and quit
all right and if i do a git log
all right if you see this c1 still is
there in history and our history is
going ahead from c5 i see another commit
but what was it as a part of this commit
actually is getting rid of this commit
c3 so if at all i see my files here
there's only m1 m2 and m4
m3 was added as a part of c3 now i've
gotten rid of m3
by getting rid of the revert command for
c3 so this is a better way of undoing
things
now that we have acquainted ourselves
with few of those basic git commands let
me get into a very very interesting
topic regarding git which is about
branching the topic is interesting
because kit deals with branches in a
completely different way
compared to any other version control
tool
in most of the version control tools
whenever you create a new branch a
complete copy or a subset of the whole
repository is created which in my
opinion is very very cost inefficient
because it is a very very expensive
operation both in times of time and the
disk space however in git you just
create a very very lightweight mobile
pointer whenever you create a branch
there is no folder or no copy of the
repository that is created in short the
branches are very very inexpensive and
great so go ahead and create any number
of branches that you need however once
you create your branches do all the work
relating to that branch in that specific
branch and once you've completed your
task go ahead and merge your branches
back into your base branch and then
delete the branch
let me go ahead and create a repository
with some branches in this and give you
a demonstration of that
so let me go back to my
base directory which is git demo and
then i'm going to create a new folder
here
i'll create a folder called arc details
all right this is my folder here
all right i navigate into this folder
and let me create a repository here
i initialize a repository a dot git
folder is created without any
files in it so let me create a few files
on it
say notepad name dot text
organization name
i create a name.text within this maybe
i'll create one more file in this
notepad
employees.txt
simply learn
has
over
3k employees
i just put in some content in this save
this content
all right
so if i try to go get status i just
see two files in it so let me go ahead
and
add these two files and let me commit my
changes so okay
commit iphone am or iphone m
first command
so if i do a gig log
i see only one commit and there are two
files and you can see those two files
that is here
all right
so at this stage let me go ahead and
create a new branch
and the command for creating new branch
is get
branch name of the branch
so let me name my branch as bangalore
branch blr branch
and this created a branch
but i don't see any changes in the
folder structure or in the file that
exists here
i've just created this branch so if at
all i do a git
branch
i see these two branches
and whatever star means i'm currently in
this master branch so let me go ahead
and get into the blr branch at this
moment the number of files that exist in
this repository is same there's
absolutely no change in any of the
branches both master and blr branch
point to the same snapshot
so let me get into
the other branch and the command to do
that is gate checkout
plr branch
i've actually switched into bangalore
branch if you see the content of the
files there's exactly two files the way
it was earlier because i've created a
branch from my base branch which is a
master branch and when i created a
branch there were two files existing
here if you see the content of these
files they would all be the same
all right so let me create a
file that is specific to panel branch
so i would just say notepad
maybe i want to put on the address of
this organization specific to bangalore
in this address dot text so i see
notepad address dot text
we'll say simply learn
angular office
say located
in some address
i would say bangalore
that is the content of this file
and i'm creating all this new file in
this blr branch so i would say git add
dot and i would say git
commit hyphen m
bangalore
branch
commit
all right if you see this now i have an
address dot text which is there only in
the bangalore branch that i'm presently
on now let me switch back to my master
branch the command to do that is get
check out
master branch
if you remember when i forked out or
when i created a new branch from the
master branch i didn't have this address
or text in it so let me go back to git
git checkout master branch
and keep noticing this particular
what happened to the address.text
it kind of disappeared
how did that happen it's all because of
this magical git folder so what happened
is now git knows that when you are in
the master branch the
file that was there in the bangalore
branch which was called the
address.txt didn't exist
so
git is playing around with the file
system snapshot so if i come back let's
say i come back to get
check out
bangalore branch
if you see this the address.txt file
appears
so this particular file is only present
in the branch and git is playing around
with the file system snapshot by moving
the pointers across and ensuring that
whenever i am switching to bangalore
branch i see this address.txt when i go
back to my master branch i don't see
this bangalore branch
contents which is the address.txt
all right now that i created this branch
maybe i may need to push this onto the
server so let me go ahead and create a
particular repository structure on the
server similar to whatever we did in our
previous exercise
so
the name of the folder needs to be
exactly this one so let me copy this
and let me create a repository very
quickly
go here and say new repository
all right this
is the name of the repository
get
branch demo this is what i'm going to
put in as a description i would say
public i don't want any readme files in
it because i already have a repository i
will just say create a repository
all right
let me use
the ssh url yeah this is the ssh url
this is good for me so let me copy this
url
let me add it here
i'm linking my local repository with the
server
and i would let me come back to my
master branch
let me first push my master branch so i
would say git
push
iphone u origin
master
it asks for my passphrase
all right
i pushed my master branch looks good it
says new master is created so if i go
back to my server and i do a refresh
if you see it says only one branch
and it says what is the name of the
branch master
if you see the contents there is
employees.txt and name.txt
now
let's try to push the other branch that
is there the command to do that is a
little different compared to
the way we created it on the client
because on the client we created the
branch with a git branch command now
this branch doesn't exist on the server
and i need to push this new branch onto
the server so the command would be
gate
push
hyphen u
origin
and the name of the branch that i want
to specifically push
all right now it created a branch out
here
let me do a refresh of this
all right it says two branches
if i get into this banter branch i would
see the address dot text if at all i go
back into master branch i would not see
this address.txt
wonderful
now let me do one thing let me try to
get the changes from the branch that i
created back into the master branch that
is what i would mean by
merging i would want the changes that is
there as a part of the bangalore branch
to come back into my master branch so if
i go to click checkout
bankrupt branch i see this attention tag
this is there only as a part of
bangalore branch now assuming that i'm
done with the changes from the banner
branch i want to get those changes back
into my master so let me come back to my
master branch
and the way to merge in the changes is
get merge
so what is that you want to merge i want
to merge the bangalore branch changes
and where will it merge it'll merge it
into the current branch that i'm on
presently i'm in the master branch so
this command would merge the changes
from the bangalore branch into your
master branch so with this if you'll
keep looking here the content that was
there that was added as a part of
bangalore branch which is nothing but
the address dot text this file should
appear as soon as we do a merge
all right so it happened
quickly and you would see this address
dot text that is here so if you see
let's check the contents in terms of the
git log
all right so there was only one branch
that we had earlier which had only one
commit right now we are at this
bangalore branch commit which was there
as a part of the bangalore branch commit
so with this change let me push this
change onto the server as well gate push
origin
master
okay those changes were pushed to the
server and now
if at all i do a refresh out here
okay i'm in two branches
the branches master even if i'm in
master brands i should see this address
dot text that is there even if i'm in
the bangalore branch the content is all
same because we must these two branches
now that i've merged this branch i don't
need this branch anymore so i would go
ahead and delete this locally as well as
push it onto the server so that it gets
deleted from the server as well so
delete branch locally the command is get
branch
hyphen d and the name of the branch
only thing you need to ensure is that
you should not be currently on that
branch which you're trying to delete so
i would say get branch and i'm presently
in the master branch so i can go ahead
and delete the other branch so get
branch hyphen d bangle branch
all right this got rid of our bandwidth
branch locally
if at all i don't get branch hyphen we
it shows there's only one branch as of
now however this branch would still
exist on the server because server
doesn't know anything about the changes
that we have done
we need to specifically push our changes
onto the server
okay there are two branches still here
so let me go ahead and push these
changes so that the branch gets deleted
from the server as well the command to
do that is get
push
origin
hyphen iphone delete
and the name of the branch
all right
so this went ahead and deleted the
branch
from the server let's check that
okay if you see now there's only one
branch
these are the basic steps that you would
need to know before you work with any of
the branches within git and as i said
before the branches are very very
inexpensive and good go ahead and create
any number of branches that you want but
just ensure that once you create your
branch finish off your task and once you
finish off your task go ahead and delete
the branch and before you delete the
brands please ensure that you merge in
the branches so that you get in or take
in the work that was done as a part of
that particular branch
to summarize the git branching commands
are as follows to create a new branch
you issue a command git branch the name
of the branch and this would
automatically spin off or create a new
branch from the existing branch from
where you issue this command if you are
on the master branch and if you execute
this command git branch new underscore
branch it creates a new underscore
branch from the master branch once you
create a new branch in order to get into
this branch you type in git check out
the name of the branch
this would automatically switch the file
system snapshot between different
branches now the branches that are
created are by default created on the
local repository
in case you want to push any specific
branch onto the server you would have to
issue a command git push hyphen u origin
and the name of the branch so this will
ensure that the contents of the new
branch are pushed onto the server at any
time if you want to list out all
existing branches on your local
repositories the command would be git
branch hyphen av assuming that you did
all your work in a new branch and you're
happy with the changes you would want to
bring back those changes into the master
branch the command to merge the contents
of any new branch into a master branch
would be git merge and the name of the
branch this would automatically merge
the branch contents that you specified
into the branch on which you currently
reside if at all you are on the master
branch and if you issue a command gate
merge new underscore branch this would
merge the contents of the new branch
onto the master branch so once you merge
the contents of any branch you would
possibly want to go ahead and delete
this branch so the command to delete
those branch locally is get branch
hyphen capital d and the name of the
branch this again would delete the
branch locally in order to make this
change on the server which is in order
to remove this branch from the server
the command to do that is get push
origin hyphen iphone delete and the name
of the branch this would also delete the
branch that you created on the server in
this session we're going to deep dive
into what jenkins is and how it improves
your devops continuous integration
environments so let's talk a little bit
about life before jenkins let's see this
scenario i think it's something that
maybe all of you can relate to as
developers we all write code and we all
submit that code into a code repository
and we all keep working away writing our
unit tests and hopefully we're running
our unit tests but the problem is that
the actual commits that actually gets
sent to the code repository aren't
consistent you as a developer may be
based in india you may have another
developer that's based in the
philippines and you may have another
team lead that's based in the uk and
another development team that's based in
north america so you're all working at
different times and you have different
amounts of code going into the code
repository there's issues with the
integration and you're kind of running
into a situation that we like to call
development hell where things just
aren't working out and there's just lots
of delays being added into the project
and the bugs just keep mounting up the
bottom line is the project is delayed
and in the past what we would have to do
is we'd have to wait until the entire
software code was built and tested
before we could even begin checking for
errors and this just really kind of
increased the amount of problems that
you'd have in your project
the actual process of delivering
software was slow there was no way that
you could actually iterate on your
software and you just ended up with just
a big headache with teams pointing
fingers at each other and blaming each
other
so let's jump into jenkins and see what
jenkins is and how it can address these
problems
so jenkins is a product that comes out
of the concept of continuous integration
that you may have heard of as power
developers where you'd have two
developers sitting next to each other
coding against the same piece of
information what they were able to do is
to continuously develop their code and
test their code and move on to new
sections of code jenkins is a product
that allows you to expand on that
capacity to your entire team so you're
able to submit your codes consistently
into a source code environment
so there are two ways in which you can
do continuous delivery one is through 90
builds and one is through continuous
so the approach that you can look at
continuous delivery is modifying the
legacy approach to building out
solutions so what we used to do is we
would wait for nightly builds and the
way that our nightly builds would work
and operate is that as co-developers we
would all run and have a cut-off time at
the end of the day and that was
consistent around the world that we
would put our codes into a single
repository and at night all of that code
would be run and operated and tested to
see if there were any changes and a new
build would be created and that would be
referred to as the nightly build with
continuous integration we're able to go
one step further we're able to not only
commit our changes into our source code
but we can actually do this continuously
there's no need to race and have a team
get all of their code in an arbitrary
time you can actually do a continuous
release because what you're doing is
you're putting your tests and your
verification services into the build
environment so you're always running
cycles to test against your code
this is the power that jenkins provides
in continuous integration so let's dig
deeper into continuous integration so
the concept of continuous integration is
that as a developer you're able to pull
from a repository the code that you're
working on and then you'll be able to
then at any time submit the code that
you're working on into a continuous
integration server and the goal of that
continuous integration server is that it
actually goes ahead and validates and
passes any tests that a tester may have
created
now if on the continuous integration
server a test isn't passed then that
code gets sent back to the developer and
the developer can then make the changes
it allows the developer to actually do a
couple of things it allows the developer
not to break the build and we all don't
want to break the builds that are being
created but it also allows the developer
not to actually have to run all the
tests locally on their computer write
tests particularly if you have a large
number of tests can take up a lot of
time so if you can push that service up
to another environment like a continuous
integration server it really improves
the productivity of your developer
what's also good is that if there are
any code errors that have come up that
may be beyond just the standard ci test
so maybe there's a code the way that you
write your code isn't consistent those
errors can then be passed on easily from
the tester back to the developer too the
goal from doing all this testing is that
you're able to release and deploy and
your customer is able to get new code
faster and when they get that code it
simply just works so let's talk a little
bit about some of the tools that you may
have in your continuous integration
environment so the cool thing with
working with continuous integration
tools is that they are all open source
at least the ones that we have listed
here are open source there are some that
are private but typically you'll get
started with open source tools and it
gives you the opportunity to understand
how you can accelerate your environment
quickly so bamboo is a continuous
integration tool that specifically runs
multiple builds in parallel for faster
compilation so if you have multiple
versions of your software that runs on
multiple platforms this is a tool that
really allows you to get that up and
running super fast so that your teams
can actually test how those different
builds would work for different
environments and this has integration
with and maven and other similar tools
so one of the tools you're going to need
is a tool that allows you to automate
the software build test and release
process and buildbot is that open source
product for you again it's an open
source tool so there's no license
associated with this so you can actually
go in and you can actually get the
environment up and running and you can
then test for and build your environment
and create your releases very quickly so
buildbots also written in python and it
does support parallel execution jobs
across multiple platforms if you're
working specifically on java projects
that need to be built and test then
apache gump is the tool for you it makes
all of those projects really easy it
makes all the java projects easier for
you to be able to test with api level
and functionality level testing so one
of the popular places to actually store
code and create a versioning of your
code is github and it's a service that's
available on the web just recently
acquired by microsoft if you are storing
your projects in github then you'll be
able to use travis continuous
integration or travis ci and it's a tool
designed specifically for hosted github
projects
and so finally we're covering jenkins
and jenkins is a central tool for
automation for all of your projects now
when you're working with jenkins
sometimes you'll find there's
documentation that refers to a product
called hudson hudson is actually the
original version of the product that
finally became jenkins and it was
acquired by oracle when that acquisition
happened the team behind um hudson was a
little concerned about the direction
that oracle may potentially go with
hudson and so they created a hard fork
of hudson that they renamed jenkins and
jenkins has now become that open source
project it is one of the most popular
and continuously contributed projects
that's available as open source so
you're always getting new features being
added to it it's a tool that really
becomes the center for your ci
environment
so let's jump into some of those really
great features that are available in
jenkins so jenkins itself is really
comprised of five key areas around easy
installation easy configuration plug-ins
extensibility and distribution so as i
mentioned for the easy installation
jenkins is a self-contained java program
and that allows it to run on most
popular operating systems including
windows mac os and unix you even run it
on linux
it really isn't too bad to set up it
used to be much harder than it is today
the setup process has really improved
the web interface makes it really easy
for you to check for any errors in
addition you have great built-in help
one of the things that makes tools like
jenkins really powerful for developers
and continuous integration teams and
your devops teams as a whole when you
have plug-ins that you can then add in
to extend the base functionality of the
product jenkins has hundreds of plugins
and you can go and visit the update
center and see which other plugins that
would be good for your devops
environment certainly check it out
there's just lots of stuff out there in
addition to the plugin architecture
jenkins is also extremely extensible the
opportunity for you to be able to
configure jenkins to fit in your
environment is almost endless now it's
really important to remember that you
are extending jenkins not creating a
custom version of jenkins and that's a
great differentiation because the core
foundation remains as the core jenkins
product the extensibility can then be
continued with newer releases of jenkins
so you're always having the latest
version of jenkins and your extensions
mature with those core foundation the
distribution and the nature of jenkins
makes it really easy for you to be able
to have it available across your entire
network it really will become the center
of your ci environment and it's
certainly one of the easier tools and
more effective tools for devops
so let's jump into the standard jenkins
pipeline so when you're doing
development you start off and you're
coding away on your computer the first
thing you have to do when you're working
in the jenkins pipeline is to actually
commit your code now as a developer this
is something that you're already doing
or at least you should be doing you're
committing your code to a git server um
or to an svn server or a similar type of
service so in this instance you'll be
using jenkins as the place for you to
commit your code jenkins will then
create a build of your code and part of
that build process is actually going
through and running through tests and
again as a developer you're already
comfortable with running unit tests and
writing those tests to validate your
code but there may be additional tests
that jenkins is running so for instance
as a team you may have a standard set of
tests for how you actually write out
your code so that each team member can
understand the code that's been written
and those tests can also be included in
the testing process within the jenkins
environment assuming everything past the
the tests you can then get everything
placed in a stage and release ready
environment within jenkins
and finally again ready to deploy or
deliver your code to a production
environment jenkins is going to be the
tool that helps you with your server
environment to be able to deploy your
code to the production environment and
the result is that you're able to move
from a developer to production code
really quickly this whole process can be
automated rather than having to wait for
people to actually test your codes or go
through a nightly build you're looking
at being able to commit your code and go
through this testing process and release
process continuously as an example
companies etsy will release up to 50
different versions of their website
every single day
so let's talk about the architecture
within jenkins that allows you to be so
effective at applying a continuous
delivery devops environment so the
server architecture really is broken up
into two sections on the left hand side
of the section you have the code the
developers are doing and submitting that
code to a source code repository and
then from then jenkins is your
continuous integration server and it
will then pull any code that's been sent
to the source code repository and will
run tests against it it will use a build
service such as maven to actually then
build the code and every single stage
that we have that jenkins manages there
are constant tests so for instance if a
build fails that it feedback is sent
right back to the developers so that
they can then change their code so that
the build environment can run
effectively
the final stage is to actually execute
specific test scripts and these test
scripts can be written in selenium so
it's probably good to mention here that
both mavin and selenium are plug-ins
that run in the jenkins environment so
before we were talking about how jenkins
can be extended with plug-ins maven and
selenium are just two very popular
examples of how you can extend the
jenkins environment the goal to go
through this whole process again is an
automated process is to get your code
from the developer to the production
server as quickly as possible
have it fully tested and have no errors
so it's probably important at this point
to mention uh one piece of information
around the jenkins environment that if
you have different code builds that need
to be managed and distributed this will
require that you need to have multiple
builds being managed jenkins itself
doesn't allow for multiple files and
builds to be executed on a single server
you need to have a multiple server
environment with running different
versions of jenkins for that to be able
to happen so let's talk a little bit
about the master slave architecture
within jenkins so what we have here is
an overview of the master slave
architecture within jenkins on the left
hand side is the remote source code
repository and that remote source code
repository could be github or it could
be a team foundation services or the new
azure devops code repository or it could
be your own git repository the jenkins
server acts as the master environment on
the left hand side and that master
environment can then push out to
multiple other jenkins slave
environments to distribute the workload
so it allows you to run multiple builds
and tests and production environments
simultaneously across your entire
architecture so jenkins slaves can be
running the different build versions of
the code for different operating systems
and the server master is controlling how
each of those builds operate so let's
step into a quick story of a company
that has used jenkins very successfully
so here's a use case scenario um over
the last 10 or 15 years there has been a
significant shift within the automotive
industry where manufacturers have
shifted from creating complex hardware
to actually creating software we've seen
that with companies such as tesla
where they are creating software to
manage their cars we see the same thing
with companies such as general motors
with their onstar program and ford just
recently have rebranded themselves as a
technology company rather than just a
automotive company
what this means though is that the
software within these cars is becoming
more complex and requires more testing
to allow more capabilities enhancements
to be added to the core software so
bosch is a company that specifically ran
into this problem and their challenge
was that they wanted to be able to
streamline the increasingly complex
automotive software by adopting
continuous integration and continuous
delivery best practices with the goal of
being able to delight and exceed the
customer expectations of the end user so
bosch has actually used cloudbees which
is the enterprise jenkins environment so
to be able to reduce the number of
manual steps such as building deploying
and testing bosch has introduced the use
of cloud bs from jenkins and this is
part of the enterprise jenkins platform
it has significantly helped improve the
efficiencies throughout the whole
software development cycle from
automation stability and transparency
because jenkins becomes a self-auditing
environment now the results have been
tangible previously it took three days
before a build process could be done and
now it's taken that same three-day
process and reduced it to less than
three hours that is significant
large-scale deployments are now kept on
track and have expert support and there
is clear visibility and transparency
across the whole operations through
using the jenkins tools let's get
started with jenkins jenkins is a web
application that is written in java and
there are various ways in which you can
use and install jenkins i have listed
popular three mechanisms in which
jenkins is usually installed on any
system the topmost one is as a windows
or linux based services so if at all you
have windows like the way i have and i'm
going to use this mechanism for this
demo so i would download a msi installer
that is specific to jenkins and install
this service so whenever installed as a
service it goes ahead and nicely
installs all that is required for my
jenkins and i have a service that can be
started or stopped based upon my need
any flavor of linux as well one other
way of running jenkins is downloading
this generic war file and as long as you
have jdk installed you can launch this
war file by the command opening up a
command prompt or shell prompt if it
layer on linux box specifying java
hyphen jar and the name of this war file
it typically brings up your web
application and you know you can
continue with your installation the only
thing being if at all you want to stop
using jenkins you just go ahead and
close this prompt you either do a
control c and then bring down this
prompt and your jenkins server would be
down other older versions of jenkins
were run popularly using this way in
which you already have a java based web
server running up and running so you
kind of drop in this war file into the
root folder or the httpd root folder of
your web server so jenkins would explode
and kind of bring up your application
all user credentials or user
administration is all taken care of by
the apache or the tomcat server or the
web server on which jenkins is running
this was a very older way of running but
still some people use it because if they
don't want to maintain two servers if
they already have a java web server
which it's being nicely maintained and
backed up jenkins can run attached to it
all right so either ways it doesn't
matter however you're going to bring up
your jenkins instance the way we're
going to operate jenkins is all going to
be very very same or similar one with
the subtle changes in terms of user
administration if at all you're
launching it through any other web
server which will take care of the user
administration otherwise all the
commands or all the configuration or the
way in which i'm going to run this demo
it is going to be same across any of
these installations all right so the
prerequisites for running jenkins as i
mentioned earlier jenkins is nothing but
a simple web application that is written
in java so all that it needs is java
preferably jdk 1.7 or 1.8 2gb ram is the
recommended ram for running jenkins and
also like any other open source tool
sets when you install jdk ensure that
you set in the environment variable java
home to point to the right directory
this is something very specific to jdk
but for any other open source tools that
you've installed there's always a
preferred environment variable that you
got to set in which is specific to that
particular tool that you're going to use
this is a generic thing that is there
for you know for any other open source
projects because the way open source
projects discover themselves is using
these environment variables so as a
general practice or a good practice
always set these environment variables
accordingly so i already have jdk 1.8
installed on my system but in case you
do not what i would recommend is just
navigate on your browser to the oracle
home page and just type in or search for
install
jdk 1.8
and navigate to the oracle home page
you will have to accept the license
agreement and there are a bunch of
installers that is okay that you can
pick up based upon the operating system
on which you're running so
i have this windows 64 installer that is
already installed and running on my
system so i will not get into the
details of downloading this or
installing it let me show you once i
install this what i've done with regard
to my path
so
if you get into those environment
variables
all right so i have just set in a java
home variable
if you see this c colon program files
java jdk 1.8 this is where my my java is
located c program files
c program files java
okay so this is the home directory of my
jdk so that is what i have been i've set
it up here in my environment variable
so if you see here this is my java home
all right one other thing to do is
ensure that in case you want to run java
or java c from a command prompt ensure
that you also add that path into this
path variable so if you see this
somewhere i will see yes there you go c
colon program files java jdk 1.8 pin so
with these two i'll ensure that my java
installation is nice and you know good
enough so to check that to double check
that or to verify that let me just open
up a simple command prompt
and if i type in java iphone version
all right
and java c
iphone version
so the compiler is on the path java is
on the path and if at all i do this
even the environment variable specific
to my java is
installed correctly so i am good to go
ahead with my jenkins installation
now that i have my prerequisites
all set for installing jenkins let me
just go ahead and download jenkins
so let me open up a browser and say
download
jenkins
all right lts is nothing but the long
term support these are all stable
versions weeklies i would not recommend
that you try these unless until you have
a real need for that
long term support is good enough and as
i mentioned there are so many flavors of
jenkins there is available for download
all right so what i want is
yes this is the war file which is
generic war file that i was talking to
you earlier and this is the windows msi
installer so go ahead and download this
msi installer i already have that
downloaded so let me just open that up
all right so this is my downloaded
jenkins instance or other installer this
is a pretty maybe a few months old but
this is good enough for me
before you start jenkins installation
just be aware of one fact that there is
a variable called jenkins home this is
where jenkins would store all this
configuration data jobs project
workspace and all that specific to
jenkins so by default if at all you
don't set this to any particular
directory if at all you install an msi
installer all your installation gets
into sequel and program files 86 and
jenkins folder if at all you run a war
file depending upon the user id with
which you're running your war file the
jenkins folder there's a dot jenkins
folder that gets created inside the user
home directory so in case you have any
need wherein you want to backup your
jenkins or you want jenkins
installations to get into some specific
directories go ahead and set this
jenkins home variable accordingly before
you even begin your installation for now
i don't need to do any of these things
so i've already downloaded the installer
let me just go ahead with the default
installation all right so this is my
jenkins msi installer i would just i
don't want to make any changes into the
jenkins configuration c colon program
files is good for me yeah this is where
all my destination folder and all the
configuration specific to it goes i'm
happy with this i don't want to change
this
i would just say go ahead and click
installation
okay so what typically happens once the
jenkins installation gets through is
it'll start installing itself and there
are some small checks that needs to be
done
so and by default jenkins launches on
the port 8080 so let me just open up
localhost 8080.
there's a small checking that will be
done as a part of the installation
process wherein i need to type in the
hash key all right so there's a very
very simple hash key that gets stored
out here so i'll have to just copy this
path
if i told you you're running as a war
file you would see that in your logs
all right so this is a simple hash key
that gets created every time when you do
a jenkins station so as a part of the
installation it just asks you to do this
so
if that is not great it will crib about
it but this looks good
so it's going ahead
all right one important part during the
installation
so you would need to install some
recommended plugins
what happens is the plugins are all
related to each other so it's like the
typical rpm kind of a problem where you
try to install some plugin and it's got
a dependency which is not installed and
you get into all those issues in order
to get rid of that what jenkins
recommends there's a bunch of plugins
that is already recommended so just go
ahead and blindly click that
install recommended plugin so if you see
there is
a whole lot of plugins which are bare
essential plugin that is required for
jenkins in order to run properly so
jenkins as a part of the installation
would get all these plugins and then
install it for you
this is a good combination to kind of
begin with and mind you at this moment
jenkins needs uh lots of bandwidth in
terms of network so in case your you
know your network is not so good few of
these plugins would kind of fail
and these plugins are all you know on
available on openly
or or mirrored sites and sometimes some
of them may be down so do not worry in
case some of these plugins kind of fail
to install you'll get an option to kind
of retry installing them but just ensure
that you know at least most or 1995 of
all these plugins are installed without
any problems let me pause the video here
for a minute and then get back once all
these plugins are installed
my plugin installation is all good there
was no failures in any of my plugins so
after that i get to create this first
admin user again this is one important
point that you got to remember
keen given any username and password but
ensure that you kind of remember that
because it's very hard to get back your
username and password in case you forget
it all right so i'm going to create a
very very simple username and password
something that i can remember
i will
that's my name and um an email id is
kind of optional but it doesn't allow me
to go ahead in case i don't so i just
given an admin and i got a password i've
got i remember my password this is my
full name
all right i say save and finish
all right that kind of completed my
jenkins installation it was not that
tough was it
now that i have my jenkins installed
correctly let me quickly walk you
through some bare minimal configurations
that is required these are kind of a
first time configuration that is
required so and also let me warn you the
ui is little hard for many people to
wrap their head around it specifically
the windows guys but if at all you're a
java guy you know how painful it is to
write ui in java you will kind of
appreciate know all the effort that has
gone into the ui bottom line you are a
little hard to you know wrap your head
around it but once you start using it
possibly you'll start lacking it
all right so let me get into something
called as managed and cans
this can be viewed like a
main menu for all jenkins configuration
so i'll get into some of those important
ones
something called as configure system
configure system this is where you kind
of put in the configuration for your
complete jenkins instance few things to
kind of look out for this is a home
directory this is a java home where all
the configurations all the workspace
anything and everything regarding
jenkins is stored out here
system message you want to put in some
message on the system you just type in
whatever you want and it's probably show
up somewhere up here on the menu number
of executors very very important
configuration
this just lets jenkin know at any point
in time how many jobs or how many
threads can be run you can kind of
visualize it like a thread that can be
run on this particular instance as a
thumb rule if at all you're on a single
core system number of executors two
should be good enough
in case at any point in time if there
are multiple jobs that kind of get
triggered the same time in case the
number of executors are less compared to
the number of jobs that have there to
woken up no need to panic because they
will all get queued up and eventually
jenkins will get to running those jobs
just bear in mind that whenever a new
job kind of you know gets triggered the
cpu usage and the memory usage in terms
of the disk right is very high on the
jenkins instance
so that's something that you got to kind
of keep in mind all right but number of
executors two for my system is kind of
good label for my jenkins i don't want
any of these things usage how do you
want to use your jenkins this is good
for me because i only have a primary
server that is running so i want to use
this node as much as possible quite
better each of these options have got
some pair minimal
help kind of a thing that is that is out
here by clicking on these question marks
you will get to know as to what are
these particular configurations
all right so this all look good what i
want to show you here is there's
something regarding the docker
timestamps git plugin svn
email notifications
i don't want that what i want the yes i
want this smtp server configuration
remember i mentioned earlier that i
would want jenkins to be sending out
some emails
and what i've done here is i've just
configured the smtp details of my
personal email id
in case you are in a in organization you
would have some sort of an email ids
that is set up for a jenkins server so
you can specify the smtp server details
of your company so that you know you can
authorize jenkins to kind of send out
emails
but in case you want to try it out like
me
i have configured my personal email id
which is on my gmail for sending out
notifications so the smtp server would
be
smtp.gmail.com i'm using the smtp
authentication i have provided my email
id and my password i'm using the smtp
port which is 465 and i'm you know reply
to address is the same as mine i can
just send out an email
and see if at all this configuration
works again gmail would not allow you to
allow anybody to send out notifications
on your behalf so you'll have to lower
the security level of your gmail id so
that you can allow a programmatically
somebody to send out email notifications
on your behalf so i've done already that
i'm just trying to see if i can send a
test email with the configuration that
i've set in
yes
all right so the email configuration
looks good
so this is how you configure your
you know your gmail account in case you
want to do that if not put in your
organization smtp server details which
are for the valid username and password
and it should all be set
all right so no other configurations
that i'm going to change here all of
these look good
all right so i come back to managing
ken's
okay one other thing that i want to kind
of go over is the global tool
configuration
imagine this scenario look at it this
way jenkins is a is a continuous
integration server it doesn't know what
kind of a code base it's going to pull
in what kind of a tool set that is
required or what is the code that is
going to pull in and how is it going to
build so you will have to put in all the
tools that is required for building the
appropriate kind of code that you're
going to pull in from you know your
source code repositories so just to give
you an example in case your source code
is a java source code and assuming that
you know because in this demo this is my
laptop and i've put in all the
configurations jdk everything on my
laptop because i'm a developer i'm
working on the laptop but my continuous
integration server would be you know a
separate server without anything being
installed on it so in case i want
jenkins to you know run a java code i
would need to install jdk on it i need
to specify the jdk location of this out
here this way
okay since i already have the jdk
installed and i've already put in the
java home directory or rather the
environment variable correctly i don't
need to do it git if at all i want the
jenkins server to use git git is a you
know command
bash or the command prompt for for
running git and connecting to any other
git server so you would need git to be
you know installed on that particular
system and set the path accordingly
gradle and maven if at all you have some
mavens as well you want to do this any
other tool that you're going to install
on your system
which is your continuous integration
server you will have to come in here and
configure something
in case you don't configure it when
jenkins runs it will not be able to
find these tools for building your task
and it'll crib about it
that's good i don't want to save
anything
managing let me see what else is
required yes configure global security
all right the security is enabled and if
you see by default it's the security
access control is set to jenkins own
user database so what does this mean you
know jenkins by default it uses file
system where it stores all the user
names which hashes up these user names
and kind of stores them
so as of now it jenkins is configured to
use its own database assuming that you
are running in an organization you would
probably want to have a you know some
sort of an ad or an ldap server using
which you would want to control access
to your jenkins repository rather
jenkins tool
so you would specify your ldap server
details the root dn
password or the manager dn and the
manager password and all these details
in case you want to connect your jenkins
instance with your
ldap or ad or any of the authentication
servers that you have in your
organization
but for now since i don't have any of
these things i'm going to use this own
database that's good enough
all right so i will set up some
authorization methods and stuff like
that once i put in few jobs so for now
let me not get into any of these details
of this just be aware that jenkins can
be connected for authorization to an
ldap server or you can have jenkins
managing its own servers which is
happening as of now so i'm going to save
all this stuff
that's good for me so enough of all
these configurations let me put in a
very very simple job
all right so job new item you know
little difficult to kind of figure out
but then that's the new item so i'll
just say you know first job this is good
for me i just give a name for my job i
would say it's a freestyle project
that's good enough for me i don't want
to choose any of that so unless until
you choose any of this this particular
button would not become active so choose
the freestyle project and say ok
at a very high level you would see
general source code management build
triggers build environment build and
post build in case you install more and
more plugins you will see a lot more
options but for now this is what you
would see so what am i doing at the
moment i'm just putting up a very very
simple job and the job could be anything
and everything so i don't want to put in
a very complicated job for now for the
demo let me just put in a very very
simple job i'll give a description
this is an optional thing this is my
first
jenkins job
all right i don't want to choose any of
these again there are some helps
available here
i don't want to choose any of this i
don't want to connect it to any source
code for now
i don't want any triggers for now i'll
come back to this in a while build the
environment i don't want any build
environment as a part of this build step
you know i just want to you know run few
things so that i kind of complete this
particular job so since i'm on a windows
box i would say execute windows batch
command
all right so what do you want to do i
would let me just echo something echo
uh hello
this is my first jenkins job
and possibly i would want the date and
the timestamp
pertaining to the job i mean the date
and time in which this job was run all
right very very simple command that says
you know this is my first job it just
puts out something along with the date
and the time
all right i don't want to do anything
else i want to keep this job as simple
as this so let me
save this job
all right so once i save this job you
know the job names comes up here and
then i need to build this job and you
will see some buildings tray out here
nothing is there as of now because i've
just put in a job i have not run it yet
all right so let me try to build it now
you see a build number you will see a
date and a timestamp so if i click on
this you will see a console output if i
go here
okay as simple as that
and where is all the job details that is
getting into if you see this
if i navigate to this particular
directory
all right so this is the directory what
i was mentioning earlier regarding
jenkins home
so all the job related stuff that is
specific to this particular jenkins
installation is all here
all the plugins that is installed the
details of each of those plugins can be
found here
all right so the workspace is where all
the jobs that i've created whichever i'm
running would be wrong there will be
individual folders specific to the jobs
that has been put up here all right so
one job one quick run
that's what it looks like pretty simple
okay let me do one thing let me put up a
second job
i would say second job
i would say freestyle project
all right this is my second job
i just want to demonstrate the
powerfulness of the automation server
and how simple it is to automate a job
that is put up on jenkins
which will be triggered automatically
remember what i said earlier about
jenkins because at the core of jenkins
is a very very powerful automation
server all right so what i'm going to do
i will just keep everything else the
same i'm going to put in the build
script pretty much similar to
second job
that
gets triggered
automatically
every
minute all right let me do that
percentage date
and i'll put in the time
all right so i just put in another job
called second job and it pretty much
does the same thing as what i was doing
earlier in terms of printing the date
and the time but this time i'm just
going to demonstrate the powerfulness of
the automation server that is there if
you see here there's a build trigger
so a build can be triggered using
various triggers that is there so we'll
get into this github uh triggering or
hook or a web hook kind of a triggering
later on but for now what i want to do i
want to ensure that this job that i'm
going to put in would be automatically
triggered on its own let's say every
minute i want this job to be run on its
own
so build periodically is my setting
if you see here there's a bunch of
help that is available for me so for
those of you who have written cron jobs
on linux boxes you'll find it very very
simple but for others don't panic let me
just put up a very very simple regular
expression for scheduling this job every
minute all right so that's
one
two
three four
five right come up come up come up all
right so five stars is all that i'm
going to put in and jenkins got a little
worried and he's asking me do you really
mean every minute oh yeah i want to do
this every minute let me save this and
how do i check whether it gets triggered
every minute or not i just don't do
anything i'll just wait for a minute
and if at all everything goes well
jenkins would automatically trigger my
second job in a minutes time from now
this time around i'm not going to
trigger anything look there you see
it's automatically got trigger
if i go in here
yep second job that gets triggered
automatically you know it was triggered
at 42
1642 which is 442 my time that looks
good
and if everything goes well every one
minute onwards this job will be
automatically triggered
that i have
my jenkins up and running a few jobs
that has been put up here on my jenkins
instance i would need a way of
controlling access to my jenkins server
this is wherein i would use a plug-in
called role based access plugin and
create few rules the rules are something
like a global rule and a project rule
project specific growth i can have
different roles and i can have users who
have signed up or the users whom i
create kind of assigned to these roles
so that each of these users fall into
some category this is my way of kind of
controlling access to my jenkins
instance and
ensuring that people don't do something
unwarranted all right so first things
first let me go ahead and install a
plug-in
for doing that so i get into manage
jenkins and uh manage plug-in
a little bit of a confusing screen in my
opinion there's updates available
installed in advanced as of now we don't
have the role based plugin so let me go
to available it'll take some time for it
to get refreshed all right now these are
the available plugins these are the
install plugins
all right so let me come back to
available and i would want to search for
my role based access plugin so i would
just search for role and hit enter
okay role based authorization strategy
enables user authorization using a role
based strategy roles can be defined
globally or for particular jobs or nodes
and stuff like that so exactly this is
the plugin that i want
i would want to install it without a
restart
all right looks good so far
yes
go back to the top of the page yes
remember jenkins is running on a java
using a java instance so typically many
things would work the same way unless
and until you want to restart jenkins
once in a while but as a good practice
whenever you do some sort of a big
installations or big patches on your
jenkins instance just ensure that you
kind of restart it otherwise there would
be a difference in terms of what is
installed on the system and what is
there on the file system you will need
to flush out few of those settings later
on but for now these are all very small
plugins so this would run without any
problems but otherwise if at all there
are some plugins which would need a
restart you know kindly go and restart
your jenkins instance but for now i
don't need that
it looks good i've installed the plugin
so where do you see my plugin i
installed the plugin that is specific to
the
user control or the access control so
let me go into
yes
global security
and uh i would see this role-based
strategy showing up now
all right so this comes in because of my
installation of my role-based plugin so
this is what i would want to
enable
because i already have my own database
set up and for the authorization part in
the sense that who can do what i'm going
to install i mean i've already installed
a role based strategy uh plugin and i'm
going to enable that strategy all right
i would say save
okay now i've installed the role based
access plugin i would need to just set
it up and check that you know i would go
ahead and create some roles and ensure
that i assign users as per these roles
all right so let me go to
manage jenkins
configure
all right let me see where is this
configure configure global security is
that where i create my roles
nope not here
yes manage and assign roles
okay again you would see these options
only after you install these plugins so
for now i've just enabled the plugin i
have enabled role based access control
and i would go ahead and create some
rules for this particular jenkins
instance so i would say first
manage rules
so i would need to create some roles
here and the rules are at a very high
level these are global rules and there
are some project rules and there are
some slave rules i'll not get into
details of all of these at a very very
high level which is a global role let me
just create a role a role can be kind of
visualized like a group so i would
create a role called developer typically
the jenkins instance or the cia instance
are kind of owned up or controlled by qa
guys so qr guys would need to provide
some sort of you know limited access to
developers so that's why i'm creating a
role called developer
and i'm adding this role at a global
role level so i would say add this here
and you would see this developer role
that is there and each of these options
if we hover over it you would see some
sort of a
help on what what are these uh you know
permissions specific to
so what i want is like you know it
sounds a little
different but i would want to give very
very little permissions for the
developer so from an administration
perspective i would just want him to
have a read
kind of a role credentials again i would
just want to view kind of a rule i don't
want him to create any agents and all
that stuff that looks good for me
for a job i would want him to just
possibly
read i don't want him to build i don't
want him to cancel any jobs i don't want
him to configure any job i don't even
want him to create any job i would just
want him to read few things i would not
give him possibly a role to the
workspace as well i mean i don't want
him to have access to the workspace i
would just want him to
read a job
check you know have read-only access to
the job run um no i don't want him to
give him any any particular
access which will allow him to run any
jobs view configure
yeah possibly create yeah
delete i don't want to read yes
definitely
and this is the specific role so what
i'm doing i'm just creating a global
role called developer and i'm giving him
very very limited roles
in the sense that i don't want this
developer to be able to run any agents
nor create jobs or build jobs or cancel
jobs or configure jobs at the max i
would just want him to read a job that
is already put up there
okay
so i would save
now i created a role
i still don't have any users that is
there on the system so let me go ahead
and create some user on the system
that's not here i will say configure
manage and cans manage users
okay let me create a new user
i would call this user as yeah
developer1 sounds good
some password
some password that i can remember
okay his name is developer one
d at
t dot com or something like that
okay so this is the admin with with
which i kind of configured or brought up
the system and developer one is a user
that i have configured so still have not
set any rules for this particular user
yet so i would go to manage and gains
i would say
manage and assign roles i would say
assign roles
okay so if you see what i'm going to do
now is assign a role that is specific to
that particular i will find the
particular user and assign him the
developer role that i have already
configured
the role shows up here i would need to
find my user whoever created and then
assign him to that particular role so if
you remember the user that i created was
developer1 i would add this particular
user and now this particular user what
kind of a role i want him to have
because this is the global rule that had
created so developer i would assign this
developer 1 to this particular global
rule and i would go ahead and save my
changes
now let me check the permissions of this
particular user by logging out of my
admin account and logging back as
developer1
if you remember this role was created
with very less privileges
so
there you go i have jenkins but i don't
see a new item i can't trigger a new job
i can't do anything i see these jobs
however i don't think so i'll be able to
start this job i don't have the
permission set for that the maximum i
can do is look at the job see what was
there as a part of the console output
and stuff like that so this is a limited
role that was created and i added this
developer to that particular role which
was a developer role
so that the developers don't get to
configure any of the jobs because the
jenkins instance is owned by a qr person
he doesn't want to give developer any
administrative rights so the rights that
he set out by creating a developer role
and anybody who is tagged any user who's
tagged as a part of this developer role
would get the same kind of permissions
and these permissions can be you know
fine grain it can be a project specific
permissions as well but for now i just
demonstrated the high level permission
that i had set in
let me quickly log out of this user and
get back
as the admin user because i need to
continue with my demo with the developer
role that was created i have very very
less privileges one of the reasons for
jenkins being so popular as i mentioned
earlier is the bunch of plugins that is
provided by users or community users who
don't charge any money for these plugins
but it's got plugins for connecting
anything and everything so if you can
navigate to or if you can find jenkins
plugins
you would see index of over so many
plugins that is there all of these are
wonderful plugins whatever connectors
that you would need if you want to
connect jenkins to an aws instance or
you want to connect jenkins to a docker
instance or any of those containers you
would have a plug-in you can go and
search up if i want to connect jenkins
to bigbucket
bitbucket is one of the git servers
there's so many plugins that is
available okay so bottom line jenkins
without plugins is nothing so plugins is
the heart of jenkins for you to connect
or for in order to connect jenkins with
any of the containers or any of the
other tool sets you would need the
plugins if you want to connect or you
want to build a repository which has got
java and maven you would need to install
maven and jdk on your jenkins instance
if at all you're looking for a net build
or a microsoft build you would need to
have ms build installed on your on your
jenkins instance and the plugins that
will trigger ms build if at all you want
to listen to some server side web hooks
from github you will need github
specific plugins if you want to connect
jenkins to aws you need those plugins if
you want to connect to a docker instance
that is running anywhere in the world as
long as you have the url which is
publicly reachable you just have a
docker plug-in that is installed on your
jenkins instance sonar cube is one of
the popular static code analyzers so you
can connect a jenkins build you can
build a job on jenkins and push it to
sonar cube and get sonar cube to run
analysis on that and get back the
results in jenkins all of these works
very well because of the plugins now
with that let me connect our jenkins
instance to github i already have very
very simple java repository up on my
github instance so let me connect
jenkins to this particular github
instance and pull out a job that is put
up there all right so this is my very
very simple uh you know repository there
is there called hello java
and this is what is there in the repos
there is a hello hello.java application
that is here or a simple class file that
is there it's got just one line of
system dot out so this is already
present on github.com at this place and
this would be the
url for this repository
if i pick up the https url this is my
steepest url so what i would do is i
would connect my jenkins instance to go
to github provide my credentials and
pull out this repository which is on the
cloudhostedgithub.com
and get it to my jenkins instance and
then build this particular java file
i'm keeping the source code very very
simple it's just a java file how do i
build my java file how do i compile my
java file i just say java c and the name
of my
class file which is hello java and how
do i run my java file i would say java
and hello
okay so remember i don't need to install
any plugins now because uh what it needs
is a git plugin so if you remember when
we were doing the installation there was
a bunch of recommended plugins so git is
already installed on my system so i
don't need to install it again so let me
put up a new job here it says git job it
would be a freestyle project that's good
for me i would say okay
all right so the source code management
remember in the earlier examples we did
not use any source code because we were
just putting up some echo kind of uh
jobs we did not need any integration
with any of the source code systems so
now let me connect this so i'm going to
put up a source code and git would show
up because the plugin is already there
svn perforce any of those additional
source code management tools if at all
you would need just install those
plugins and jenkins connects wonderfully
well to all these particular source
control tools okay so i would copy the
https url from here i would say this is
the url that i'm supposed to
go and grab my source code from but all
right that sounds good but what is the
username and password so i'll have to
specify a username
and password all right so i would say
the username this is my username and
this is my https credential for my job
okay so this is my username and this is
my password i just save this i say add
and then i would say you know use this
credentials to go to github and then on
my behalf pull out a repository all
right if at all at this stage if there's
any error in terms of not able to
jenkins not able to find git or the git
dot exe or if my credentials are wrong
somewhere down here you would see a red
message saying that you know something
is not right you can just go ahead and
kind of fix that for now this looks good
for me i'm going to grab this
url what am i going to do this step
would pull the source code from the
github
and then what would be there as a part
of my build step
because this repository just has a java
file correct hello.java so in order to
for me to build this i would just say
execute windows batch command and i
would say java c
hello dot
java that is the way i would build my
java code and if i have to run it i
would just say java
hello
pretty simple two steps and this would
run after the repository contents are
fetched from github
so java c java that sounds good i would
say save this
and let me try to run this
okay if you see
there's a lot of you know it executes
kit on your behalf it goes out here it
provides my credentials and says you
know it pulls all my repository and by
default it will pull up the master
branch that is there on my repository
and it kind of builds this whole thing
java c hello java and it runs this
project java hello and there you see
this is the output that is there and if
at all you want to look at the contents
of the repository if you can go here
this is my
workspace
of my system hang on this is not right
okay good job if you see here this is my
hello.java this is the same program that
was there on my github repository
okay so this is a program that was there
on
github repository all right so this was
the same program that was here and
jenkins on our behalf went over all the
way to github pulled this repository
from there and then you know it brought
it down to my local system on my jenkins
instance it compiled it and it ran this
particular application
okay now that i have integrated jenkins
successfully with github for a simple
java application let me build a little
bit on top of it what i will do is i
have a maven based web application that
is up there as a repository in my
github so this is the repository that
i'm talking about it's called amv and
web app it's got it's a maven based
repository as you would know my one is a
very very simple java based
build tool that will allow you to run
various targets and it will compile it
will based upon the goals that you
specify it can compile it can run some
tests and you can you can build a war
file and even deploy it into some other
server for now what we're going to use
maven is just for building and creating
a package out of this particular web
application it contains a bunch of
things and what is important is just the
index.jsp it just contains an html file
that is there as a part of this web
application so from a perspective of
requirements now since i'm going to
connect jenkins with this particular
repository git we already have that set
we only need two other things one is
maven because jenkins will use maven so
in order to use maven jenkins would have
to have a maven installation that is
there on the jenkins box and in this
case the jenkins box is this laptop
and after i have my maven installed i
also need a tomcat server tomcat is a
very very simple web server that you can
freely download i'll let you know how to
quickly download and install the tomcat
alright so download maven first
and the various ways in which you can
kind of download this maven there is zip
files
binary zip files and archive files so
what i've done is i've just already
downloaded maven and if you see i've
unzipped it here so this is the folder
with which i have unzipped my maven so
as you know maven again is is a one open
source uh build tool so you'll have to
set in a few configurations and set up
the path so mvn hyphen iphone version if
i specify this after i set in my path my
one should work and if at all i echo m2
home which is nothing but the variable
environment variable specific to my
onenote it is already set here
so once you unzip maven just set this m2
home variable to the directory where you
unzip your i1 also just set the path to
this particular directory slash bin
because that is where your maven
executables are all found
all right so that's with maven and you
know since i've set the path and the
environment variable maven is running
perfectly fine on my system i just
verified it okay next one is a tomcat
server
download apache tomcat server 8.5 is
what i have on my system
so i'm just going to show you where to
download this from
this is where you download tomcat server
and um
i already have the server downloaded
again this doesn't need any installation
i just unzip it here
and it kind of has a bin and
configuration i have made some subtle
changes in the configuration first and
foremost tomcat server also by default
runs on port 8080 since we already have
our jenkins server running on port 8080
we cannot let tomcat run on the same
port there will be a port clash so what
i've done i have configured tomcat to
use a different port so if i go to this
configuration file here there is a
server.xml
let me open this up here
all right okay so this is the port by
default it will be 8080 i've just
modified it to 8081. so i've changed the
port on which my tomcat server would run
all right so that's one chain second
change when jenkins kind of tries to get
into my tomcat and deploy something for
someone he would need some
authentications so that he'll be alloyed
deployment by tomcat so for that i need
to create a user on tomcat and provide
this user credentials to my jenkins
instance
so i would go to
tomcatusers.xml file here
i have already created
a username called deployer and the
password is deployer and i've added a
role called manager hyphen script
manager hyphen script will allow
programmatic access to the tomcat server
so this is the role that is there so
using this credentials i will enable or
i'll empower jenkins to get into my
tomcat server and deploy my application
all right only these two things that is
required
let me just start my tomcat server first
so i get into my bin folder i open a
command prompt here and there's a
startup.bat
it's pretty fast it just takes a few
seconds yes there you go tomcat server
is up and running now this is running on
port 8081 so let me just check if that
looks good
so localhost
8081.
okay my tomcat server is up and running
that sounds good the user is already
configured on this that's also fine so
what i'll do as a part of my first job
my one is also installed on my system so
i'm good to use maven as a part of my
jenkins so i will put up a simple job
now
i will say job
mbn
web app i call this
freestyle job that's good
okay so this will be a git repository
what is the url of my git repository
is this guy
https url
okay
that's this url i will use the
credentials the old credentials that are
set up will work well because it's the
same git user that i'm kind of
connecting into
all right so now the change happens here
where after i get this since i said this
is a simple maven repository i will have
some maven targets to run
so the simple target first is
let me run maven package this creates a
war file
okay so mvn package is the target
package is the target so when whenever i
run this package it kind of creates it
it builds it it tests it and then
creates a package so this is all that is
required maybe let me try to save this
and let me first run this and see
if it connects well if there's any
problem with my war file or the war file
gets created properly
okay
wonderful
so it built a war file and if you see it
all shows you
what is the location where this war file
was generated
so this will be the workspace if you see
this this war file was successfully
built now i need to grab this particular
war file and then i would need to deploy
it into tomcat server
again i would need a small plugin to do
this because i need to connect tomcat
with my jenkins server
let me go ahead and
install the plugin for the container
deployment so i will go to manage
plugins
available
type in container
container container
deploy to container okay so let's put
this the plugin that i would need i will
install it without a restart
right seems to be very fast
nope sorry still installing
okay
it installed the plugin so if at all you
see this
if you go to my workspace
okay in the target folder
i would see this web application war
file that is already built
so i would need to configure this plugin
to pull up this war file and deploy it
onto the tomcat server for deploying
onto the tomcat server i will use the
credentials of the user that i've
created
okay so let me go to configure this
particular project
again and um
okay all this is good
so the package is good i'm gonna just
create a package that's all fine
now
add a post build step
so after the war file is built as a part
of this package directive let me use
this
deployment to container now this will
show up after you install the plugin so
deploy this one to the container
now what is that you're supposed to
specify you're supposed to specify the
what is the location
okay so this is a global uh you know
configuration that is there that will
allow you to
from the root folder it will pick up the
war file that is there so star star
forward slash star dot war that's good
for me
okay what is the context path context
path is nothing but just the name of an
application that you know under which it
will get deployed into the tomcat server
i will just say mvn web app
that's the name of my thing now i need
to specify what kind of a container that
i'm talking about
all right so the deployment would be for
this tomcat 8.5 is what i need
okay because the server that we have is
a tomcat 8.5 server that i have so this
would be the url so the credentials yes
i need to add a credential for this
particular
server so if you remember i had created
a credential
for my web application so let me just
find that
my tomcat server yes configuration of
this
okay so deployer and deployer username
is deployer password is deployer
okay so let me use that credential
i would say i would say add a new
credential jenkins credential the
username is deployer and the password is
deployer
so i would use this deployer credentials
for that and what is the url of my
tomcat instance
so this is the url of my tomcat instance
so take the war file that is fine found
in this particular
folder
and then you know context path is same
in web use the deployer deployment
credentials and get into this local host
which is there
8081 this is the tomcat server that is
running on my system and then go ahead
and deploy it
okay so that is all that is required so
i would say just save this
and let me run it now
okay it builds successfully built the
war file it is trying to deploy it and
looks like the deployment went ahead
perfectly well
so
the context path was mvn web app so if i
type in this
all right if at all i go ahead into my
tomcat server there would be a web apps
folder
you would see the
you know the date timestamp so this is
the file that get got recently copied
and this is the explorer version of our
application
so the application was built the source
code of this application was pulled from
the github server it was built locally
on the jenkins instance and then it was
pushed into a tomcat server which is
running on a different port which is
808.1 now for this demo i'm running
everything locally on my system but
assuming that you know this particular
tomcat instance was running on
some other server with some other
different ip address all that you've got
to go and change is the url of the
server
so this would be the server in case you
you already have that you know if you
have a tomcat server which is running on
some other machine that's all fine with
a different ipa that's all good enough
the whole bundle or the war file that
was built as a part of this jenkins job
gets transferred onto the other server
and gets deployed that's the beauty of
jenkins and automatic deployments or
other deployments using jenkins and
maven
distributed build or master slave
configuration in jenkins as you would
have seen you know we just have one
instance of jenkins server up and
running all the time and also i told you
that whenever any job that kind of you
know gets started on the jenkins server
it is little heavy on in terms of disk
space and the cpu utilization so which
kind of you know if at all you're in an
organization wherein you're heavily
reliant on the jenkins server you don't
want your jenkins server to go down so
that's where you kind of start
distributing the load that is there on
the jenkins server so you primarily have
a server which is just a placeholder or
like a master will take in all the kind
of jobs and what he'll do is based upon
trigger that has happened to the job or
whichever job needs to be built he if at
all he can delegate these jobs onto some
other machines or some other slaves you
know that's a wonderful thing to have
okay use case one use case two assuming
that you know if you have a jenkins
server that is running on a windows box
or on a linux one and if at all you have
a need where you need to build based
upon operating systems you have multiple
build configurations to support maybe
you need to build a windows you know
windows based dot net kind of a projects
where you would need a windows machine
to build this particular project you
also have a requirement where you want
to build linux linux based systems you
also have a mac you you support some
sort of an apps or something that is
built on mac os you would need to build
you know mac based system as well so how
are you going to support all these needs
so that's where in a beautiful concept
of master slave or you know primary and
delegations or agent and master comes
into play so typically you would have
one jenkins server who will just you
know configure with all the proper
authorizations users configurations and
everything is set up on this jenkins
server his job is just delegations he
will listen to some sort of triggers or
based upon the job that is coming in he
will if there is a way nice way of
delegating these jobs to somebody else
and you know taking back the results he
can control a lot of other systems and
these systems may not have a complete or
there's no need to put in a complete
jenkins installation all that you got to
do is have a very very simple runner or
a slave that is a simple jar file that
is run as a low priority thread or a
process within these systems so with
that you can have a wonderful
distributed build server that can be set
up and in case one of the servers goes
down your master would know that what
went down and kind of delegate the task
to somebody else so this is the kind of
distributed build or the master slave
configuration so what i'll do in this
exercise or in this demo is i'll set up
a simple slave but since i don't have
too many machines to kind of play around
what i'll do is i will set up a slave in
in one other folder within my hard drive
so i've got the c drive and d drive my
jenkins is on my c drive so what i do is
i would just use my e drive and set up a
very very simple slave out there i'll
just show you how to provision a slave
and how to connect to a slave and how to
delegate a job to that slave let me go
back to my jenkins master and configure
him to you know talk to an agent
so there are various ways in which this
client and server talk to each other
what i'm going to choose is something
called as jnlp java network launch
protocol so using this i would ensure
that you know the client and server talk
to each other so for that i need to
ensure that i kind of enable this jnlp
port so let me try to find out where is
that let me try this
okay yes
agents and by default this jnlp agent's
thing would be disabled so if you see
here there's a small help on this
so i'm going to use this jnlp which is
nothing but java network launch protocol
and you know i'll configure the master
and server to talk to each other using
jlp so for that i need to enable this
guy so i enable this guy instead of
making the by default the configuration
was disabled so i make him random i make
him you know enabled and i say save this
configuration
all right so now i've configured or has
made a setting for the master
so that the jlp
port is kind of opened up so let me go
ahead and you know create an agent
so i'll go to manage nodes so if you see
here there's only one master here so let
me provision a new node here
so this is the way you know in which you
bring up a new node you have to
configure it on the server jenkins would
put in some sort of security around this
particular
agent and let you know how to launch
this particular engine so that he can
connect to our jenkins master so i would
say new node i would give a name for my
node i would say windows
node because both of these are windows
only so that's fine i just give an
identifier saying that windows node i
would say this is a permanent agent i
will say okay
so if you see the name let me just copy
this name here with the description
number of executors since it's a slave
node and both of these are running on my
system i'll keep the number of executors
as one
that's fine remote root directory now
this is where let me just clarify this
since i have both my
my master is running on my c drive c
drive program files 86
or hang on not 86
c column program files
it is indeed 86
all right jenkins so this is where my
master is running so i don't want the c
drive what i'll do is i'll use something
called as a drive i have another drive
in my system but please visualize this
like you know you're running this on a
separate system altogether
so i create a folder here called jenkins
node and this is where i'm going to
place my or i'm going to provision my
slave
and i'm going to run him from here so
this is the directory in which i'm going
to provision my slave node so i'm going
to copy this here and that is the remote
root directory of your particular agent
or slave so i just copy it here the
label you know probably this is fine for
me
and usage how do you want to use this
guy
so i would don't want him to run all
kinds of jobs i will only build jobs
with label expressions that match this
particular node and so this is the label
of this node so in order for somebody to
kind of delegate any task to them they
will have to specify this particular
label so imagine this way if i have a
bunch of windows system i name it as
windows star
anything that says from windows i can
give a regular expression and say that
anything that matches windows run this
particular task there if i have some mac
machines i name all these mac agents as
a mac star or something like that and i
can delegate all tasks you know saying
that start with whatever starts with mac
this node run the mac jobs there
so you identify a node using the label
and then delegate the task there
all right so launch method you know we
will use java web start because we're
going to
we we're going to use jnlp protocol okay
that sounds good directory i think
nothing else is required availability
yes we'll keep this agent yep online as
much as possible that sounds good all
right let me save this
all right i'm just provisioning this
particular node now
so if i click on this node i get a bunch
of commands
along with an agent.jar
so this is the agent.jar that has to be
taken down to the other machine or the
slave node and from there i need to run
this along with a small security
credential so let me copy this whole
text here in my notepad
not bad plus plus is good for me
okay i copy this whole
path there i also want to download this
agent.jar
i would say yes
this agent.jar is the one that is
configured by our server so all the
details that is required for launching
this agent.jar is found in this
sorry for launching this agent is found
this agent.jar so typically i need to
take this jar file onto the other system
and then
kind of run it from there so
i have this alien.jar i copy this or
whether i cut this i come back to my
folder my jenkins node i paste it here
okay so now with this provisionagen.jar
and i need to use this whole command
ctrl a ctrl c and then launch this
particular agent so let me bring up a
command prompt right here
and then launched it so i'm saying in
the same folder where there is agent.jar
i'm going to launch this a particular
agent java hyphen jar agent.jar jnlp
this is the url of my server in case the
server and client are in different
locations or different ips you have to
specify the ipad address all this anyway
would show up
and then the secret and you know the
root folder of your jenkins or the slave
node
okay
so
something ran and then you know it says
it's connected very well it seems to
have connected very well so let me come
back to my
jenkins instance and see you know if you
told me you see earlier this was not
connected now let me refresh this guy
okay now these two guys are connected
provision are jenkins node and then i
copied all the credentials of the
slave.jar along with the launch code and
then took it to the other system and
kind of
ran it from there since i don't have
another system i've just got a separate
directory in another folder another
drive and i'm launching the agent from
here as long as this particular agent is
up and running or this command prompt is
up and running the agent would be
connected so once i close this the
connection goes down
all right so successfully you've
launched this particular agent now this
would be the home directory of this
jenkins node or the jenkins slave so any
task that i'm going to delegate to this
particular slave would all be run here
it'll create a workspace right here all
right so good
so let me just come back and let me kind
of put up a new task here i will say
that you know delegate job is good i say
freestyle project i'm going to create a
very very simple job here
i don't want it to connect to gate or
anything like that let me just create a
very very simple
echo
relegated to the
slave related to i don't like the word
slave delegated to
agent
put this way
all right so delegated to agent sounds
good now how am i going to ensure that
this particular job
runs on the agent or on the slave that i
have configured
right you see this if at all you
remember how we provisioned our
particular slave we give a label
right so now i'm going to put in a job
that will only match this particular
label
so i'm going to say that whatever
matches this you know windows label run
this job on that particular node so we
have only one node that's matching this
in a windows node so this job will be
delegated out there so i save this
and let me build this
this is again a very very simple job
there's nothing in this i just want to
demonstrate how to kind of delegate it
to an agent so if you see this
it runs successfully
and where is the workspace the workspace
is right inside our jenkins node it
created a new workspace delegated job it
put in here so my old or my primary
master job is in sql
program files under jenkins and this is
the slave job that was successfully run
very very simple but very very powerful
concept of master slave configuration or
distributed build and jenkins
okay approaching the final section where
we've done all this hard work in
bringing up our jenkins server
configuring it putting up some jobs on
it creating users and all this stuff now
we don't want this configuration to kind
of go away we want a very nice way of
ensuring that we backup all this
configuration and in case there is any
failure hardware crash or a machine
crash we would want to kind of restore
from the existing configuration that we
kind of backed up
so one quick way to do that would be or
one dirty way to do that would be just
you know take a complete backup of our
colon program files colon jenkins
directory because that's where our whole
jenkins configuration is present but we
don't want to do that let's use some
plugins for taking up a backup so let me
go to manage in cans
and click on available
and let me search for some back there
are a bunch of backup plugins so i would
recommend one of these plugins that i
specifically use
so this is the backup plugin so let me
go ahead and install this plugin
all right so we went ahead and installed
this plugin
so let me come back to my
manage plugins
stop this plugin is there
so
hang on backup manager so you will see
this option once you install this plugin
so first time i can you know do a setup
i would say back up this particular i'll
give a folder uh this folder is
pertaining to the folder where i want
jenkins to backup some data
and i would say the format should be zip
format is good enough let me give a name
or a template or a file name for my
you know backup this is good i want it
in verbose mode i don't want to shut on
my jenkins or should i shut it down no
okay one thing that you got to remember
is that whenever a backup happens if
there are too many jobs that is running
on the server
it can kind of slow down your uh jenkins
instance because it's it's in the
process of copying a few of those things
and if the files are being changed at
that moment it's little bit problematic
for jenkins so typically you back up
your servers only when there is very
less load or typically try to you know
bring it to a shutdown kind of a state
and then take a backup
all right so i'm going to back up all
these things you know i don't want to
exclude anything else i want the history
i want the maven artifacts
possibly i don't want this guy i would
just say save
and then i would say
back him up
so this would run a bunch of you know
steps and all the files that is required
as a part of this is pretty fast but
then if at all you have too many things
up on your server for now we didn't have
too many things up on our server but in
case you had too many things to kind of
backup this may take a while so let me
just pause this recording and get back
to you once the backup is complete so
there you go the backup was successful
created a backup of all the workspace
the configurations the users and you
know all that so all this is kind of
hidden down in this particular
zip file so at any instance if at all i
kind of crash my system for some
instance or say hard disk failure and i
bring up a new instance of jenkins i can
kind of use the backup plugin for
restoring this particular
configurations
so how do i do that i just come back to
my manager gains
come back to
backup manager and i will say restore
that's an or
jenkins configuration in this we are
going to talk about the maven here now
we will be talking about that how
exactly we can make use of maven here in
performing various kind of operations
whether it's a build compilation with
this kind of stuff there so let's talk
about it why exactly we use maven here
now meven is something which uh is a
kind of a build tool which is there for
most of the job is projects here so this
tool also helps us in building up the
source code by downloading some couple
of dependencies these dependencies are
something which is being configured by
the developers which a developer feels
that the project is dependent on and he
requires those dependencies to be
downloaded so uh this tool is
specifically used to build and manage
any kind of a job-based project whatever
the complexity of the topic or the
project is there so this tool will be
able to handle that particular
requirement or that project so it
simplifies the uh day-to-day work of a
java developer and helps them in their
projects for performing daily to daily
activities
right now meven also helps us in getting
the uh specific jar files for each and
every project so if you are going you
can pretty much make a jar file var file
or er file any kind of a package
mechanism you can follow for your maven
day so to download the dependencies we
don't have to actually go to the
official website of each and every
software you can easily get it uh the
dependencies of each and every
third-party binaries on the
mvnrepository.com this is a website
which is present on which if you visit
you will be able to download the
dependencies which is required by your
project or by your
specific
project over here so it totally depends
on how exactly you want to download and
you want to get together a specific
repository over here so
mvnrepository.com is the one if you
visit you will be able to download and
go through all the jar files dependent
jar files as independences which you
require for your current project
right so now what exactly is a maven all
about so let's see on that part
so
maven is a popular open source build
tool which is uh developed by the apache
group and the primary uh ownership of
this tool is to build publish and deploy
several projects at once movement is
written in java and it can be used to
build projects written in c shaft scala
ruby etc so apart from java these are
the different programming languages or
the tools which is supported by the
maven here for performing the build
activity so the tool is uh used for
build and management of any kind of a
job-based project it simplifies the
day-to-day uh work of a java developer
and helps them to automate most of the
compilation or build uh perspective
tasks on the projects
right
now maven is a kind of a bomb-based
project so it also known as an project
object model and it focuses on of
simplification and standardization of
the building process in the process it
take cares of all the followings here
bills dependencies reports
distribution releases mailing list so
all these things are being taken care as
in this particular process here and
ultimately it's an availability inside
the maven that how the overall build
process needs to be automated and
standardized here so all these
particular mechanisms is can be followed
as such over here so that we can have a
good
standards and the simplifications
implemented as such here
now what exactly is a maven repository
all about
so maven repository is uh something
which
is a
kind of a directory or it's kind of a
location where we have all the jar files
packaged all together in a single
location so depending on the software
which you want to download the dependent
java files can be downloaded from there
so the metadata refers to the pom files
relevant to each project here this
metadata is what allows maven to
download the dependencies now there are
three type of repositories from where we
can download the dependencies the first
one is the local repository second one
is the remote repository and the third
one is the central repository so these
are the primary three type of
repositories which is available there
for a specific maven over here
so whatever repository you want to
follow you want to access you can pretty
much access it and you can go with that
right
now the local repository will be primary
present onto your pc that's the way that
how it's present there and the
particular remote repository is
something which you can store on any
remote machine or remote server and the
central repository is something which
you can have it onto the internet so
usually the central repositories is
something in which we can actually host
our different kind of dependencies and
the jar files over there
so local repository on the machine of
the developer where the project material
is saved so all the particular
dependencies jar file will be available
on your local machine remote machine is
the location where you can actually
store all your particular dependencies
from where you can download these
dependencies whenever you require it so
this and repositories work similar to
the central repository whenever anything
is needed from the remote repository
it's first downloaded if into your local
repository and then it will be utilized
so if you feel that the dependency is
something which is not there in the
local it will be first downloaded from
the remote repository and then it will
be utilized or will be referenced onto
the local machine there
and central repository is refers to the
main community repository there where
you will be able to see each and every
dependency present on that repository so
maven downloads the repositories from
here in the local repository whenever
they're needed or whenever required all
these dependencies are cached locally
from where it will be referenced in the
next or you know whenever we want to
refer that we will be able to do that
particular reference easily on that part
so this is the way that how the three uh
particular repositories or movement
repositories really helps us for
performing various kind of automations
as such here
right now what are the basic concepts of
maven here so some of the couple of
basic concepts which is present in maven
is like for the first time we have the
project object model so project bomb
reference to the xml file which has all
the information regarding the project
how this particular project should be
built up how the different build process
should be automated there it also has a
description of the project details
regarding the versioning version
information is also stored as such in
this xml file in this
particular form reference file as such
over here
the xml file is which is there in the
project home directory so maven is uh
something which search for the palm file
in the current directory if it's able to
find that particular pom file so it will
execute or it will proceed with the
build step otherwise they it will hold
there itself so this spawn file is very
important because it will act as an kind
of a build script and primary the maven
tool will be able to process each and
everything which is configured as such
in this
specific xml file there and according to
that only it will function or it will
proceed further
right now second thing is the
dependencies and repositories so
dependencies are usually refers to the
java files so the java libraries which
we need in our into our particular
project so while uh working on the
project we may be having the dependency
on couple of dependencies so these
dependencies we have to actually
download or we have to actually refer
and once these a particular information
or these details are referred so what
will happen that uh we need to download
these specific dependencies from the
particular maven repositories so if the
dependencies are not present in your
local repository then maven will try to
download it from the central repository
and cache it into your local repository
but first of all it will look on into
the local repository and if it is not
present in local then it will go to the
remote or the central repository
then we have build life cycles and phase
and goals there so build life cycles
consists of the sequence of build phases
and each field phase consists of
sequence of goals here now each goal is
responsible for performing a specific
task when a phase is uh running all the
goals related to that phase and its
plugins are also used to following the
compilation preparing the artifacts
downloading the dependencies all
different things being done by the
plugins here
then we have the build profile so build
profiles refers to a set of
configuration values now generally we
have the generic build process for all
the environments all the particular code
base there but sometimes we do have some
kind of a differences there so that is
where we can go for the profiles because
a specific profile can have its own
configuration and whatever it's required
for the build process we can have
different different configurations
stored inside the maven build script
here
then with different build profiles are
added to the pom files and which enables
the different uh build as such here so
depending on these profiles we can
actually decide that how we need to
proceed with the build process and how
the different kind of build automations
needs to be performed here then a build
profile helps in customizing the build
for the different environments so that
also we can perform as such while work
forming or while working on the
different components and the different
management here so a build profile is
something which you can configure you
can utilize and depending on that build
profile we will be deciding whether to
proceed further or how to decide on that
particular factor so these are something
which we need to take care or we need to
work according to see which we can
decide that how the specific
configurations and specific automation
needs to be performed here
now
usually when we go for the uh maven
there so we have to use some couple of
maven plugins now the goal of using
these uh specific plugins is to automate
some of the basic stuff like compilation
creating the var file creating the java
file so when we are using the plugins we
don't have to configure the steps or
write the steps that how these uh
specific plugins should be installed or
should be referenced it's ultimately the
internal configurations which we are
looking forward or which we are using
while working on these specific plugins
so you can download some couple of
plugins using which we will be able to
decide that how a specific goals needs
to be achieved here so maven has its own
standard plugins that can be utilized so
if uh you know want to go for a custom
one so you can do that but pretty much
you can go for the default one and you
can pretty much have
some specific goals executed with the
help of these build plugins
now next thing is the maven architecture
so in maven what happens that uh
let's talk about the basic architecture
of maven here so
the maven executable when it's deployed
so it usually uh reads the palm.xml file
which is the build script here now once
the specific found xml file is being
read out so it will process the
components it will uh you know download
or it will process the dependencies
plugins life cycles phases and goals and
even the build profiles and uh if any
kind of interaction is required so it
will try to connect to the central
repository or remote repository and
according to that it will provide the
information and provide the details as
such so mu and repository is something
which is very important because it's
ultimately trying to connect to the
maven repository and try to achieve the
various kind of automation here
so it's very important because
ultimately it's trying to help us to go
for the
complete end-to-end build automation
when we'll go for a specific bomb based
build automation
so movement is executable will read the
palm of excel file then download the
dependencies defined into the power xml
file and that uh dependencies are cached
locally from the remote or the central
repository now then uh create and
generate a remote report according to
the requirement and execute the life
cycles phases goals plugins etc so it
will process the pawn rectangle file
there and whatever the plugins and goals
or the life cycles which is configured
there step by step each of them will be
executed into a sequence here now let's
talk about the overall build life cycle
of the maven here so what happens that
uh the maven build life cycle is
something which is a kind of a
collection of different steps there and
this is something which is followed to
perform a build automation for a
specific project so they are pretty much
three steps which is being done so first
one is the default so it handles the
project deployment there second handles
the project cleaning which is a clean
there and then we have site so it
handles the creation of the project
sites documentation there
so these are the three built in
particular life cycles which is
available there at the wave level which
you can utilize to perform a various
kind of particular steps execution for
your project
all right so the build cycle has uh the
different build phases or stages there
because when we are performing a build a
variety of things needs to be performed
over here so the first one is the
compile then test compile is there so
compilation is there for the source file
and test compile is there for the test
cases test will execute the test cases
package will package the bundle then we
have the integration test to run the
integration test cases then we have the
verify then install goal is there and
the last one is the deploy which is
there to deploy the artifacts to the
artifactory so all these things are the
different phases and the stages which is
being followed as per a specific build
here so during these builds these are
the different phases and these stages
which we normally follow for performing
the build automation
now what is the exactly advantage of a
specific uh maven here so that is
something which we need to talk about
that how the particular automation needs
to be done or how we can actually go for
the configurations where we feel that
yes we want to perform or we want to
take certain benefits out of the
implementation of maven here
so for that what happens that we have to
see that the various kind of uh benefits
the first one is that apache maven helps
manage all the processes there such as
building documentation releasing and
distribution in project management here
so the tool simplifies the process of
project building it increases the
performance of the project and the
building process all together and the
task of downloading jar files and other
dependencies is also done automatically
we don't have to indulge in any kind of
download part as such manually over here
right and even provides easy access to
all the required information so maven
makes it easy for a specific developer
to build a project in the different
environment so we don't have to worry
about the environment we don't have to
worry about the infrastructure nothing
is required everything is available
there inside this package and you know
depending on the particular you can
write the source code on one machine and
you can pretty much do the build on
another machine and this is the reason
how the build automation really happens
on the first place because the developer
is writing the source code in one
location and the same code is deployed
onto the uh particular or built onto
this jenkins or any kind of build tool
there
right in maven you can easily add new
dependencies so you must write the
particular dependencies in the form file
so if you feel that you want to download
some particular dependencies so all you
have to do is that you have to put that
dependency into the
specific bond.xml file there and
depending on that the execution will be
really performed and executed as a chair
right so let's talk about the demo now
so let's see that how exactly we can go
for this demo and we can perform the
various kind of automations
so this is the virtual machine which we
have here on which the maven is already
installed so we can run like mvn
so maven will be available as in three
point six point three here now i'm going
to run a particular command called uh
mvn archetype generate here
let me create a directory here
our temp directory
and to perform this activity over there
so mvn
arc type
generate
now once we run that so what will happen
that it will uh download some of the
binaries there because uh ultimately
what we are trying to do is that we are
trying to generate a new project like a
maven project so a couple of uh
particular plugins will be downloaded by
the maven executable so that it can
achieve that particular execution so we
just have to wait for downloading all
these values now here it's trying to
give us a particular attributes like
it's asking the different attributes
over here so what exactly we want to
configure so if you want to configure
you can provide that details otherwise
you can
perform or whatever the setup you want
to perform now here it's asking for the
version so which kind of version we want
to follow so i'm going to follow like
five here so i'll press five
then a group id which is there so um
it's basically a kind of a group
mechanism so i can say like com
dot simply learn so that's the value
which i'm providing here artifate id i
can make it like a
sample project or something like that i
can do
so that will be the artifact uh
id which is there so
version i'm keeping the same only so
and uh yeah so package same here
so i just want to create so i'll just
provide the value called yes and enter
so with this what will happen that a
sample project will be created here
right so whatever the artifact id you
provided so according to that the
project is created in this directory so
you have to go into this directory and
see that what exactly the files are
created there so you have the power.xml
file now this bound.xml file when i open
so you can see here that there are some
attributes like you can have the values
related to what version group id you
want to follow so this is a group id
this is the artifact id so this is jar
file by default you can change it
according to your requirement and this
is the version and if you feel that you
want to do the changes to the name that
also you can perform here so by default
the junit dependency is added but if you
want to keep on adding your own custom
dependencies you will be able to do that
now in this case if you run like mvn
clean install
so it will be considered as in
particular maven project a pawn.xml file
is already there present in the local
directory so according to that the
execution of the steps will be performed
and according to that you will be able
to get some desired values here so
ultimately in the target directory you
will be able to see that some couple of
jar file or a specific jar file is
generated here so you can see that in
the target directory this jar file or
this artifact is generated here so this
is a way that how we can actually go for
a generic one like a new
particular project and later on you can
depending on your uh understanding you
can keep on adding or you can keep on
modifying the dependencies and that's
how you can get the final result there
so that's it for this demo uh in which
we have find out that how exactly we can
go for a particular project uh
preparation with the help of mvn
executable
so that's it for this demo thanks right
so that was the demo in which we uh saw
that how exactly we can go for the
movement and we can execute some build
uh process related to maven there are
you exploring test automation are you
wondering why everyone is talking about
selenium around you do you want to know
what selenium is all about if yes this
is the video for you all right so let's
get started manual testing a definition
if you can say a manual testing involves
the physical execution of test cases
against various applications and to do
what to detect bugs and errors in your
product it is one of the primitive
methods of testing a software this was
the only method which we knew of earlier
it is execution of test cases without
using any automation tools it does not
require the knowledge of a testing tool
obviously because everything is done
manually also you can practically test
any application since you are doing a
manual testing so let's take an example
so say we have a use case you are
testing say a facebook application and
in facebook application let's let's open
the facebook application and say create
an account this is your web page which
is under test now now as a tester what
would you do you would write multiple
test cases to test each of the
functionalities on this page you will
use multiple data sets to test each of
these fields like the first name the
surname mobile number or the new
password and you will also test multiple
links what are the different links on
this page like say forgotten account or
create a new page so these are the
multiple links available on the web
pages also you look at each and every
element of the web page like your radio
buttons like your drop down list apart
from this you would do an accessibility
testing you would do a performance
testing for this page or say a response
time after you say click on the login
button literally you can do any type of
tests manually once you have these test
cases ready what do you do you start
executing this test cases one by one you
will find bugs your developers are going
to fix them and you will need to rerun
all these test cases one by one again
until all the bugs are fixed and your
application is ready to ship now if one
has to run test cases with hundreds of
transactions or the data sets and repeat
them can you imagine the amount of
effort required in that now that brings
us to the first demerit of the manual
testing manual testing is a very time
consuming process and it is very boring
also it is very highly error prone why
because it is done manually and human
mistakes are bound to happen since it's
a manual executions tester's presence is
required all the time one is to keep
doing manual steps step by step again
all the time he also has to create
manual reports group them format them so
that we get good looking reports also
send these reports manually to all
stakeholders then collection of logs
from various machines where you have run
your tests consolidating all of them
creating repositories and maintaining
them and again since it's all as a
manual process there is a high chance of
creating manual errors there scope of
manual testing is limited for example
let's say regression testing ideally you
would want to run all the test cases
which you have written but since it's a
manual process you would not have the
luxury of time to execute all of them
and hence you will pick and choose your
test cases to execute that way you're
limiting the scope of testing also
working with large amount of data
manually is impractical which could be
the need of your application what about
performance testing you want to collect
metrics on various performance measures
as a part of your performance testing
you want to simulate multiple loads on
application under test and hence
manually performing these kind of tests
is not feasible and to top it all up say
if you are working in an agile model
where code is being churned out by
developers testers are building their
test and they are executing them as and
when the bills are available for testing
and this happens iteratively and hence
you will need to run this test multiple
times during your development cycle and
doing this manually definitely becomes
very tedious and boring and is this the
effective way of doing it not at all so
what do we do we automate it so this
tells us why we automate one for faster
execution two to be less error prone and
three the main reason is to help
frequent execution of our test so there
are many tools available in the market
today for automation one such tool is
selenium birth of selenium much before
selenium there were various tools in the
market like say rft and qtp just to name
a few popular ones selenium was
introduced by gentleman called jason
huggins way back in 2004. he was an
engineer at thoughtworks and he was
working on a web application which
needed frequent testing he realized the
inefficiency in manually testing this
web application repeatedly so what he
did was he wrote a javascript program
that automatically controlled the
browser actions and he named it as
javascript test runner later he made
this open source and this was renamed as
the selenium core and this is how
selenium came into existence and since
then selenium has become one of the most
powerful tool for testing web
applications so how does selenium help
so we saw all the tea merits of manual
testing so we can say by automation of
test cases one selenium helps in speedy
execution of test cases since manual
execution is avoided the results are
more accurate no human errors since your
test cases are automated human resources
required to execute automated test cases
is far less than manual testing because
of that there is a lesser investment in
human resources it saves time and you
know time is money it's cost effective
as selenium is an open source it is
available free of cost early time to
market since you save effort and time on
manual execution your clients will be
merrier as you would be able to ship
your product pretty fast lastly since
your test cases are automated you can
rerun them any point of time and as many
times as required so if this tool offers
so many benefits we definitely want to
know more detail about what selenium is
selenium enables us to test web
applications on all kind of browsers
like internet explorer chrome firefox
safari edge opera and even the headless
browser selenium is an open source and
it is platform independent the biggest
reason why people are preferring this
tool is because it is free of cost and
the qtp and the rfd which we talked
about are chargeable selenium is a set
of tools and libraries to facilitate the
automation of web application as i said
it is not a single tool it has multiple
components which we'll be seeing in
detail in some time and all these tools
together help us test the web
application you can run selenium scripts
on any platform it is platform
independent why because it is primarily
developed in javascript it's very common
for manual testers not to have in-depth
programming knowledge so selenium has
this record and replay back tool called
the selenium id which can be used to
create a set of actions as a script and
you can replay the script back however
this is mainly used for demo purposes
only because selenium is such a powerful
tool that you should be able to take
full advantage of all its features
selenium provides support for different
programming languages like java python
c-sharp ruby so you can write your test
scripts in any language you like one
need not know in-depth or advanced
knowledge of these languages also
selenium supports different operating
systems it has supports for windows macs
linux even ubuntu as well so you can run
your selenium test on any platform of
your choice
and hence selenium is the most popular
and widely used automation tools for
automating your web applications
selenium set of tools so let's go a
little more deeper into selenium as i
said selenium is not a single tool it is
a suite of tools so let's look at some
of the major components or the tools in
selenium and what they have to offer so
selenium has four major components one
selenium id it's the most simplest tool
in the suite of selenium it is
integrated development environment
earlier selenium ide was available only
as a firefox plugin and it offered a
simple record and playback functionality
it is a very simple to use tool but it's
mainly used for prototyping and not used
for creating automation in the real-time
projects because it has its own
limitations like any other record and
replay tool selenium rc this is nothing
but selenium remote control it is used
to write web application test in
different programming language what it
does it it basically interacts with the
browser with the help of something
called as rc server and how it interacts
its uses a simple http postgate request
for communication this was also called
as selenium 1.0 version but it got
deprecated in selenium 2.0 version and
was completely removed in 3.0 and it was
replaced by webdriver and we will see in
detail as why this happened selenium
webdriver this is the most important
component in the selenium suite it is a
programming interface to create and
execute text test cases it is obviously
the successor of the selenium rc which
we talked about because of certain
drawbacks which rc had so what webdriver
does is it interacts with the browsers
directly unlike rc where the rc required
a server to interact with the browser
and the last component is the selenium
grid so selenium grid is used to run
multiple test scripts on multiple
machines at the same time so it helps
you in achieving parallel execution
since the selenium web driver with you
can only do sequential execution grid is
what comes into picture where you can do
your parallel execution and why is
parallel execution important because in
real time environment you always have
the need to run test cases in a
distributed environment and that is what
grid helps you to achieve so all this
together helps us to create robust web
application test automation and we will
go in detail about each of these
components so before that let's look at
the history of selenium version so what
it's selenium version comprised of it
had an ide rc and grid and as i said
earlier there were some disadvantages of
using rc so rca was on its path of
deprecation and web driver was taking
its path so if you look at selenium 2
version it had an earlier version of
webdriver and also the rc so they
co-existed from tree dot onwards rc was
completely remote and web driver took
its place there is also a four dot
version around the corner and it has
more features and enhancement some some
of the features which are talked about
are w3c webdriver standardization
improved ide and improved grid now let's
look at each of the components in the
selenium suite selenium ide is the most
simplest tool in the suite of selenium
it is nothing but an integrated
development environment for creating
your automation scripts it has a record
and playback functionality and is a very
simple and easy to use tool it is
available as a firefox plugin and a
chrome extension so you can use either
of this browser to record your test
scripts it's a very simple user
interface using which you can create
your scripts that interact with your
browser the commands created in the
scripts are called selinese commands and
they can be exported to the supported
programming language and hence this code
can be reused however this is mainly
used for prototyping and not used for
creating automation for your real-time
projects why because of its own
limitation which any other record and
replay tool has so a bit history of
selenium id so earlier selenium id was
only a firefox extension so we saw that
ide was available since the selenium
version one selenium ide died with the
firefox version 55 that was id was
stopped supporting from 55 version
onwards and this was around 2017 time
frame however very recently all new
brand selenium id has been launched by
apply tools and also they have made it a
cross browser so you can install the
extension on chrome as well as as an
add-on on firefox browser so they
completely revamped this ide code and
now they have made it available on the
github under the apache 2.0 license and
for the demos today we'll be looking at
the new id now with this new ide also
comes a good amount of features
reusability of test cases better
debugger and most importantly it
supports parallel test case execution so
they have introduced a utility called
selenium side runner that allows you to
run your test cases on any browser so
you can create your automation using
idec on chrome or firefox but through
command prompt using your site runner
you can execute this test cases on any
browser thus by achieving your cross
browser testing control flow statement
so initially in the previous versions of
idea there were control flow statements
available however one had to install a
plugin to use them but now it is made
available out of box and what are these
control flow statements these are
nothing but your if else conditions the
while loops the switch cases so on it
also has an improved locator
functionality that means it provides a
failover mechanism for locating elements
on your web page so let's look at how
this id looks and how do we install it
and start working on that so for that
let me take you to my browser so say
let's go to the firefox browser so on
this browser i already have the id
installed so when you already have an id
installed you will see an icon here that
says selenium id and how do you install
this you simply need to go to your
firefox add-ons here where it says find
more extension so just type in
selenium id and search for this
extension so in the search results you
see the selenium id just click on that
and now since i've already installed
here it says remove otherwise for you it
is going to give you an add button here
just click on the add button it will
install this extension once it is
installed you should be able to see this
selenium ide icon here okay so now let's
go ahead and launch this id so when i
click on that it is going to show me a
welcome page where it's going to give me
a few options the first option is it
says record a new test case in a new
project so straight away if you choose
this option you can start recording a
test case in which case it's going to
just create a default project for you
which you can save it later then open an
existing project so you can open if you
already have a saved project create a
new project and close so i already have
an existing project with me for the demo
purpose so i'll go ahead and open that
so i'll say open existing project and i
have created a simple script what the
script does is it logs me into the
facebook using a dummy user mail your
sorry username and password that's all
it's very simple script with few lines
and this is what it's going to do so
what we will simply do is we'll just run
the script and see how it works for that
i'm just going to reduce the test
execution speed so that you should be
able to see every step of execution here
all right so what i'll do now here is
i'll just adjust this window and i'll
just simply say run current test all
right so i'll just get this side by side
so that you should be able to see what
exactly the script is doing okay so now
you are able to see both the windows
okay so now it's going to type in your
user email here there you go and now it
will enter the password and it has
clicked on the login button so it's
going to take a while to say login and
since these are the dummy ids it is you
are not able to log in here and you are
going to see this error window fine that
is what is the expected output here now
on the id if you look here after i
execute the test case every statement or
every command which i have used here is
colored coded in green so that means
this particular step was executed
successfully and then here in the log
window it will give you a complete log
of this test case right from the first
step till the end and your end result it
says fb login which is my test case name
completed successfully let's look at few
components of this id the first one is
the menu bar so let's go to our id all
right so the menu bar is right here on
the top so here is your project name so
either you can add a new project here or
rename your project so since we already
have this project which is named as
facebook and then on the right you have
options to create a new project open an
existing project or save the current
project and then comes our toolbar so
using the options in this toolbar you
can control the execution of your test
cases so first one here is the recording
button so this is what you use when you
start recording your script and then on
the left you have two options here to
run your test cases the first one is run
all tests so in case you have multiple
test cases written here you can execute
them one by one sequentially by using
this run all test else what you can do
is if you just want to run your current
test this is what you would use then id
has this debugger option which you can
use to do a step execution so say for
example now whenever i run the script
its going to execute each and every
command here sequentially so instead if
i just select the first command and say
do step execution all right so what it
does is the moment it finishes the first
command which is opening of facebook
right i think which is already done here
yeah all right so once this is done it
is going to wait immediately on the
second command and it says pause
debugger so from here you can do
whatever you would like to do in case
you want to change the command here you
can do that you can pause your execution
you can resume your execution here right
you can even completely stop your test
execution or you can just select this to
run the rest of the test case so if we
say run the test case what it is going
to do is it's just going to simply go
ahead and complete the com complete the
test case now there is another option
here which is you see the timer there
which says test execution speed so to
execute your test cases in the speed you
want say whenever you are developing an
automation script right and say you want
to give a demo so you need to control
the speed sometimes so that the viewer
is able to exactly see all the steps
which is being performed and this gives
you an option to control that complete
execution right so do you see the
grading here so we have somewhere from
fast to completely slow execution so the
previous demo which i showed was i
controlled the speed and then i executed
it so that we could see every command
how it is being executed all right so
what's the next this is called as an
address bar so whichever wherever
whenever you enter an url here that is
where you want to conduct your test and
another thing what it does is it keeps a
history of all the urls which you have
used for running your test then here is
where your script is recorded so each
and every instruction is displayed here
in the order in which you have recorded
the script and then if you look here you
have something called as login reference
so now log is an area where it records
each and every step of your command as
in when they get executed right so if
you see here it says open https
facebook.com and ok so that means this
command was executed successfully and
after the complete test case is done it
gives you whether the test case passed
or failed so in case there is a failure
you will immediately see this test case
is filled in red color also there is
something called as reference here for
example say if i click on any of this
command the reference tab what it is
going to show me is a details of this
command which i have used in the script
it gives you the details of the command
as well as what the arguments have been
used or how how is that you need to be
using this particular command okay so
now what we'll do is let's go ahead and
write a simple script using this id so
with this you will get an idea how do we
actually record scripts in id so for
that i have a use case here a very very
simple use case so what we will do is we
will open amazon dot in then we will
search simply search for say product
iphone and once we get that search page
where all your iphones are displayed we
will just do an asset on the title of
the page simple all right so let's do
that so first thing what i need is an
url okay so first let me go to my
firefox browser here and say amazon.com
so why i'm doing this just to simply get
the right url absolute url path here and
so that i don't make any mistakes while
typing in the url okay so i got this so
let me close all these windows i don't
need any of this let's minimize this all
right so here what i'll do in the tests
tab i'll say add a new test and name
this test as uh amazon search
done i'll say add now i'll enter this
url which i just copied it from my
browser okay and then i'll just say
start recording so what it
did was since i've entered the url in
this address box it just opened the
amazon dot in url now let's do our test
case so in my test case what i said was
i want to search for iphone once i have
this i'm just going to click on my
search button so now this gives me a
list of all iphones and then i said i
want to add an assertion on the title of
this page so for me to do that what id
gives me an option is i have to just
right click anywhere on this page and
you'll see the selenium id options here
so in this i will select assert title
and then i will close this browser so
that kind of completes my test case so
now take a look at all the steps which
is created for me so it says open slash
because i have already provided the url
here so either you can replace it with
your regular url or you can just leave
it as it is so what i will do since this
is going to be a proper script and i
might be using this to run it from a
command prompt also so i'll just replace
this target with the actual url and then
what it is doing it is setting a window
size then there are whatever i did on
that particular url on that website it
has recorded all the steps for me so
this is where it says type into this
particular text box which is my search
box and what did it type iphone this was
the value which i entered now there was
one more feature which i told you in
this new ide which had which i said it
has a failover mechanism for your
locating techniques now that is what
this is now if you look here this id is
equal to tab search textbook this is
nothing but that search box where we
entered the text iphone and it has
certain identification through which
this ide identifies that web element and
that has multiple options to select that
particular search box so right now what
it has used is id is equal to two tab
search box however if you know the
different locating techniques you will
be able to see here that it has other
techniques also which it has identified
like the name and the css and the xpath
so how does this help in failovers say
tomorrow if amazon dot in website
changes the id of this element right you
are not going to come and rewrite the
scripts again instead by using the same
script what it will do is if this
particular id fails if it is unable to
find the element using the first locator
which is the id it simply moves to the
next available ones and it tries to
search for that element until one of
this becomes true that is what was the
failure mechanism which has got added
now it's a very brilliant feature
because most of our test cases break
because of element location techniques
well let's come back to this so then we
added an assert title right so what is
assert title here it simply captures the
title of that particular page and it
checks this is all very simple test case
so what we will do now is we will stop
the recording and then i have also given
a close browser so right now what i will
do is i'll just comment this out why
because if i just run this test case
it's going to be very fast and you might
not be able to catch the exact command
execution what has happened all right so
right now i'll just disable it so that
it will just do all these test cases and
it just stays there without closing the
browser so now i'll just say run the
current testing so your amazon in is
launched
okay it is typed in the iphone it's also
clicked on the search so it is done so
now if you look here since we are in the
reference tab it is not able to show so
let's go to the log and now let's see
the lock so it's going to be a running
lock so if you notice here the previous
examples which we have run for facebook
is also in the same lock so we will have
to see the log from running amazon
search because that's our test case so
if you see here every command line right
was executed successfully assert title
was also done and your test case was
executed successfully so it passed now
what we will do is on this assert title
i'll just modify this
and let's say just add some text i just
add double s here now this by
intentionally i am going to fail this
test case just to show you that whenever
there is a test case failure how does
the id behaves and how do you get to
know the failures all right so i'll just
run the disk test case again so before
that let's close the previous
window all right done and now
here i'll also uncomment the close
because anyway it's a failure which i am
going to see which i should be able to
see it in the logs so i'll close the
browser after the execution of test case
okay so let's simply go and run the test
case okay amazon.com is launched it
should search for iphone now yeah there
you go all right
now it should also close the browser yes
it has closed the browser and it has
failed now see here now this is the line
where our command filled why because the
expected title was not there and if you
look in the logs it says your assert
title on amazon.in failed actual result
was something different and it did not
match with what we had asked it for so
this is how simple it is to use your id
to create your automation scripts so we
saw all the components of id we saw the
record button then i showed you the
toolbar i showed you the editor box and
also the test execution log so now let's
come to what are the limitations of this
id with ide you cannot export your
scripts your test scripts to web driver
scripts this support is not yet added
but it is in the works data driven
testing like using your excel files or
reading data from the csv files and
passing it to the script this capability
is still not available also you cannot
connect to database for reading your
test data or perform any kind of
database testing with selenium webdriver
yes you can also unlike selenium
webdriver you do not have a good
reporting mechanism with the ide like
say for example test ng or repotential
so that brings us to the next component
of the suite which is selenium rc
selenium remote control so selenium rc
was developed by paul hammond he
refactored the code which was developed
by jason and was credited with jason as
a co-creator of selenium selenium server
is written in java it is used to write
web application test in different
programming languages as it supports
multiple programming languages like your
java c perl python and ruby it interacts
with the browser with the help of an rc
server so this rfc server uses a simple
http get and post request for
communication and as i said earlier also
selenium rc was called as selenium 1.0
version but it got dedicated in selenium
2.0 and was completely removed in 3.0
and it got replaced by what webdriver
and we'll see why this happened and what
was that issue which we had with the rc
server so this is the architecture of
selenium remote control at a very high
level so when jason huggins introduced
selenium you know the tool was called as
javascript program and then that was
also called as a selenium core so every
html has a javascript statements which
are executed by web browser and there is
a javascript engine which helps in
executing this command now this rca had
one major issue now what was that issue
say for example you have a test script
say test.javascript here which you are
trying to access elements from anywhere
from the google.com domain so what used
to happen is every element which is
accessible e are the elements which can
belong only to google.com domain let's
say for example mail the search or the
drive so any elements from this can be
accessible through your test scripts
however nothing outside the domain of
say google.com in this case was
accessible say for example if your test
scripts wanted to access something from
yahoo.com this was not possible and this
is due to the security reasons obviously
now to overcome that the testers what
they had to do was they had to install
the selenium core and the web server
which contained your web application
which is under test on the same machine
and imagine if you have to do this for
every machine which is under test this
is not going to be feasible or even
effective all the time and this issue is
called as a same origin policy now what
the same origin policy issue says is it
prohibits a javascript from accessing
elements or interacting with scripts
from a domain different from where it is
launched and this is purely for the
security measure so if you have written
a scripts which can access your
google.com or anything related to
google.com these scripts cannot access
any elements outside the domain like as
we said in the example yahoo.com this
was the same origin policy now to
overcome this what this gentleman did
was he created something called a
selenium remote control server to trick
the browser in believing that your core
your selenium core and your web
application under test are from the same
domain and this is what was the selenium
remote control so if you look at again a
high level architecture or how did this
actually work first you write your test
scripts which is here right in any of
the supported language like your php or
your java or python and before we start
testing we need to launch this rc server
which is a separate application so this
selenium server is responsible for
receiving the cellini's commands and
these salinis commands are the ones
which you have written in your script it
interprets them and reports the result
back to your test so all that is done to
your rc server the browser interaction
which happens through rc server right
from here to your browser so this
happens through a simple http
post and get request and that is how
your rc server and your browser
communicate and how exactly this
communication happens this rc server it
acts like a proxy so say your test
scripts ask to launch a browser so what
happens is this commands goes to your
server and then your rc server launches
the browser it injects the javascript
into the browser once this is done all
the subsequent calls from your test
script right from your test scripts to
your browser goes through your rc and
now upon upon receiving these
instruction your selenium core executes
this actual commands as javascript
commands on the browser and then the
test results are displayed back from
your browser to your rc to your test
scripts so the same cycle gets repeated
right until the complete test case
execution is over so for every command
what you write in your javascript here
or your test script here goes through a
complete cycle of going through the rc
server to the browser collecting the
results again from the rc server back to
your test scripts so this cycle gets
repeated for every command until your
complete test execution is done so rc
had definitely a lot of shortcomings and
what are those so rc server needs to be
installed before running any test
scripts which we just saw so that was an
additional setup since it acts as a
mediator between your commands which is
your salinis commands and your browser
the architecture of rc is complicated
why because of its intermediate rc
server which is required to communicate
with the browser the execution of
commands takes very long it is lower we
know why because every command in this
takes a full trip from the test script
to your rc server to the core engine to
the browser and then back to the same
route which makes your overall test
execution very slow lastly the aps
supported by rc are very redundant and
confusing so rc does have a good number
of aps however it is less object
oriented so they are redundant and
confusing say for example say if you
want to write into a text box how and
when to use a type key command or just a
type command is always confusing another
example is some of the mouse commands
using a click or a mouse dot both kind
of you know almost providing a similar
functionality so that is the kind of
confusion which developers used to
create hence
selenium rc got deprecated and is no
more available in latest selenium
versions it is obsolete now now to
overcome this shortfalls webdriver was
introduced so while rc was introduced in
2004 web driver was introduced by simon
stewart in 2006. it's a cross-platform
testing platform so webdriver can run on
any platform like say linux windows mac
or even if you have a ubuntu machine you
can run your selenium scripts on this
machine it is a programming interface to
run test cases it is not an ide and how
does this work actually so test cases
are created and executed using web
elements or objects using the object
locator and the web driver method so
when i do a demo you will understand
what this web driver methods are and how
do we locate the web elements on the web
page it does not require a core engine
like rc so it is pretty fast why because
webdriver interacts directly with the
browser and it does not have that
intermediate server like the rc hat so
each browser in this case what happens
is each browser has its own driver on
which the application runs
and this driver is responsible to make
the browser understand the commands
which you will be passing from the
script like say for example click of a
button or you want to enter some text so
through your script you tell which
browser you want to work with say chrome
and then the chrome driver is
responsible for interpreting your
instructions and to execute it on the
web application launched on the chrome
browser so like rc webdriver also
supports multiple programming languages
in which you can write your test scripts
so another advantage of web driver is it
supports various frameworks like test ng
junit n unit and report ng
so when we talk about the limitations of
webdriver you will appreciate how this
support for various frameworks and tool
help in making the selenium a complete
automation solution for web application
so let's look at the architecture of
webdriver at a high level what is in web
drivers so webdriver consists of four
major components
the first one is we have got client
libraries
right or what we also call it as
language bindings
so since selenium supports multiple
language and you are free to use any of
the supported languages to create your
automation script these libraries are
made available on your selenium website
which you need to download and then
write your scripts accordingly so let's
go and see from where do we download
this
so if i go to my browser
so
seleniumhq.org right so if you're
working with selenium this website is
your bible so anything and everything
you need to know about selenium right
you need to come here and use all these
tabs here in this website so right now
what we are going to look at is what are
those language binding so for that i'll
have to go to this download tab here
okay and if you scroll down here you
will see something like selenium client
and web driver language bindings
and for each of the supported language
of selenium you have a download link
right so say for example if you are
working with java here what you need to
do is you need to download your java
language binding so let's go back to the
presentation so this is where your
language bindings are available next so
selenium provides lots of aps for us to
interact with the browser
and when we do the demo i'll be showing
you some of this aps right and these are
nothing but the rest apis
and everything whatever we do through
the script happens through the rest
calls then we have a json wire protocol
what is json javascript object notation
it is nothing but a standard for
exchanging data over the web so for
example you want to say launch a web
application through your script
so what selenium does it it creates a
json payload and posts the request to
the browser driver that is here and then
we have this browser drivers themselves
and as i said there is a specific driver
for each browser
as you know every tool has its own
limitation
so does selenium
so let's look at what these limitations
are and if there are any workarounds for
them
cannot test mobile applications requires
framework like apm
selenium is for automating web
application it cannot handle mobile
applications mobile applications are
little different and they need its own
set of automation tool
however what selenium provides is a
support for integrating this apm tool
which is nothing but a mobile
application automation tool
and using apm and selenium you can still
achieve mobile application automation
and when do you usually need this when
your application under test is also
supported on mobile devices you would
want a mechanism to run the same test
cases on web browser as well as your
mobile process right so this is how you
achieve it the next limitation so when
we talked about the components of
selenium i said that with webdriver we
can achieve only sequential execution
however in real time scenario we cannot
just live with this we need to have a
mechanism to run our test cases
parallelly on multiple machines as well
as on multiple browsers so though this
is a limitation of webdriver but what
selenium offers is something called as
grid which helps us achieve this and we
will see in shortly what the selenium
grid is all about
also if you want to know more details as
how do we work with the grid how do you
want to install that grid so do check
out our video
on simply learn website on selenium grid
third limitation so limited reporting
capability so selenium web driver has a
limited reporting capability it can
create basic reports but what we
definitely need is a more
so it does support some tools like say
test ng report ng and even extent
reports which you can integrate with
selenium and generate beautiful reports
powerful isn't it
also there are other challenges
with selenium like selenium is not very
good with image testing
especially for the ones which are
designed for web application automation
but then we have other tools which can
be used along with selenium like auto it
and siculi so if you look at all this
selenium still provides a complete
solution for your automation need and
that's the beauty of selenium and that
is why it makes the most popular tool of
today for automation
okay let's do a quick comparison between
the selenium rc and the web driver
so rc has a very complex architecture
you know why because of the additional
rc server whereas due to direct
interaction with the browser webdriver
architecture is pretty simple
execution speed
it is lower in rc and much faster in web
driver why because in web driver we have
eliminated the complete layer of
selenium server
right that the rc server and we
established a direct communication with
the browser through browser drivers
it requires an rc server to interact
with the browsers we just talked about
it and whereas webdriver can directly
interact with the browser
so rc again we talked about this as one
of the limitations that we have lot of
redundant abs which kept developers
guessing as which api to use for what
functionality
web driver offers pretty clean apis to
work with
rc did not offer any support for
headless browser whereas in web driver
you do have a support for using headless
browsers
let's see the web driver in action now
now for the demo we will use this
particular use case and what this use
case says is navigate to the official
simply learn website
then type the selenium in search bar and
click on it and click on the selenium
3.0 training so we are basically
searching for selenium 3.0 training on
the simply learn website first let's do
the steps manually and then we will go
ahead and write the automation script so
let's go to my browser
on my browser what i'll do is i'll let
me first launch the simply learn website
okay and here what my use case step says
is i need to search for
selenium and click on the search button
so once i do that it is going to give me
a complete list of all kind of selenium
trainings which is available with simple
learn and what i am interested in is the
selenium 3.0 training here once i find
this on the web page i need to go and
click on that all right so this is all
the steps which we are going to perform
in this use case okay now so for writing
the test cases i'll be using an id which
is eclipse i've already installed my
eclipse and also i have installed
selenium in this instance of my eclipse
all right so if you can see the
reference library folder here you will
see all the jars which are required for
the selenium to work next another prereq
which is required for selenium and that
is your driver files now every browser
which you want to work with has its own
driver file to execute your selenium
scripts and since for this demo i'll be
working with the firefox browser i will
need a driver file for firefox now
driver file for firefox is the
geckodriver which i have already
downloaded and placed in my folder
called drivers now where did i download
this from let's go ahead and see that so
if i go back to my browser and if you go
to your selenium hq dot website you have
to go to this download tab here in the
download tab when you scroll down you
will see something like third party
drivers bindings and plugins in this you
will see the list of all the browsers
which is supported by selenium and
against each of this browser you will
find a link which has the driver files
now since we'll be using the gecko
driver
this is the link where you need to go to
and depending on which operating system
which you're working on you need to
download that particular file now since
i'm working on mac this is the file
which i'm using if you're a windows user
you need to download this zip file and
unzip it so once you unzip that you
would
get a file called gecko driver for your
firefox or a chrome driver for your
chrome browser and then what you do is
you just create a directory called
drivers under your project and just
place the driver files here so these are
the two prereqs for your selenium one is
importing your jar files like this and
then having your drivers downloaded and
keep them under a folder where you can
reference to okay so now we'll go ahead
and create a class
i already have a package created in this
project so i'll use this project and
create a new class
so i'll say create new java class and
let's call this as search training i
will be using a public static void main
and i'll click on finish
so let's remove this auto generated
lines as we do not need them all right
now the first statement which you need
to write before when you start writing
the rest of your coders what you need to
do is you need to define or declare your
driver variable using your class web
driver so what i would do is i'll say
web driver
driver
done all right now you'll see that this
id is going to flash some errors for you
that means it is going to ask you to
import certain libraries which is
required by the web driver so simply
just go ahead and say import web driver
from
org.opensq dot selenium this is the
package which we will need all right so
you have a driver created which is of
the class webdriver and now after this
i'm going to create three methods all
right so first method i will have for
launching the firefox browser okay and
then i will write a simple method for
searching
selenium training
and clicking on it
this is the actual use case what we'll
be doing
and then third method i'm going to write
is just to close the browser which i'm
going to be opening right so these are
the different methods which i'll be
creating and from the public static void
main i will just call these methods one
after the other okay so let's go ahead
and write the first method now my first
method is launching the firefox browser
so i'll say public void since my return
type is null or there is no return type
for this let's call it as launch browser
okay all right now in this for launching
any browser i need to mention two steps
now the first step is where i need to do
a system.set property okay let's do that
first and then i'll explain what this
does i'll just say system dot
set property so this accepts a key and a
value pair so what is my key here my key
here is web driver dot
gecko dot driver and i need to provide a
value so value is nothing but the path
to the gecko driver and we know that
this gecko driver which i am going to
use here is right here in the same
project path under the drivers folder
correct and that is what the path which
i am going to provide here so here
simply i need to say
drivers slash
gecko driver
g-e-c-k-o all right done and let me
close this sentence all right now since
i'm a mac user my gecko driver
installable is just the name gecko
driver if you're a windows user and if
you are running your selenium scripts on
the windows machine you need to provide
a complete path to this including dot
exe because driver executable on your
machines is going to be geckodriver.exe
so just make sure that your path which
you mentioned here in the system.set
property is the correct path okay then
the next thing what we need to do is i
need to just say driver is equal to new
firefox driver okay so this command new
firefox driver creates an instance of
the firefox browser now this is also
flagging me error why because again it's
going to ask me to import the packages
where the firefox driver classes present
okay we did that now these two lines are
responsible for launching the firefox
browser form so this is done so what's
my next step in the use case now i need
to launch the website simply learn so
for that we have a command called
driver.get driver.get what it does is
whatever url you're going to give it
here in this double quotes as an
argument it is going to launch that
particular website and for us it's a
simply learn website so what i do as a
best practices instead of typing out the
url i go to my browser
launch that url which i want to test and
i simply copy it come back to your
eclipse and just simply paste it so this
ensures that i do not make any mistakes
in the url okay so done so our first
method is ready where we are launching
the browser which is our firefox browser
and then launching the simply learn
website now the next method what is my
next method in my next method i need to
give the search string to search
selenium training on this particular
website now for that we need to do few
things what are those few things let's
go to the website again all right so let
me relaunch this let's close this okay
let me remove all this and let's go to
the home page first okay this is my home
page so as you saw when i did a manual
testing of this i entered the text here
so now since i have to write a script
for this first i need to identify what
this element is for that what i'm going
to do is i'm just going to say right
click here and i'll say inspect element
all right now this element let's see
what attribute it has which i can use
for finding this element so i i see that
there is an id present so what i'm going
to do is i'm just going to simply use
this id and then i'll just copy this id
from here go back to eclipse let's write
a method first so i'll say public void
and what do we give the method name say
search training
or just search all right now in this i
need to use a command called driver dot
find element
by id is what i'm going to use as a
locating technique and in double quotes
the id which i copied from the website
is what i'm going to paste here okay and
then what am i going to do on this
element is i need to send that text the
text which i'm going to search for which
is selenium so i'll just say send keys
and whatever text i want to send i need
to give it in double quotes so for that
selenium so this is done so now i've
entered the text here and after entering
the text i need to click on this button
so for that i need to first know what
that button is so let's inspect that
search button okay now if you look at
the search button other than the tag
which is span and the class name i do
not have anything here all right so what
i can do is i can either use the class
name or i can write an x path since this
is a demo which we have already used id
locating technique i would go ahead and
use the x path here so for me to
construct an x path uh i will copy this
class first okay
and then i already have a crow path
installed on my firefox so i'll use the
crow path and first test my x bar so
i'll just say double slash let's see
what was that element it has a span tag
okay so i'll have to use span and at
class equal to and i'll just copy the
class name here and let's see if it can
identify that element yeah so it is able
to identify so i'll just use this x path
in my code so i'll go back to eclipse
and i'll say driver dot find element by
dot x path and the x path which i just
copied from crow path is what i'm going
to paste here and what is the action i
need to do here i need to say click done
so i have reached a stage where i have
entered this selenium okay and then i
have clicked on the search button once i
do this i know that expected result is i
should be able to find this particular
link here selenium 3.0 training okay and
i should be able to click on that so for
that again i need to inspect this so
let's inspect this selenium 3.2 all
right so now what are the elements this
has now this particular element has
attributes like it has a tag h2 then it
has got some class name and some other
attributes so i would again would like
to use a x path here now this time while
using the x path i am going to make use
of a text functionality so that i can
search for this particular text so i'll
simply copy this i'll go to my crow path
the tag is h2 so i'll say simply h2
okay and here i'll say text equal to and
this is the text which i copied i missed
out that yes there so i'm just going to
add an s okay so let's first test here
whether it is able to identify that
element yeah so it is able to identify
so can you see a blue dotted line it is
able to show us which element it is
identified so i'll copy this x path now
and let's go to my ide eclipse so now
here what i need to do is i'll have to
again simply say driver dot find element
by dot x path
and paste the x path which we just did
and then again i have to do a click
operation done all right so technically
we have taken all the steps of the use
case and we have written the commands
for that
now let's add an additional thing here
say after coming to this page after
finding this we want to
say print the title of this page now
what is the title of this page if you
just hover your mouse on this it says
online and classroom training for
professional certification courses
simply now so what i will do is after
doing all these operations i will just
print out this page title on our console
so for that i have to just do this
driver dot ah so let's do a sysop so
i'll say sys out system dot out dot
println okay and here i would say
let's add a text here the page title is
and then let's append it with
driver dot
get title so this is the command which
we'll be using to fetch the page title
done now what is the last method i need
to add just to close the browser all
right so let me add a method here i'll
say public void close browser
and this is one single command which i
need to call i'll say driver dot quit
okay and then i need to call all these
methods from my public static void main
so i let me use my class name which is
this so i'm going to create an object
obj is equal to
new class name and then using this
object first is i need to call the
method launch browser and then i'll call
the method search
right and then i'll call the method
close process done so technically our
script is ready with all the
functionality which we wanted to cover
from our use case now there are few
other tweaks which i need to do this and
i'll tell you why i need to do this now
for example after we click here right
after we click on the search if you
observed on your website it took a
little while before it listed out all
the selenium trainings for us and
usually when you're actually doing it
you wait for the selenium 3.0 training
to be available and then you click on
that now same thing you also need to
tell your scripts to do that you need to
tell your scripts to wait for a while
until you start seeing the selenium 3.0
training or it appears on your web page
there are multiple ways to do that in
your script and it is a part of overall
synchronization what we call where we
use kind of implicit and explicit kind
of favorites now since this is a demo
for demo purpose what i'm going to do is
i'm going to use a command called
thread.sleep and i'm just going to give
an explicit weight of say three seconds
so you can use this mainly for the demo
purposes you can use a thread.sleep
command now this thread.sleep command
needs us to handle some exceptions so
i'm just going to click on add throws
declaration and say interrupted
exception now same thing i'll have to do
it in my main function also okay so
let's do that and complete it all right
so this is done so by doing this what am
i doing i'm ensuring that before i click
on the selenium three dot training we
are giving enough time for the script to
wait until the webpage shows this link
to the selenium 3.0 training that's one
thing i'm doing all right and also now
since you're going to be seeing this
demo through the video recording the
script when it starts running it is
going to be very fast so you might just
miss out saying how it does the send
keys and how did it click on the search
button for us to enable us to see it
properly i'll just add some explicit
weights here just for a demo purpose so
after entering the keys right so what
i'll do is i'll just give a simple
thread dot sleep here
okay so probably a three seconds or two
seconds wait should be good enough okay
three seconds wait should be good enough
here so that we should be able to see
how exactly this works on your browser
when we execute this
okay now our complete script is ready so
what i'll do is i'll just save the
script and then we will simply run the
script so to run the script i'll just
say right click run as java application
okay it says ask me to select and save i
have saved the script now so let's
observe how it runs okay the
simplylearn.com the website is launched
so the selenium text has been entered in
the search box it has clicked on the
search okay all right so now it did
everything whatever we wanted it to do
all right so since we are closing the
browser you are unable to see whether
the selenium three dot training was
selected or not however what i have
given here is to fetch the title after
all these operations were complete and
if you see here the complete operations
was done and we were able to see the
page title here okay so now what i will
do since we are unable to see whether it
clicked on the selenium three dot or
training or not i'll just comment our
the close browser the command okay so we
will not call the close browser so that
the browser remains open and we get to
see whether did it really find the
training link or not okay so let me
close this window we don't need this
firefox window close all tabs and then
i'll just exactly execute the script so
i'll say run as java application so save
the file
okay simplylearn.com is launched so
search text is entered now it's going to
click on the search button yes all right
so we've got the search results it
should click on selenium theodore
training and yes it is successfully able
to click on that all right so now it's
not going to close the browser because
we have commented on that line however
it did print us the title here all right
so this is a simple way of using the
selenium scripts
selenium grid so grid is used to run
multiple test scripts on multiple
machines at the same time with webdriver
you can only do sequential execution but
in real time environment you always have
the need to run test cases in
distributed environment and that is
where selenium grid comes into picture
so grid was conceptualized and developed
by patrick the main objective is to
minimize test execution type and how by
running your test parallely so design is
in such a way that commands are
distributed on multiple machines where
you want to run test and all these are
executed simultaneously what do you
achieve by this methodology of course
the parallel execution on different
browsers and operating system grid is
pretty flexible and can integrate with
many tools like say you want a reporting
tool integrated to pull all the reports
from the multiple machines where you're
running your test cases and you want to
present that report in a good looking
format so you have an option to
integrate such report okay so how does
this grid work so grid has a hub and
node concept which helps in achieving
the parallel execution let's take an
example say your application supports
all browsers and most of the operating
system like as in this picture you could
say one of them is a windows machine one
of them is a mac machine and another one
is say a linux machine so your
requirement is to run the test on all
supported browsers and operating system
like the one which is depicted in this
picture so what you have to do is first
thing is you configure a master machine
or what you also call it as a hub by
running something called a selenium
standalone server and this talent
standalone server can be downloaded from
the selenium hq website
using the server you create a hub
configuration that is this node and then
you create nodes specific to your
machine requirement and how are these
nodes created you again use the same
server which is your standalone selenium
server to create the node configuration
so i'll show you where the selenium
server can be downloaded so if we go
back to our
selenium hq website so you can see here
right on the top it says selenium
standalone server and this is the latest
version available so you just need to
download once you download this keep a
version of this one on your master
machine that is your hub and this should
also be present on your node machines
and there is a certain command which you
can use to install the server as a node
and as a master depending on your
configuration so once that is done you
have your master and your master or the
hub and the nodes created your master
can
control on which nodes you want to
execute test now say if this is a mac
machine this is a windows machine
through your master or your hub you
control on which machine you want to
execute what is then also you could have
a multiple combination of tests like say
for example smoke test to be run on all
these nodes that's the kind of
configuration you can create or a
certain component test to be run on say
only windows 10 with an edge browser or
say regression test on mac machine so
any such things whatever configurations
you have for your node what happens is
the hub picks the right node which
confirms to your requirements or the
configurations which are set up and then
sends a command to the node to execute
those test cases on the node everything
is controlled through your master
machine only here what happens on the
node so once the node gets the command
from the master the node actually runs
all the test cases which is it which it
intends to run on the specific browser
which you have mentioned in your
configuration file so this is a very
high level architecture and how a grid
works so if you want to know more
details of how the grid works you can
refer to our video on simply learn all
right again limitations so what
limitation does this grid have now the
first one is it has relatively poor
scalability compared to many modern
applications it is pretty static each
server is configured in advance with a
subset of required browser instances
available so if you want to vary this
you will need to reconfigure so any
configuration tomorrow on any machines
you want to change it cannot be done
automatically you need to completely
reconfigure that node and then add it
back to the grid thirdly although it is
available to run on virtual servers it
is actually not designed as a cloud
native application and because of as a
result of this it isn't optimized to
take advantage of things like say
distributed storage or dynamic scaling
or even automatic failover so these are
some of the limitations of the grid
advantages of selenium speed and
accuracy of course since there is no
manual execution your test can run
faster and with grit it helps in
parallel execution and you can run or
execute large volumes of test within a
very short time frame let's take an
example say before just before the
release of your product say during the
last lap of your testing you find a bug
and of course it has to be fixed so the
developer fixes the bug and you want to
run all the test cases pertaining to
that area now can you imagine that if
you have to do this testing manually how
long it's going to take so by automation
you can achieve this in a very short
duration of time and it will also help
you release your product in time with
very minimal or absolutely no human
errors the second advantage it's an open
source so it's available free of cost so
anyone can download it and start using
it it supports wide spectrum of
programming languages we have been
seeing throughout this presentation it
is not restricted to any particular
programming language so whatever
language you are comfortable with you
have an option to use that and write
your selenium scripts selenium has
support for almost all browsers and
operating system we also talked about
headless browser support so this helps
you create test cases once using any of
the browser and run them across all
browsers and all operating system thus
saving you lot of time from manual
execution and helping in achieving a
very broad test coverage
and we also saw that pretty easy to use
tool right so you can check out all our
videos and you can it's just a matter of
time that you can master the skill of
writing your automation scripts
reusability of course like any
programming language it provides you a
mechanism to reuse your code and avoid
redundancy well again let's see an
overall what are the limitations of
selenium itself now since selenium is
open source that is one of the biggest
advantage now there is a little
disadvantage which comes with that and
what is it you do not have much
technical support because it's an open
source code however there are loads and
loads of documentations and forums
available which you can definitely refer
to and selenium as we said it is only
for automating web applications it
cannot handle the mobile applications or
even the desktop application however it
does provide support for integrating
tools like apm for mobile testing
selenium is not very good with image
testing especially designed for your web
application tools again we have tools
like auto it and securely which can be
integrated with selenium selenium
webdriver has limited limited reporting
capability but again it does provide us
support for integrating tools like test
ng report ng and extent report it does
not have test management capabilities it
need not right not one tool need not
have each and everything what is
required but there is always a way to
integrate it so selenium does provide a
way to integrate any of the test
management tools now since selenium
supports multiple programming language
the developer of test automation will
require to have some basic knowledge of
any of the programming language it
supports to write effective automation
scripts right so this you could look at
it as an advantage or as a disadvantage
so overall if you look at all this right
selenium still provides a complete
solution for our automation need and
that is why we can still say that
selenium is one of the most popular tool
used in the industry today for your web
application automation what docker is
and how you could be using it within
your own dev ops environment so let's
get started so let's first of all
compare docker with a traditional
virtual machine so here we have the
architecture on the left and right of a
traditional virtual machine versus a
darker environment and there are some
things that you'll probably see
immediately that are big differences one
is that the virtual environment has
hypervisor layer where as the docker
environment has a docker engine layer
and then in addition to that there are
additional layers within the virtual
machine each of these really start
compounding and creating very
significant differences between a docker
environment and a virtual machine
environment so with a virtual machine
the actual memory usage is very high
whereas with the docker environment the
memory usage is very low if we look at
performance virtual machines when you
start building out particularly more
than one virtual machine on a server the
performance starts degrading and starts
getting poorer whereas with docker the
performance always stays really good
this is largely due to the lightweight
architecture used to construct the
docker containers themselves if we look
at portability virtual machines just are
terrible for portability they're still
dependent on the host operating system
and there's just a lot of problems that
happen when you are using virtual
machines for portability in contrast
docker was designed for portability so
you can actually build solutions in a
docker container environment and have
the guarantee that the solution will
work as you have built it no matter
where it's hosted finally boot up time
now the bit up time for a virtual
machine is fairly slow in comparison to
the boot up time for a docker
environment which is almost
instantaneous so we look at these in a
little bit more detail one of the other
challenges that you have with a virtual
machine is that if you have unused
memory within the environment you cannot
reallocate that memory so if you set up
an environment that has nine gigs of
memory that's being used we have six
gigs that are free you can't do anything
with it though that whole nine gig has
been allocated to that virtual machine
in contrast with docker if you have nine
gigs and six gigs becomes free that free
memory can then be reallocated and
reused across other containers used
within that docker environment another
challenge is running multiple virtual
machines in a single environment it can
lead to instability and performance
issues whereas docker is designed to run
multiple containers
in the same environment and actually
gets better the more containers you run
in that hosted single docker engine
portability issues with a virtual
machine is the software can work on one
machine but then when you move that vm
to another machine suddenly some of the
software won't work because there are
some dependencies that haven't been
inherited correctly whereas docker
itself is designed specifically to be
able to run across multiple environments
and to be deployed very easily across
the systems and again the actual boot up
time for a vm it just takes a long time
you took about minutes in contrast to
the milliseconds that it takes for a
docker environment to boot up so let's
dig into what docker actually is and
what allows for these great performance
improvements over a traditional vm
environment so docker itself is an os
virtualized software platform and it
allows it organizations to really easily
create deploy and run applications as
what are called docker containers that
have all the dependencies within that
container very easily
and the container itself is really just
a very lightweight package that has all
the instructions and dependencies such
as frameworks libraries bins etc all
within that container and that container
itself can then be moved from
environment to environment very easily
if we to look in our devops life cycle
the place where docker really shines is
in deployment because when you're
actually at the point of deploying your
solution you want to be able to
guarantee that the code that has been
tested will actually work in the
production environment but in addition
to that what we often find is that when
you're actually building the code and
you're actually testing the code having
a container running the solution at
those stages is also a really good plus
because what happens is that the people
building the code and testing the code
are able to validate their work in the
same environment that will be used for
the production environment so really
you can use docker in multiple stages
within your devops cycle but it becomes
really valuable in the deployment stage
so let's look at some of the key
advantages that you have with docker
some things that we've already covered
is that you can do
rapid deployment and you can do it
really fast the environment itself is
highly portable and was designed for
that in mind the efficiencies that
you'll see will allow you to run
multiple docker containers in a single
environment as compared to more
traditional vm environments the
configuration itself can be scripted
through a language called yaml which
allows you to be able to write out and
describe the docker environment that you
want to create this in turn allows you
to be able to scale your environment
very very quickly but with all of these
advantages probably the one that is most
critical to the type of work that we're
doing today is security you have to
ensure that the environment you are
running is a highly secure but highly
scalable environment and i'm very
pleased to say that docker takes
security very seriously so you'll see it
as one of the key talents for the actual
architecture of the system that you're
implementing so let's look at how docker
actually works within your environment
so docker works there is a what's called
a docker engine the docker engine is
really comprised of two key elements so
you have a server and a client and the
communication via the two is via a rest
api the server as you can imagine has
the instructions that are communicated
out to the client and instructs the
client on what to do the connection
between the client and the server the
communication is via a rest api on older
systems you can take advantage of the
docker toolbox which allows you to go
ahead and control the docker engine the
docker machine docker compose and
kitimatic so let's now go into what the
actual root components though of docker
r so let's have a look at those key
components there are four components
that we're going to go through we have
the docker clients and server we have
docker images we have the docker
registry and the docker container we're
going to step through each of these one
by one so let's look at the docker
clients and server first so the docker
client and server is a command line
instructed solution where you would use
terminal on your mac or command line on
your pc or linux system to be able to
issue commands from the docker daemon
the communication between the docker
client and the docker host and is via a
rest api
so you can do sim communication such as
a docker pull command which would send
an instruction to the daemon which would
then form the interaction of pulling in
the correct components
such as an image or container or
registry to the docker client the docker
daemon itself is actually a service
which actually performs all sorts of
operating and performance services and
as you'd imagine the docker daemon is
constantly listing across the rest api
to see if it needs to perform any
specific requests if you want to trigger
and start the whole process you what you
want to do is use the command dockered
within your docker daemon and that will
start all of your performances and then
you have a docker host which actually
runs the docker daemon and registry
itself so now let's look into the actual
structure of a docker image so a docker
image itself is a template which
contains instructions for the docker
container and that template is written
with a language called yaml and yellow
stands for yet another markup language
it's very easy to learn the docker image
itself is built within that yaml file
and then hosted as a file in the docket
registry the image is really comprised
of several key layers and you start with
your base layer which will typically
have your base image and this instance
is your base operating system such as
ubuntu and then you then have layer of
dependencies above that
this would then comprise the
instructions in a read-only file that
would become your docker file so let's
let you go through and look at what one
of those in sets of instructions would
look like so here we have four layers of
instructions we have a from pull run and
then command so what does that actually
look like in our layers so to break this
down the from creates a layer which is
based on ubuntu and then what we're
doing is we're adding in files from the
docker repository onto that base command
that base layer and then what we want to
be able to do is then say okay what are
the wrong commands so we can actually
then build the container within the
environment and then we want to be able
to then have a command line that
actually executes something within that
container and in this instance the
command is to run python so one of the
things that we will see is that as we
set up multiple containers each new
container is a new layer with new images
within the docker environment each
container is completely separate from
the other containers within your docker
environment so you're able to create
your own separate read write
instructions within each layer what's
interesting is that if you delete a
layer then the layer above it will also
get deleted so what happens when you
pull in a layer but something has
changed in the the core image what's
interesting then is that the actual main
image of itself cannot be modified once
you've copied the image you can then
modify it locally but you can never
modify the actual base image itself so
here are some callouts for the
components within a docket image so the
base layer are in read-only format the
layers can be combined in a union file
system to create a single image the
union file system saves memory space by
avoiding duplication of files and this
allows a file system to appear as a
writable but without modifying the file
which is known as a copy on write the
actual base layers themselves are read
only so to be able to get around this
structure within a docker container the
docker's environment itself uses what's
known as a copy and write strategy
within the images and the containers
themselves and so what this allows you
to do is you can actually copy the files
for better efficiency across your entire
container environment the copy and write
strategy does make docker super
efficient and what you're able to do all
the time is keep reducing the amount of
disk space you're using and the amount
of performance that you're taking from
the server and that's really again a key
element for docker is just this constant
ability to be able to keep improving the
efficiency within the actual system
itself all right so let's go on to item
number three which is the docker
registry so the docker registry itself
is the place where you would host and
distribute the different types of images
that you have created or you want to be
used within your environment the actual
repository itself is just a collection
of docker images and those docker images
are built on instructions that you would
write with yaml and are very easily
stored and shared and what you can
actually do is you can actually
associate specific name tags to the
actual docker images themselves so it's
easy for people to be able to find and
share that image within the docker
registry itself one of the things you
actually see as we go through the demos
you actually see us actually using the
the tag name and you'll see how it is an
alphanumeric
and how we actually use it to actually
create the actual container itself one
of the things you can do to as start off
how you would manage a registry is you
can actually use the publicly accessible
docker hub registry which is available
to anybody but you can also create your
own registry for your own use internally
the actual registry that you create
internally can have both public and
private images that you create and this
may be for various reasons of how you
structure your environment the actual
commands you would use to actually
connect to the registry are both push
and pull push is to actually push a new
container environment that you've
created from your local manager node to
the remote registry and a pool allows
you to pull a new client that has been
created and is being shared so again
full command and it pulls and retrieves
a docket image from the docker registry
and makes it very easy for people to
share different images consistently
across teams and a push command allows
you to take a new command that you've
created a new container that you've
created and push it to the registry
whether it's docker hub or whether it's
your own private registry and allow it
to be shared across your teams some key
did you know in docker registry deleting
a repository is not a reversible action
so if you delete a repository it's gone
so let's go into the final stage here
which is the actual docker container
itself so the docker container itself um
is an executable package of applications
and its dependencies bundled together so
it gives all the instructions that you
would have for the solution that you're
looking to run it's actually really
lightweight and again this is because of
the redundancy that's built into how you
structure the container and the
container itself is then inherently also
extremely portable what's really good
about running a container though is that
it does run completely in isolation so
you're able to share it very easily from
grouped group and you are guaranteed
that even if you are running a container
it's not going to be impacted by any
host os peculiarities or unique setups
as you would have in a vm or a
non-containerized environment the actual
memory that you have on a docker
environment that can be shared across
multiple containers which is really
useful typically when you have a vm you
would have a defined amount of memory
for each vm environment the challenge
you start running into though is that
you can't share that memory whereas with
docker you can easily share the memory
for a single environment across multiple
containers
the actual container is built using
docket images and the command to
actually run those images is a run
command and so this guy should go
through a basic structure of how you
would run a docket image so you go into
terminal window and you would write a
docker run redis and then it would run a
container called redis so we're going to
go in and
if you don't have the redis image
locally installed it will then pull it
from the registry then the new docker
container redis will be then available
within your environment so you can
actually start using it so let's look at
why containers are so
lightweight they're so lightweight
because they really have been able to
get away from some of the additional
layers that you have in virtualization
within vms and the biggest one is the
hypervisor and the need to run on a host
operating system those are two big big
elements so if you can get rid of those
then you're doing great so let's look at
some of the more advanced concepts
within the docker environment and we're
going to look at two advanced components
one is docker compose and the second is
docker swamp so let's look at docker
compose docker compose is really
designed for
running multiple containers as a single
service and it does this by running each
container in isolation but allowing the
containers to interact with each other
as was stated earlier on you would
actually write the compose environment
using yaml as the language in the files
that you would create so where would you
use something like docker compose so an
example would be if you are running an
apache server with my sql database and
you need to create additional containers
to run additional services without the
need to start each one separately and
this is where you would write a set of
files using docker compose to be able to
help balance out that demand
so let's now look at docker swarm so
docker swarm is a service that allows
you to be able to control multiple
docker environments within a single
platform
so what you actually are looking at
doing is within your docker swamp is
we're treating each node as a docker
demon and we're actually having an api
that's interacting with each of those
nodes there are two types of node that
you're going to be getting comfortable
working with one is the manager node and
the second is the worker node and as
you'd expect the manager node is the one
sending out the instructions to all of
the worker nodes but there is a two-way
communication that is happening the
communication allows for the imagine
node to be able to manage the
instructions and then listen to receive
updates from the working node so if
anything happens within this environment
the imagine node can react and adjust
the architecture of the worker node so
it's always in sync it was really great
for
large scaled environments so finally
let's go through what are some of the
basic commands you would use within
docker and once we've gone through all
these basic commands we'll actually show
you a demo of how you'd actually use
them as well so if we're going to go in
probably the first command is to install
docker and so if you have yam installed
you just do yum install docker and
you'll install docker onto your computer
to start the docker daemon as you want
to do system ctl start docker the
command to remove a docker image is
docker rmi and then the image id itself
and that's not the image name that's the
actual alphanumeric id number that you
want to grab the command line to
download a new image is docker pull and
then the name of the image you'd want to
pull and by default you're going to be
pulling from the docker default registry
that will then connect to your docker
daemon and download the images from that
registry
the command line to run an image is
docker run and then the image id
and then we have the if we wanted to
pull specifically from docker hub then
we would have a docker pull and then the
image name and colon its tag
to pull build an image from a docker
file you would do docker build
t and then the image name and colon tag
to shut down the container you do docker
stop container id the access for running
a container is docker exec it container
id bash
so we've gone through all the different
commands but let's actually see how they
would actually look and we're going to
go ahead and do a demo
so welcome to this demo where we're
going to go ahead and put together all
of the different commands that we have
outlined in the presentation for docker
first is just to list all of the docket
images that we have so we do
sudo docker images and we enter in our
password
and this will now list out the images
that we've created already and we have
three images there
so let's go ahead and pull a docker
image so to do that we'll we'll go ahead
and type sudo
docker
and actually we don't want to do image
we want to select pull
and then the name of the image that we
want to pull which is going to be my
sequel
and by default this is actually going to
go ahead and use the latest my sequel
command mysql image that we have so it's
now go ahead and pull this image it's
going to take a few minutes depending on
your internet connection speed it's kind
of a large file that has to be
downloaded so we'll just wait for that
to download
you can see the others have completed
just waiting for this last file to
download almost there
once that's done what we're going to go
ahead and do is we'll actually uh run
the docking container and create a new
container using the image that we just
downloaded but we have to wait for this
to download first
all right so the image has been pulled
from docker hub
and let's go ahead and create the new
docker container so we're going to do
sudo docker
run
dash d
dash
p
0.0.0.0
[Music]
colon 80
and then we'll put in my sql
colon
later so we have the latest version
and we have our new toku
and that shows our new docker container
has been created
now let's go ahead and see if the
container is running
and we'll do
sudo docker
ps
to list all the running containers and
what we see is that the container is not
listed there which means it's probably
not running so let's go ahead and list
out all of the images that we have
within docker so we can see whether it's
actually listed there so we'll do ps
dash a
and yes there we are we can see that we
do have our new container my sql latest
and it was created 36 seconds ago but
it's in the exit mode so what we have to
do is we have to change that status so
it's actually running
so let's change that to running state
we'll do sudo
docker
run
dash
i t
dash dash
name
and we can name it
sl
sql
uh mysql
slash spin slash
flash
and that's now going to be in the root
and we'll exit out of that and now if we
list out the document containers we
should see it is now
an active container
sure docker
start
and then we'll start the
scene
and then
and we should now see it
there we are it's now in the running
state excellent
and we can see that it was updated six
seconds ago
we're going to go ahead and we're going
to clear the screen
okay now what we want to do is remove
the docker container
so we're going to do is check list of
images that we have
and to sudo docker images
here are the images that we have and we
have my sql is listed and what we want
to do is delete my sql
and to do that we're going to type in
sudo docker rm dash f
image
mysql
run that command and what we'll find is
the image uh there's no such image oh
okay so what we actually have to do is
we have to go and see that the image is
now gone it's been removed excellent
it's exactly what we wanted to see
and we can also delete an image by its
image id as well
however if an image is running
and active we have to kill that image
first so we'll go ahead and we're going
to select the image id we'll copy that
and it's going to
replace that it won't be able to
actually run correctly because the image
is active so what we have to do now is
stop the image and then we can kill it
so it's in the running state
so we have to do
so we do sudo darker kill
and kill sl and then we'll kill the
container
and now
we'll see that the container has gone
and now we can delete the image
and that's going to be the image going
with image id boom
easy peasy
okay let's go ahead on to the next
exercise which is to
so here we are we've listed all of the
uh
containers and they're all gone so let's
go into the next exercise final exercise
which is to actually create a batch
image
and we do a batch http image so let's go
ahead and write that out so it's gonna
be docker
run
dash
did
dash dash
name
white is that's going to be the name of
this http service dash p
8080 colon 80
v
open quotes
dollar sign pwd
close quotes
colon
slash usr
slash local
slash
apache 2
slash htdocs
slash
httpd
semicolon 2.4
run that
put in our password again
uh so what we see is the port is already
being used so let's go ahead and see
which ports let's go see if we can
change the port or see what ports are
running so let's do
sudo images and see which ports are
being used because it's either the the
port or the name um hasn't been put in
correctly so sudo docker images
ps
sudo docker
ps-a
and
yep
let's port 80 there
so we'll clear the screen
so we're going to change the container
name because i think we actually have
the wrong container name here so let's
go and change that and we'll paste that
in and voila there we go
now working and we'll just double check
and make sure everything's working
correctly so to do that we'll go into
our web browser
and we'll type in
as soon as firefox opens up
type in localhost
colon8080
which was the the port that we created
and there we are it's a list of all the
files which shows that the server is up
and running
this is anjali from simply learn and
today we will dive into a tutorial on
the configuration management tool chef
so if you look at the devops approach or
the devops life cycle you will see that
chef falls under operations and
deployment why should we use chef well
consider a large company now this
company caters to a large number of
client and provides a number of services
or solutions of course to get all of
this done they need a huge number of
servers and a huge number of systems
basically they will have a huge
infrastructure now this infrastructure
needs to be continuously configured and
maintained in fact when you're dealing
with an infrastructure that size there's
a good chance systems may be failing and
in the long run as your company expands
new systems may even get added so what
do you do well you could say the company
has the best system administrator out
there but all by himself could he
possibly take care of an infrastructure
that size no he can't and that's where
chef comes in because chef automates
this entire process so what does chef
provide chef provides continuous
deployment so when you look at the
market space today you see how products
and their updates are coming out in a
matter of days so it's very important
that a company is able to deploy the
product the minute it's ready so that
once it's out it's not already obsolete
chef also provides increased system
robustness as we saw chef can automate
the infrastructure but in spite of this
automation there's a good possibility
that errors do creep in chef can detect
all these bugs and remove them before
deploying them into the real environment
not only this chef also adapts to the
cloud we all know how today the services
tools solutions everything is revolving
around the cloud so chef does really
play along by making itself easily
integratable with the cloud platform so
now that you know why to use chef let's
look at what exactly is chef chef is an
open source tool developed by ops code
of course there are paid versions of
chef such as chef enterprise but other
than that most of it is freely
accessible chef is written in ruby and
airline if you would have gone through
any previous material on chef i'm sure
you would have come across ruby being
related to chef but not erlang so this
is why because ruby and erlang are both
used to build chef but when it comes to
actually writing the codes in chef it's
just ruby and these are the codes that's
deployed onto your multiple servers and
does the automatic configuration and
maintenance and this is why chef is a
configuration management tool so i've
used this term configuration management
a couple of times what exactly does this
mean let's start with the definition of
configuration management configuration
management is a collection of
engineering practices that provides a
systematic way to manage entities for
efficient deployment so let's break this
down configuration management basically
is a collection of practices and what
are these practices for these practices
are for managing your entities the
entities which are required for
efficient deployment so what are these
entities that you need for efficient
deployment they are code infrastructure
and people code is basically the code
the system administrators right for
configuring your various systems
infrastructure is the collection of your
systems and your servers and then
finally you have the teams that take
care of this infrastructure so codes
need to be updated whenever your
infrastructure needs a new configuration
or some sort of updation in the
operating system or the software
versions your code needs to be updated
at first and as the requirements of the
company change the infrastructure's
configuration needs to change and
finally of course the people need
coordination so if you have a team of
system administrators and say person a
makes some change to the code person b c
d and so on need to be well aware when
the change is made as to why it was made
what was the change made and where
exactly this change was made so there
are two types of configuration
management on our left we have the push
configuration here the server that holds
the files with instructions to configure
your notes pushes these files onto the
node so the complete control lies with
the server on your right side we have
the pull configuration in case of pull
configuration the nodes pole against the
server to first check if there's any
change in the configurations required if
there is the nodes themselves pull these
configuration files shelf follows pull
configuration and how it does this we'll
see further in our video another
important term often used with chef
infrastructure as code so let's
understand what this term infrastructure
as code means through this small story
so here's tim tim's a system
administrator at a large company now he
receives a task he has to set up a
server and he has to install 20 software
applications over it so he begins he
sets up the server but then it hits him
it would take him the entire night to
install 20 software applications
wouldn't things have been much simpler
if he just had a code to do so well of
course codes do make things much simpler
codes have a number of advantages
they're easily modifiable so if today
tim is told we need mysql installed on
20 systems tim simply writes a code to
do so and the very next day tim is told
we changed our mind we don't need maya
skill i think we'll just use oracle this
does not bother him because now he just
opens the file he makes a few
corrections in his code and that should
work just fine code is also testable so
if tim had to write ten commands to do
something and at his tenth command he
realized the very first command he wrote
there was something not right there well
that would be quite tiresome wouldn't it
with codes however you can test it even
before running it and all the bugs can
be caught and corrected codes are also
deployable so they're easily deployable
and they're deployable multiple times
so now that we saw the various
advantages of having codes let's say
what infrastructure as code exactly is
here's the definition infrastructure as
code is a type of id infrastructure
where the operation team manages the
code rather than a manual procedure so
infrastructure as a code allows the
operations team to take care of a code
which automatically performs various
procedures rather than having to
manually do those procedures so with
this feature all your policies and your
configurations are written as code let's
now look at the various components of
chef so our first component is the
workstation the workstation is the
system where the system administrator
sits he or she creates the codes for
configuring your nodes now these codes
which in case of chef are written in
ruby are called the recipes and you'll
have multiple number of recipes so a
collection of recipes is called a
cookbook now these cookbooks are only
created at the workstation but they need
to be stored at the server so the knife
is a command line tool so it's basically
a command that you will see us executing
in one of our demos that shifts these
cookbooks from the workstation over to
the server a second component is the
server so servers like the middleman it
lies between your workstation and your
nodes and this is where all your
cookbooks are stored because as you saw
previously the knife sends these
cookbooks over from the workstation to
the server the server can be hosted
locally that's on your workstation
itself or it can be remote so you can
have your server at a different location
you can even have it on the cloud
platform and a final confidence the node
so nodes are the systems that require
the configuration in a chef architecture
you can have a number of nodes oh hi is
a service which is installed on your
node and it is responsible for
collecting all the information regarding
your current state of the node this
information is then sent over to the
server to be compared against the
configuration files and check if any new
configuration is required chef client is
another such service on your node which
is responsible for all the
communications with the server so
whenever the node has a demand for a
recipe the shift client is responsible
for communicating this demand to the
server since you have a number of nodes
in a chef architecture it's not
necessary that each node is identical so
of course every node can have a
different configuration let's now have a
look at the chef architecture so here we
have a workstation one server machine
and two nodes you can have any number of
nodes first things first the system
administrator must create a recipe so
the recipes that are mentioned in our
chef architecture are just dummy recipes
we look into actual functioning recipes
later in our demo so you have one recipe
two recipes three recipes and a
collection of recipes forms a cookbook
so guys if you look at the recipe in
source you have simply learn 3.erb erb
is the extension for your ruby files so
the cookbooks are only created at the
workstation they now need to be sent
over to the server where they are stored
and this is the task of the knife knife
is a command line tool which is
responsible for transferring all your
cookbooks onto the server from the
workstation here's the command for
running your knife knife upload simply
db where simply db is the name of the
cookbook we then move on to our node
machines at a node we run the ohi
service the ohi service will collect all
information regarding the current state
of your nodes and send it over to the
chef client when you run the chef client
these informations are sent over to the
server and they are tested against the
cookbooks so if there is any discrepancy
between the current state of your notes
and the cookbook that is if one of the
notes does not match the configurations
required the cookbook is then fetched
from the server and executed at the node
this sets the note to the right state
there are various flavors of chef we'll
quickly go through these first we have
chef solo with chef solo there's no
separate server so your cookbooks are
located on the node itself now this kind
of configuration is used only when you
have just a single node to take care of
the next flavor is the hosted chef with
hosted chef you still have your
workstation and your note but your
server is now used as a service on the
cloud this really makes things simple
because you don't have to set up a
server yourself and it still performs
all the functioning of a typical chef
this is the configuration you will
notice that we'll be using in our demo
chef line server with chef client server
you have a workstation you have server
and you have n number of nodes now this
is the traditional chef architecture
this is the one we have used for all the
explanations previously and finally we
have private chef private chef is also
known as enterprise chef in this case
your workstation server and node all are
located within the enterprise
infrastructure this is the main
difference between chef client server
and private chef in case of shep client
server all these three machines could be
dispersed the enterprise version of chef
also provides the liberty to add extra
layers of security and other features
and we reach the final part of our video
where we'll have the hands-on so before
we dive into our demo let me just
quickly give you an introduction to it
we'll be using two virtual boxes both
sent to s7 one will be used as
workstation while the other will be a
node so we are just using one node to
make things simple the server will be
used as a service on the cloud now these
are the steps we'll be performing during
our demo we'll first download and
install the chef dk on our workstation
we then make an empty cookbook file and
we'll write a recipe into it we need to
then set up the server so as i mentioned
earlier server will be a service on the
cloud so you'll have to create a profile
but this will be completely free we then
link the workstation to the server and
will upload the recipe to the server the
notes will now download the cookbooks
from the server and configure themselves
so now that you have some idea about
what we'll be doing let's move on to the
actual demo we begin our demo
here's my oracle vm virtualbox manager i
have two machines here i've already
created my workstation and node both of
these are sent to s7 machines
just for you to differentiate this is my
terminal
and for my workstation it's a black
background with white text and as of my
note it's a black background with green
text
the first thing you do is you go to your
workstation box and open a web browser
search for chef dk installation
go to the first link which is your
chef's official page and under red hat
enterprise because our system's a red
hat system
select the link of the version that
you're using so i'm using centos 7 so my
operating system version is 7 so i'll
take this link now this is the link for
downloading your chef dk you copy this
link and go to your terminal guys notice
i'm in the home directory of my root
user so let's install our chef dk
and it's getting installed now this will
take some time because it's quite a
large file
and chef dk is downloaded next step we
need to install it
and this is the version of the chef dk
that we have downloaded
so type the same
okay so that's done so now we need to
make our recipes and the recipes will
exist within cookbooks so first let's
make a chef repository so within that
we'll have a folder for holding all our
cookbooks and within our cookbook we'll
write our recipe so we start with the
directory for chef repository
[Music]
move into it
create a folder called
cookbooks within which we'll store each
of our cookbooks
move into this
folder
[Music]
okay so we'll just check the contents
here right now so we have our chef dk we
have a chef repo folder here and let's
check the content of the chef repo
and this has cookbooks okay so our first
cookbook that we'll be making will be
under this folder cookbooks so let's
move into cookbooks
we are in
now we need to create our first cookbook
so the instruction for creating your
first cookbook is chef
generate
cookbook
and the name of your cookbook so i'm
just giving the name a sample
yeah so our cookbook sample is created
now when you create your cookbook you'll
notice that a hierarchy is also
automatically created so let's just
check the hierarchy of our cookbook
let's move into sample
and three is the command for checking
the hierarchy so here as you can see we
have recipes and under recipes we have
default.rb
so we'll be editing this default.rb to
create our recipe okay so let's begin
with that let's move into our recipes
folder
and open your default.rb
and here we are so now we'll type in our
code
so what's our recipe for our recipe is
for installing the httpd package on our
note and then we'll also create a small
index file where we'll just have a
simple content such as welcome or
something like that just to check if our
http is working fine so let's begin
typing the code here package httpd
service
httpd
do and what must be done with this
package is that once it's installed it
needs to be enabled
and it needs to be started
and so that's our first task our next
task
is creating our html file
so as you know all your html files
will follow this path name
and this is the content of your file
you have successfully
configured
your node
and that's it that's our simple code
so our recipe is now ready save it and
exit back to your terminal now what we
need to do is that we need to configure
our server so go to your browser
on the search engine type manage dot
chef dot io
so as i mentioned earlier we'll be using
a server as a service on the cloud
so you'll enter your
login page for the chef server most of
you may not have a profile already so
you go to click here to get started and
fill in the details
it's just like creating an account on
facebook so i already have my account
i've put in the credentials here i'll
just sign in now the first thing once
you sign in is you'll get an option to
create an organization so all you have
to do there is you gotta enter the name
of your organization and just below that
there's another box for entering a short
form of your organization now my
organization name was simply learn and
the short form was slp123 so when you
come to the administration tab under
organization you can see this
organization name next step click on
this arrow and you gotta download your
starter kit okay so once you click on
down starter kit you'll come to this
page where there's a button for download
starter kit
so do download it
save the file
so now come back to your terminal
so you come back to your terminal and
next what you need to do is you need to
unzip your shift starter.zip so for that
first we'll move our chef's starter to
the root so it's currently present under
the downloads folder let's move it
so we have moved our chefstarter.zip now
let's unzip it
first let's just check
the contents of our root directory right
now
so we have a chef repository
chef repo
folder that we created the chef starter
zip
that we just moved and of course the
chef dk so now we can unzip our
chef starter kit
and that's done so our next step we
gotta move the chef starters.zip file
into our cookbooks which lies inside the
chef repository this is done because
we'll be executing our further commands
to connect our workstation with the
server from the cookbooks because that
is where our sample cookbook is
and that's moved
so now we'll run a knife command so what
knife does is that it uploads your
recipes or your cookbooks onto the
server so here's the command for running
your knife
samples the name of the cookbook that
you're uploading and uploading sample
0.1.0
and uploading sample yeah so our
cookbook is uploaded now let's just
check this at our server how we do that
is
go back to your browser where you have
opened your server
so there's no node here yet
because we have not configured our node
with the server but we have configured
our workstation with the server
and you see here our cookbooks
uploaded sample so our workstation and
our server are connected so now we need
to connect our node with the server so
first we move on to our node machine
we need to take the ip address of our
node machine
so for the ip address we'll just type
ifconfig
[Music]
right so this is your ip address
192.168.2.190
[Music]
note this down somewhere guys
now that's done
go back to your workstation
i'll just keep it this way so i can see
both okay go back to your workstations
terminal
but this time to connect our server with
the node so we have taken the ip of our
node and this is where we'll be using it
192.168.2 point the username which is
root in our case
and then enter the password
and then finally you enter your node
name
so this is the name that will appear for
this particular node on our server i'm
just giving it chef node you can give it
whatever you like we'll just check the
command knife bootstrap the ip address
ssh user our user which is root
ssh password the password for the root
and finally the node name
and the nodes getting created
so once the node is connected to your
server we'll go back to our browser open
our server service on the cloud and
we'll check the note tab so ideally your
node name should appear there
great so our node is added also if you
notice here our chef client service on
the node has started running so let's
just check this with the server
go to your notes
and here we go so chef node a centos 7
platform
this is our ip so it's all done so now
we need to add a cookbook to the run
list of this node so come here click on
this arrow
edit run list
here sample this is the cookbook that we
want to run on our node put on the
current run list and here we have the
run button just click on that so this
should have transferred our cookbook
onto the node let's check that go to
your node machine
clear this
we need to be the root
let's run the chef client service
so we are running it once again because
after it was started we did add
something to our run list the changes in
the run list is updated
so in 1 minute 56 seconds
our cookbook has
run
on our note so the configuration changes
should have been made
let's check that it's pretty simple just
go to your browser
on the search engine just type localhost
and here's our html page that we created
on our workstation congrats you
configured your first note and i really
hope you did so that is the end of our
demo we have successfully installed the
httpd package on our node and we have
also executed a html file we look into
the tutorial on the configuration
management tool puppet so let's begin
why puppet so consider the scenario of
an mnc the mnc puts together the small
team of system administrators they are
responsible for taking care of the
infrastructure of this organization now
this infrastructure could consist of
data centers service centers and many
such components fortunately for the mnc
they were doing extremely well so the
number of clients kept growing
consistently and with this came a boom
in the infrastructure size now here is
where the problem came in with such a
large infrastructure the small team that
they put together in no way could manage
this so what do we do the solution seems
pretty simple right just increase the
size of the team sure we'll increase the
size of team but when do you think we
can put an upper limit on the size when
do we get to stabilize the steam so here
is where puppet comes in with puppet a
small team is enough to take care of
this large infrastructure this is
because the data center server centers
all of them can be updated in a matter
of seconds with puppet entire load of
doing so has now shifted from the team
onto the tool not only this with puppet
if servers do fail and there's a very
high chance of servers failing when
you're considering an organization the
scale of an mnc puppet can instantly
roll them back to their previous working
states and if that wasn't enough puppet
also provides the capability to deploy
servers on demand and enforce security
on them now all of this is done through
simple coding which is written in ruby
we look at how puppet works more so now
that we know why we should use puppet
let's have a look at what exactly is
puppet so first and foremost puppet is a
configuration management tool as i
already mentioned in the beginning of
this video so this simply means that
puppet ensures that all your systems are
maintained at a consistent state so
consider that you want to deploy a
number of servers now you require these
servers to be identical if this task is
given to a human there's a very good
chance that those systems will not be
identical or some of them may even fail
humans are prone to errors you cannot
blame them so puppet ensures that all
these servers are deployed on time and
they are identical secondly puppet is
also a deployment tool this simply means
that puppet has the capability to deploy
your applications your services
softwares all of this on your notes
automatically and finally puppet
implements infrastructure as code now
this term infrastructure as code is a
very important one when it comes to the
devops approach you would have noticed
this term being used in our previous
video on chef2 if not you can always
click the top right corner to know more
so what does this term infrastructure as
code mean infrastructures code simply
means that all your policies your tasks
your instructions everything is written
in coded format so in case of puppet
specifically all of this is written in
the ruby language so now that we know
what puppet is let's look into the
puppet architecture so puppet has a
master slave architecture as you can see
here on the top we have the puppet
master and below we have the puppet
clients so the puppet master is the
system where your system administrator
sits the clients are those systems which
require configuration you can have n
number of clients connected to the
puppet master so don't worry we look
into each of these components in detail
firstly we have the puppet master so the
puppet mask is where the system
administrator sits and he or she types
in the codes here so the codes are not
only written in the system but they are
also stored here and whenever the client
requires these codes for their
configuration they simply request it so
manifest is the first subcomponent of
the puppet master these are the actual
files where the codes are written so in
case of puppet these are ruby files
modules tie manifests templates and
files into a single unit
now these codes dictate the instructions
for performing various tasks on your
client the next component is templates
so if manifests are your code templates
are the data so let me explain this to
you with an example consider you want to
create a file called index.html on one
of your client machines so what you do
is you write the code for creating this
file in your manifest and the content of
this file is written in your templates
then you simply link them but here's the
thing when you divide your code and data
in this way it's a very clean structure
so it's preferred to do it in this
manner files are your static contents so
the files are basically sent to your
client and they are simply downloaded at
the client there is no execution or
compilation involved with your files now
this is where files and templates are
extremely different because with
templates they are never sent over to
your client the templates are simply
read by the parser at the master itself
modules ties the manifest templates and
files into a single unit so modules is
not a separate competent as such it just
provides a very clean hierarchy this is
the most important component of the
puppet master ca which stands for
certificate authority
now as we will see later in this video
the puppet master and the puppet client
communicate through an exchange of ssl
certificates so when the client sends
over the certificate to the master ca
provides the master the authority to
sign these certificates the minute the
master signs a certificate the master is
basically saying that yes this client is
registered with me and i agree to
exchange data with this client our next
component puppet client of course these
are the systems that require to be
configured agent is a service installed
on the client the agent is solely
responsible for all the communication
between the master and the client and
finally we have factor so factor is
responsible for collecting all the data
about the present state of our clients
and sending this data over to the puppet
master at the master this data is
compared against the manifest which are
your code files and then these manifests
are sent over to the client depending
upon the results of this comparison so
now that we had a look at the various
components of puppet let's see how these
work together
so we have a master and we have three
clients now before any information can
be transferred between the master and
the client it's important that these
components recognize each other also
there needs to be an encrypted channel
of communication between each pair of
master and client now all the data which
is transferred between the master and
the client it flows through this channel
so let's see how this entire procedure
of recognizing each other works the core
of this procedure are the ssl
certificates ssl stands for secure
socket layer secure socket layer is a
security protocol and it forms an
encrypted channel between two components
what this encrypted channel ensures is
that all the data that is passed through
this channel is not accessible by any
other system outside so it provides
complete security
okay so we will consider a very general
scenario we have a master and a client
here this is not the puppet master or
the puppet client they're just two
systems and we're just going forward
with master slave architecture so the
client so far is not a client it is just
a system and we will refer to the system
as system a so system a sends over a
client certificate to the master
associated with this client certificate
is the host name of system a now master
goes through the certificate it sees the
host name and then it decides whether it
wants to form a communication link with
the system a if it does it signs the
certificate and the signed certificate
is sent back to system a now the system
a is officially a client the minute the
master signed the client certificate it
said that yes i am willing to exchange
information with this system and i do
take the system as one of my clients so
now that the system is officially a
client it can request for data from the
master and the master will simply send
over the data now we are here to talk
about puppet so if this was a puppet
master and this was a puppet client then
the first three stages will be the same
so the puppet client sends over the
certificate to the master the master
signs the certificate sends it back and
the client requests for data now by data
here of course we mean the configuration
data those are the manifest or even
could be your files
so what happens after this request after
this request the factor service which is
present on your clients collects all the
information regarding the present state
of your client so this information could
include the operating system that's
installed on them the various number of
software present on them the versions of
these software now all this information
is collected it's called the fact and
it's sent over to the master at the
master this information that is the
facts is compared against the manifest
so why does the master do this the
master basically compares the facts
against manifest to know if what the
manifest is about to perform is already
performed on these systems so if the
manifest has some additional
functionality they are compiled into
catalogs and then these catalogs are
sent over to the client now remember
those agent services which existed in
your clients here's where they come in
the agents take the catalog and execute
them on the client once executed these
catalogs make the required changes on
the client and a report is generated
this report is then sent back to the
master so the master keeps record of all
the changes that's made in the system
and this comes very handy when one of
the systems fail and it's required to be
rolled back to its previous working
state so this entire procedure can be
repeated n number of times and can be
repeated at regular intervals so if you
have a scenario where a system needs to
be configured every 30 minutes what you
can do is you can set your interval and
automatically every 30 minutes your
systems will be configured and we reach
the final and the most exciting part of
our video which is the hands-on so today
i'll be showing you how you can use
puppet to install apache on one of your
client machines so we'll be using two
machines here we'll have a server and
we'll have a node machine the server is
essentially your master the node is your
client i'm just using the term server
and node instead because i want to keep
it very close to as they are used in the
commands now both these machines are
going to be sent to seven machines and i
have oracle vm virtualbox installed on
my machine so on that i've simply
created two virtual boxes both centos 7
of course so before we move on to the
actual demo i'll just take you through
the various steps so first we'll install
the puppet server on our server or
master machine we'll then start the
server service we then shift over to our
node or the client machine and we'll
install the puppet agent service we will
then start the service too and the
minute you start the puppet agent
service an ssl certificate is created so
this certificate will have the host name
of your node attached to it and this is
how the master or the server will
recognize the certificate and then it
will sign the certificate so once your
master or the server signs the
certificate you can write your manifests
so the manifesto is just the codes for
configuration and once that tool is done
you shift back to your client or the
node system and you run the asian
service so once you run the agent
service your manifest or your cat logs
because as you know the manifests are
compiled into catalogs these are
executed on your node and this will make
the required changes so that's how this
entire process is going to work now
let's move on to the actual
demo this is my oracle vm virtualbox
manager the last two machines you see
here are the ones we'll be using for
this demo the puppet server is your
puppet master puppet client of course is
the client so let's just have a look at
these two machines
this is my puppet server so just so you
can differentiate guys the terminals
have been set accordingly puppet server
has a black background with white text
and puppet client here has a black
background with green text
so we'll move on to server machine or
the master machine because that's the
one we'll be working on first so before
we begin we need to set the hostname of
a master to puppet so this is a very
essential step in the configuration of
puppet if you miss this out there are
quite a lot of other changes you'll have
to make in certain files so let's do
this first
so that's the command to set the host
name the last word you see there that's
the new hostname you want
okay so now we'll just check if our
hostname is set so just type hostname
and yeah it's puppet so next we will
check the ip of this machine
so for that you just type if config
enter
so this is your ip guys
under enp0s3
in its value
that is
192.168.2.183 of course the ip will
differ for you guys
needless to say
so note that down somewhere because
we'll require it when we are configuring
our client
okay so now you want your puppet server
and your client
to communicate so for this we need to
remove certain firewalls so the command
for this is
sudo because we want the root permission
system
ctl
stop
firewall
d
and put in the password
okay so all your firewalls are removed
so the next step now we start on with a
puppet process so we download the puppet
labs at first now guys ensure that your
systems your virtual boxes in this case
are connected to the net
also you won't be getting an ip if it's
not for the first time
so here's the command to download the
puppet lag
foreign
enter the password again
okay so the puppet labs is downloaded
now you need to install this
so installation guys we will be
installing the puppet server on the
master machine or the puppet server
machine
so this may take a while
so that took a while so i just skipped
to the last part where it's completed
the installation process is over
now we need to make a small change
in our system config puppet server file
so let's just move to the file first
this file will open in vi editor
so this line here it basically allocates
memory for your puppet server now you do
not need 2gb
so we are going to reduce the size
512 mb should be enough
so guys notice here i did not type the b
okay so i just changed this to xms
m
let's save that
always remember to open this file using
sudo otherwise saving the changes you
made could be quite troublesome
okay so now we can start a puppet server
service
we enable the service
okay so that's done so basically our
puppet server service
has started it's running presently
so for a while we are done with the
server machine
let's move on to our client machine
okay first things first we open our edc
host file
with sudo because you need to make a few
changes and save it
open this in the vi terminal
okay guys so here
you have to add this one line at the end
type in the ip
for your puppet server machine
puppet
dash
master
so let's save this file
now we'll move on to downloading puppet
labs on our puppet client so the command
is the same that we use for puppet
server
so puppet labs is downloaded now we need
to install the puppet agent service here
again this will also take some time
puppet servers installed
let me just clear this window
now that our puppet agent service is
installed we'll start this service so
i'll just type in the command for
starting the puppet agent service
as you can see here ensure changed
stopped to running
so basically the service was not running
before and now it's changed to the
running state
and while we executed this command not
only did the service start running but
an ssl certificate was also created
so this certificate should have the host
name of this machine that's a puppet
client machine attached to it so let's
just check what the host name of our
machine is
that's
localhost.localdomain so a certificate
should have this attached to it so guys
the first time your client sends a
certificate
the name of the certificate itself is
usually the host name of the machine so
our certificate's name should be
localhost.localdomain
we'll check this on our master system
and that's where we'll sign the
certificate to
so first we list out all the
certificates in our case since we have
just one client
and we just started the client we should
have technically just one certificate
and it will be so
yeah so this is a certificate localhost
dot local domain
we'll now sign the certificate
okay sorry about that just
need to remove these
brackets
here as you can see here the certificate
is signed
sign certificate request
here
so once the certificate is signed the
request for signing the certificate is
removed that's this line
now that a certificate is signed we can
begin to write a manifest so let's move
into a manifest folder and we'll create
a placeholder file
so we'll create a file called sample.pp
this is a sample file we won't be
writing anything in this file as of now
so we are just checking here we are just
creating this file and then we'll go to
our client machine and just check the if
we can access this file from there
so now we will move to our client
machine
[Music]
so let's test the connection
so as you can see here it says applied
catalog in 0.03 seconds so our catalog
is executed
on our client machine
now our catalog was just a placeholder
basically so the file that we created
which is sample.pp had no content and we
were just testing our client now let's
go back to our master server
put some content into this file and see
how the execution takes place
so we'll open our file sample.pp which
we created earlier in the vi editor
let's type our code here
so node and then within the brackets we
enter the host name of our client
machine
so this ensures that our manifest is
executed on this particular machine
now the apache service package on centos
is called the http
so this line that i just typed in is the
action it will ensure that the httpd
package is installed on your client
and that's it
so this is our code we'll save it
now let's go back to our client machine
and test it
so this is a client machine
and our catalogs applied on the client
so i just cleared the screen now we'll
start the apache service
okay so how do we see if it's running we
just need to go to our browser
and at localhost you must have the
testing page for your apache
so we type localhost
enter
and yeah this is the testing page for
apache so as you can see we have
successfully used puppet to install the
apache service on our puppet client
and this is the end of our demo ansible
is currently the most trending and
popular configuration management tool
and it's used mostly under the devops
approach so let's begin why should you
use ansible let's consider a scenario of
an organization where sam is a system
administrator sam is responsible for the
company's infrastructure a company's
infrastructure basically consists of all
its systems this could include your web
servers your database servers the
various repositories and so on so as a
system administrator sam needs to ensure
that all the systems are running the
updated versions of the software now
when you consider a handful of systems
this seems like a pretty simple task sam
can simply go from system to system and
perform the configurations required but
that is not the case with an
organization is it an organization has a
very large infrastructure it could have
hundreds and thousands of systems so
here is where sam's work gets really
difficult not only does it get tougher
sam has to move from system to system
performing the same task over and over
again this makes sam bored not just that
repeating the same task leaves no space
for innovation and without any ideas or
innovation how does the system grow and
the worst of it all is manual labor is
prone to errors so what does sam do well
here is where ansible comes in use with
ansible sam can write simple codes that
are deployed onto all the systems and
configure them to the correct states
so now that we know why we should use
ansible let's look at what exactly is
ansible ansible is an i.t engine that
automates the following tasks so first
we have orchestration orchestration
basically means bringing together of
multiple applications and ensuring an
order in which these are executed so for
example if you consider a web page that
you require to host this webpage stores
all its values that it takes from the
user into a database so the first thing
you must do is ensure that the system
has a database manager and only then do
you host your web page so this kind of
an order is very crucial to ensure that
things work right
next ansible automates configuration
management so configuration management
simply means that all the systems are
maintained at a consistent desired state
other tools that automate configuration
management include puppet and chef
and finally ansible automates deployment
deployment simply means the deploying of
application onto your servers of
different environments so if you have to
deploy an application on 10 systems with
different environments you don't have to
manually do this anymore because ansible
automates it for you in fact ansible can
also ensure that these applications or
the code are deployed at a certain time
or after regular intervals
now that we know what exactly ansible is
let's look at ansible's architecture
ansible has two main components you have
the local machine and you have your node
or the client machine so the local
machine is where the system
administrator sits he or she installs
ansible here and on the other end you
have your node or the client systems so
in case of ansible there's no supporting
software installed here these are just
the systems that require to be
configured and they are completely
controlled by the local machine at your
local machine you also have a module a
module is a collection of your
configuration files and in case of
ansible these configuration files are
called playbooks playbooks are written
in yaml yaml stands for yaml ain't a
markup language and it is honestly the
easiest language to understand and learn
since it's so close to english we also
have the inventory the inventory is a
file where you have all your nodes that
require configuration mentioned and
based on the kind of configuration they
require they are also grouped together
so later in the demo we'll have a look
at how the playbook and the inventory is
written and that will probably make it
clearer so of course a local machine
needs to communicate with the client and
how is this done this is done through
ssh ssh is your secure shell which
basically provides a protected
communication in an unprotected
environment okay so we saw the various
components of ansible now how does
ansible exactly work you have your local
machine on one end this is where you
install ansible if you have gone through
any previous material on ansible you
would have come across the term
agentless often being associated with
the stool so this is what agentless
means you're installing ansible only on
your local machine and there's no
supporting software or plugin being
installed on your clients this means
that you have no agent on the other end
the local machine has complete control
and hence the term agentless another
term that you would come across with
ansible is push configuration so since
the local machine has complete control
here it pushes the playbooks onto the
notes and thus it's called a push
configuration tool now the playbooks and
the inventory are written at the local
machine and the local machine connects
with the nodes through the ssh client
this step here is optional but it's
always recommended to do so it's where
the facts are collected so facts are
basically the current state of the node
now all this is collected from the node
and sent to the local machine so when
the playbook is executed the task
mentioned in the playbook is compared
against the current status of the note
and only the changes that are required
to be made further are made and once the
playbooks are executed your notes are
configured to the desired states so as i
mentioned before ansible is currently
the most trending tool in the market
under the configuration management
umbrella so let's have a look at the
various benefits of ansible which gives
it this position well ansible is
agentless it's efficient it's flexible
simple important and provides automated
reporting how does it do all this let's
have a look at that agentless as i
already mentioned before you require no
supporting software or plugin installed
on your node or the client system so the
master has complete control and
automatically this means that antibiotic
is more efficient because now we have
more space in our client and node
systems for other resources and we can
get ansible up and running real quick
ansible is also flexible so an
infrastructure is prone to change very
often and ansible takes no amount of
time to adjust to these changes
ansible cannot get any simpler with your
playbooks written in a language such as
yaml which is as close to english as you
can possibly get
air important basically means that if
you have a playbook which needs to be
run n number of systems it would have
the same effect on all of these systems
without any side effect and finally we
have automated reporting so in case of
ansible your playbook has a number of
tasks and all these tasks are named so
whenever you run or execute your
playbook it gives a report on which
tasks ran successfully which failed
which clients were not reachable and so
on all this information is very crucial
when you're dealing with a very large
infrastructure and finally we reach the
most exciting part of our tutorial the
hands-on before we move on to the actual
hands-on let me just brief you through
what exactly we'll be doing so i'll be
hosting two virtual boxes both centos 7
operating systems one would be my local
machine and other my node or the client
machine so on my local machine first
i'll install ansible we then write the
inventory and the playbook and then
simply deploy this playbook on the
client machine there's just one thing
that we need to do is that we need to
check if the configurations that we
mentioned in our playbook are made right
so we'll now begin our demo this is my
oracle virtualbox here i have my master
system which is the local machine and
this is the client machine so let's have
a look at these two machines this is my
client machine the terminals open right
now so the client machine terminal has a
black background with white text and the
master machine terminal has a white
background with black text just so you
can differentiate between the two so
we'll start at the master machine the
first thing to do is we need to install
our ansible so yum install
and build hyphen y is the command to do
so
so this might take some time
yeah so ansible is installed the next
step we go to our hosts file so hosts
file here is basically the inventory
it's where you'll specify all your nodes
in our case we just have one node
that's the path to your host file
as you'll see everything here is
commented so just type in the group for
your client notes
so i'm going to name it ansible clients
[Music]
and here we need to type the ip address
of a client machine so my client
machine's ip address is 192.168.2.127
so before you come to this it's advised
that you check the ip address on your
client machine the simple command for
that is ifconfig now once you type the
ip address put a space and here we need
to mention the username and the password
for our client
so i'll be logging in as the root user
so this is the password
and then the user
which is root in my case
that's it now you can save this file
just clear the screen
next we move on to our playbook we need
to write the playbook
so the extension for our playbook is yml
which stands for yaman
and as you can see here i have already
written my playbook but i'll just
explain to you how this is done
so a yaml file always begins with three
dashes this indicates the start of your
yaml file
now the first thing is you need to give
a name to the entire playbook
so i have named it sample book
host is basically where this would be
executed
so as we saw earlier in our inventory i
mentioned clients group name as ansible
clients so we use the same name here
the remote user is the user you'll be
using at your client so in my case
that's root and become true is basically
to indicate that you need to set your
privileges at root so that's called a
privilege escalation
now a playbook consists of tasks
so we have here three tasks the first
task i've named it to install httpd so
what we're doing here is we are
installing our http package which is
basically the apache server and we are
installing the most latest version of it
hence the state value is latest the next
task is running httpd so for the service
the name is httpd because that's the
service we need to start running and the
state is started our next task is
creating content so this is the part
where we are creating our web page
so copy because this is the file that
will be created at the client
the content will be welcome
and the destination of the file will be
via
www.html index.html as you know this is
like a default path that we use to store
all our html files
now as you can see here there's quite a
lot of indentation and when it comes to
yaml although it's very simple to write
and very easy to read the indentation is
very crucial
so the first dash here represents the
highest stage that is the name of the
playbook and all the dashes under task
are slightly shifted towards the right
so if you have two dashes at the same
location they basically mean that they
are siblings so the priority would be
the same so to ensure that all your
tasks are coming under the tasks label
make sure they are not directly under
name so yeah that's pretty much it so
when you write your yaml file the
language is pretty simple very readable
indentations absolutely necessary make
sure all your spaces are correctly
placed we can now save this file
next thing we need to check if the
syntax of our yaml file is absolutely
right because that's very crucial
so the command to check the syntax of
the yaml file is ansible
playbook
the name of your playbook
syntax check
so we have no syntax errors which is why
the only output you receive is
sample.yml which is the name of your
playbook
so our playbook is ready to be executed
the command to execute the playbook
is ansible playbook
and the name of your playbook
so our playbook is executed as you can
see here gathering facts that's where
all the facts of the note that the
present state of the note is collected
and sent to the local machine so it's
basically to check that if the
configuration changes that we are about
to make is already made
so it's not made we do not have the
httpd package installed on our node so
this is the first change that's made
also if it's not installed of course
it's not running that's the second
change that's made so it's put into the
running state
and a final task which is create content
is under the okay state this means that
the contents already present in the
client machine so i made it this way so
that you can actually see the different
states that's present
so over here we have okay four so four
things are all fine the facts are
gathered two things are changed and one
is already present two changes are made
zero clients are unreachable and zero
tasks have failed so this is the
documentation that i was referring to
previously that ansible provides
automatically
and is very useful as you can see
the next step we need to just check on
our client machine if all the changes
that we desired are made so let's move
to our client
so this is my client machine so to check
this since we are installing the httpd
package and hosting a web page the best
way to do it
is open your browser
and type in
localhost
so there you go your apache server is
installed and your web page is hosted
so that was very simple wasn't it
if you have any doubts about the
procedure or any other part of the
tutorial please post your doubts in the
comment section below and we'll get back
to you as soon as we see them we'll
provide the overview of how and why you
should be using kubernetes so why
kubernetes well kubernetes is really
being built from allowing you to be able
to have a more reliable infrastructure
the tool itself is designed to manage
the containers you have within your
network it's very modular in
architecture which allows it to be very
easy to be able to maintain and to be
able to scale and meet the demands that
your current customers are offering you
today the actual ability for you to be
able to deploy and update software at
scale is really at the heart and center
of kubernetes it's really one of the
reasons why kubernetes was created was
to be able to scale up the deployment of
software into tens of thousands of
networks and servers uh within a data
center and then finally when you start
working with kubernetes really what
you're doing is laying the foundation
for building cloud native applications
and part of this comes from the
architecture and history of kubernetes
which we'll get to in a little bit but
it's good to know that as you're using
kubernetes and containerized solutions
that you're really building out an
infrastructure that's designed for
cloud-centric solution delivery so let's
dig into why what kubernetes is so the
history of kubernetes is that it was
originally developed by google google
actually used the precursor to
kubernetes to manage and maintain the
data structured and data infrastructure
that they had within their network they
really liked it and one of the big
benefits that kubernete that google
provided is that they converted their
code into an open source program that
they released as kubernetes in 2014 and
made an open source this means that any
company can use kubernetes there's no
charge for it all you have to do is know
how to use the command lines to actually
get up and running the benefit of
kubernetes being open source is that
most cloud providers now support
kubernetes so whether you're using
microsoft azure you're using google
cloud or aws you'll find that you can
actually use kubernetes and kubernetes
and edit core really helped eliminate
manual processes so it allows for
deploying and scaling your
container-based solutions much more
effortless within a cloud environment so
let's jump into the features of
kubernetes and why you'd want to be
using it and we have a number of
features that we want to kind of step
through again the first thing that
kubernetes is a strong benefit of is
that it eliminates those manual
processes and allows you to automate
them the benefit you have from this is
that you can then scale up your
automation across your entire network so
whether you are managing 10 nodes within
your network or whether you're managing
10 000 doesn't matter you have the
ability to scale that something you
simply didn't have before kubernetes
also will manage the actual containers
themselves um including the security the
storage and the networking within those
containers the great uh benefit of
working with kubernetes is that uh not
only is it a cloud-centric solution but
it was really built from a core
need of a secure solution so security is
at the heart and center of all the work
you're doing which really helps benefit
any teams scaling out containers your
kubernetes environment will be
constantly monitored and so that when
you have nodes that have your containers
the health of those nodes is being
constantly communicated back to uh the
kubernetes environment so that the
entire environment is always being
managed and checked so if you have any
um additional hosting and launching that
needs to be done uh kubernetes will
help you automate those manual processes
uh if something does go wrong you can
actually set up your kubernetes
environment to do an automatic rollback
again this is just allowing you to have
that confidence that when you're
deploying a solution that everything is
going to work within that environment
and then finally kubernetes will allow
you to mount and add the storage needed
to run your apps so whether you have
storage such as a local ssd storage
device physically on the hardware or if
you're connecting to storage via the
cloud kubernetes will allow you to
access the storage you need how you're
accessing it so let's look a little bit
into the differences between kubernetes
and docker swarm so if we just step back
a little bit kubernetes and docker often
get connected with each other uh largely
because kubernetes manages containers
and docker is really famous for creating
the most popular container management
solution which is called docker if
you're a developer you're probably
already using docker today so
one of the things that kubernetes is
really really good at is that it manages
containers at scale just massive volume
of containers docker swarm is docker's
alternative to kubernetes it's a tool
that allows you to also manage large
number large numbers of containers um
there are differences between the two of
them and right now without doubt the
most popular um open source solution out
there is kubernetes from google it just
has a massive community behind it and
the community uh really have embraced um
kubernetes um yes the original product
was by developed by google but google
has been great steward and they've
allowed the community to drive the
future evolution of the product uh
docker swarm is actually managed and
developed by docker um there is a
smaller community but it is also a very
passionate community and the reason
being is that both products are actually
pretty good and you just really kind of
have to choose which one you want to go
with without doubt there is more
customization and extensions built for
kubernetes simply because the community
is just so much bigger than the docker
swarm community but with that said
docker swarm is really easy to set up so
if you are used to working within the
docker environment you will be able to
set up docker swarm very very quickly
whereas kubernetes does require some
heavy lifting to get up and running now
with that said if you are using
microsoft azure or google cloud very
often those environments will actually
set up kubernetes for you so you don't
have to do it and you can actually then
focus on writing the instructions to
maintain your kubernetes environment uh
kubernetes um has extremely high fault
tolerance again
it's because kubernetes is has been road
tested the foundation for kubernetes is
based on managing sites such as gmail
google.com
youtube i mean just incredibly robust
environment compared to docker swamp
which has lower fault tolerance and and
this really kind of leads into
the final areas where kubernetes does
guarantee um strong clusters and
management just a really reliable
environment dr swarm however is able to
take containers and deploy them into
large clusters very very quickly two
interesting differences is that with
kubernetes the load balancing is still
manual and be interesting to watch how
kubernetes matures that skill set uh in
contrast load balancing is automatic
within docker swarm so let's dig into
the kubernetes architecture and just
kind of expose some of those key
elements um if you're interested in
actually having a very deep dive into
kubernetes architecture we have already
got another video and we should have a
link in the comments that you can select
that will take you to that video as well
but this will provide you an overview as
well um so the way that kubernetes runs
is that it uses nodes to actually manage
all the individual hardware within a
specific unit and so a node is really a
physical machine
in a data center or a virtual machine
and when you're setting up an
environment on a cloud environment such
as microsoft azure or google cloud or
aws kubernetes will be managing the
containers within that node so it's
important to know that kubernetes itself
doesn't work with the individual nodes
but actually works with the cluster as a
whole and and why that's important is
that it's a tool to manage your entire
environment it's not going to come down
and manage the individual node itself
it's going to match the entire
environment the actual control of data
within a cluster and it's very very
flexible within kubernetes you can have
local storage such as an ssd
card or a traditional local storage or
you can actually connect to the cloud
and use cloud-based storage and the
benefit that cloud-based storage offers
you is that you are increasingly moving
your solution into more of a
hardware free environment cloud-based
architecture where you're not reliant on
a physical piece of hardware within your
data center and why that's important is
that it gives you the opportunity to
scale up your solutions much more
effectively so if you need to increase
the hard drive space you can do that
very easily from the cloud whereas local
hardware is a little bit harder to
manage great news kubernetes gives you
both options to be able to
choose from and so the the next layer
down is the actual management of the
application that's within a container
and as mentioned earlier docker is the
most popular container solution out
there and again if you're a developer
you're probably already using docker as
it was a natural maturity from using a
virtual machine but kubernetes itself
will actually manage the containers that
you have within your nodes and so you
have a collection of containers working
together and then you pull those
together into what's called a pod and
what's great is kubernetes will actually
manage the health of that pod so if a
container or a pod fails kubernetes will
automatically deploy out a replica so
your entire environment can stay running
and being efficient and so the pots
themselves will actually be managed by
kubernetes and you really want to
let kubernetes do this because it's
allowing you to
step away from the manual management of
parts your environment is just going to
be healthier relying on kubernetes to do
the actual management of all the pods
you have out there so you are able to
allow access to from services outside of
your kubernetes and this is done through
a process called ingress and
going back earlier we talked about how
security is a key part of all the work
that goes into kubernetes and this is a
great example of where you can use an
external service but still have that
layer of security that is vital for your
solution because to be able to provide
the ingress connection uh kubernetes
requires an ssl connection which um
automatically allows for a secure data
transfer absolutely fantastic so here we
have an overview of the actual
architecture on the right hand side we
have our nodes and the pods within our
nodes and within those pods are the
containers on the left hand side we have
the master architecture and the master
architecture is the actual brains behind
the work that you're doing it's actually
managing the schedules the controllers
uh for all of the nodes and then at the
bottom left-hand side we have commands
which are written on a local workstation
and those commands are pushed up to the
master so let's kind of dig a little bit
further into the architecture of the
master um so the master itself is uh
comprised of a number of key components
and again this is the tool that's going
to manage your uh entire kubernetes
infrastructure the key components that
you have are the etcd control manager
scheduler api server and the key four
components are etc or the cluster store
the controller manager the scheduler and
the api server the cluster store is the
tool where all the details of the work
that you're doing is stored and it's
going to manage the rules going to
manage all the instructions and this is
where you're going to post that
information the controller is actually
going to then perform the tasks that are
stored in the cluster store and as you'd
expect the schedule is the tool that
actually controls when instructions and
tasks are pushed out to
all the pods and nodes within your
network and then finally you have an api
server which allows you to be able to
control all the operations the actual
operations themselves are all
instructions written um as rest
instructions and which allows you to
take advantage of the security that has
been built into rest and so you end up
with a worker slave architecture and
slaves are all the different nodes and
pods within your network and so a part
itself will have multiple one or more
multiple containers and then each
container and then each pod will have a
docker container a kubelet and a
kubernetes proxy and the these are tools
to allow you to communicate back up to
the master layer so the docker is the
actual container itself and this is
going to actually run your application
and
the instructions here are to pull down
the correct container from the docker
images that you have within your library
the cubelet is going to manage your
containers and your container
instructions that will be deployed to
the cubelet are going to be written in
either yaml or jason format yaml is just
great if you haven't had a chance to
start working with yaml i certainly
encourage you to do so it's very easy to
pick up if you know any xml uh you'll
pick up yammer very quickly and finally
the kubernetes proxy is the tool that
interacts with the master environment
within the kubernetes network and allows
all the instructions from that are
pushed to the kubelet and to docker to
be able to perform effectively so let's
have a look at some of the companies
using kubernetes there are a lot and if
you're doing any work today in the cloud
and even if you're just starting off and
doing some simple
work in the cloud there's a really good
chance that you are using kubernetes but
some of the companies that you would are
probably not surprised at using
kubernetes are spotify sap ebay
and of course some of the the big
companies out there google with their
entire network of solutions and
microsoft with office and their tools so
let's take a a step into a youtube now
let's have a look at a kubernetes use
case and in this example we're going to
look at the new york times and how they
use kubernetes to solve a problem that
their iit department was struggling with
so when new york times started working
after their data centers their their
actual deployments were small and the
applications were managed across vms but
the problem is is that as new york times
became more of a digital company they
started building more digital solutions
and at some point they realized that uh
what they needed to do was to embrace
the cloud and move all their solutions
to the cloud however their first step of
using the cloud and this is i think
typical for a lot of companies is that
they treated the cloud hosted provider
in the same way as they would with a
data center and they at some point they
realized they had to take a change and
this is where the development team came
in and they said look how about we stop
thinking of our solutions as a data
center even though they're being run in
amazon and start thinking them as cloud
first solutions and so what they
proposed and what they ended up doing
was using google cloud platform with
kubernetes as servers um to
provide greater efficiency and so by
using kubernetes they had the following
advantages they're able to deliver
solutions at a much faster speed and in
the world of digital content speed is
everything they were able to reduce the
time for deployment from minutes to
seconds and by doing this they were able
to increase the amount of time that
uptime for the actual infrastructure um
updates began to be deployed
independently and when required so you
didn't have to schedule an event when
you did the deployment it just happened
and there was more unified approach to
deployment from the engineering staff
which just made the whole solution more
portable so the fundamental end line for
the new york times is that by leveraging
kubernetes they were able to
automatically manage their deployments
and scheduling of solutions instead of
having to do solutions through a more
traditional ticket-based system it just
really speed up the efficiency of the
new york times website so let's finally
kind of look into some of the important
terminologies before we take
our time to do a demo so we have six
terms that we're going to look through
um and we'll let you uh read through
these but uh we have a cluster which is
a set of machines physical vertical in
which applications are managed and run
we have a node that are the working
machines that run containerized
applications and other workloads there
is the pod which is within a node and is
a group of containers that are deployed
together on the same host we have
replication controllers and a
replication controller is used to define
a pod's life cycle rather than to create
the pods directly we have a selector
which is an expression match label to
filter specific resources labels are key
value pairs that are attached to objects
such as parts and the key value pair or
the label can be filter organize and
perform operations on resources
replication sets define how many
replicas of each pod will be running and
managed when you want to either replace
a pod when it dies annotation is a label
with much larger data capacity a name is
a resource as it is identified volume is
the directory which data is accessible
to a container namespaces provide
additional qualification to a resource's
name and then finally service is an
abstraction of a top-tier pods which
provide a single ip address and dns name
by which the pods can be accessed so
this time what we want to do is take you
through kubernetes demo actually runs
through some of these basic controls so
i'm going to take you through a video of
how to actually install kubernetes um
and to use some of the basic
instructions so kubernetes is the most
widely used platform for container
management the first step is to actually
install the necessary dependencies so
let's see if there's any updates first
so the first so to check if there's any
updates we use the command sudo app dash
get update we're entering our password
and this looks like it's going to take a
few minutes because we've got a few
updates that need to be running all
right we're done all right next we're
going to write sudo apt-get install dash
y apt-transport
https and this will install all the
dependencies we need to actually start
installing the solutions needed for
kubernetes all right that was quick now
we're going to put in the docker
dependency and the way we do that is
write the command sudo apt install
docker dot io i'll go to typo correct
that quickly and put in y so for yes and
we continue and it's going to take a
while because we're going to download
and install docker off the internet and
it's quite a large installation now
would be a good time to go get a cup of
coffee because it'll take us about a
minute to get this all done once we
actually have docker installed we'll let
you go ahead and we'll start docker and
enable docker using our sudo commands
all right so that's all done so let's
start to enable docker we're using so
we're gonna use sudo system ctl start
docker and sudo system ctl enable docker
this will be quite quick so the next
step is to install all the components
for kubernetes and we're going to uh
install the curl command and then
kuberlette cube c
and then cube adm and we're going to
install all the necessary tools we'll do
the curl command cubelet cubic c2 and
cube adm and so let's go ahead and put
in the sudo apt-get install curl we're
going to get a prompt we can say yes for
that and then after this we'll go ahead
and install kubernetes so the first what
we're going to do is we're going to
actually put in the kubernetes key so
that's going to be sudo curl dash s and
then we have a long url which is https
packages.cloudgoogle.com apt doc apt
dash key dot gpg
sudo apt dash key there we go and create
my typo there
okay now we have to go ahead and change
permissions of a folder so we do that
with sudo chmod 777 slash etc
apt
sources.list.d
all right we're good okay now you want
to go ahead and open up your text editor
and we're going to make um an actual
edit
and we're going to create a simple file
and so what we're going to type in is
the following command db http apt dash
dot kubernetes dot io slash kubernetes
xenial
main and we're going to save this file
in the etc folder and then look for and
then apt which is going to be down a
little bit and there we have it and
we're gonna save it in the
apt-get updates and we're gonna name
this file as
kubernetes dot list and we'll save that
and then we can close out the notepad
and go back to the terminal window and
let's look and see if there are any
updates again so we're going to go ahead
and run apt-get update and it's going to
run any updates from what we've created
and we want to check what's in the
folder and so we do
cat slash accept
etc
bt sources.this dot d slash kubernetes
dot list and there we are it shows what
we have in that text file and so we're
going to go ahead
and we're going to uh install uh cubelet
cubic cubic 2 and cube adm but first
we're going to have to initialize the
master i'm going to show you what an
error you would get if you were to
install cubelet um and the other files
too quickly you get the following error
all right so we have installed cubelet
qbadm cubex2 and kubernet cni and so
we're going to go ahead and use sudo
swap
dash hyphen a and now we're going to
initialize the master node and we're
going to do that with sudo cube
adm in it and this will take a few
minutes for it to initialize
all right so that's all done all right
so we're going to deploy the pod to a
network and we have two commands that
we're going to use we use sudo cube
cube ctl apply and then we have a long
pathway to type out which is dash f
https raw githubs
content dot com choreos final master
documentation cube dash file dot yml
what we we have to do is we have to
actually go ahead and deploy the nodes
first so we're going to do that by now
creating
mkdi dash p
and then we have
dollar sign home dash dot cube we'll
create that new directory and sudo cp
dash i and then the path will be
etc
slash kubernetes admin dot conf and then
dollar sign home slash dot cube dot
slash config
and then final one will be
[Music]
sudo
chown dollar sign open paren id dash u
close paren colon dollar sign brand id
slash dash g close paren dollar sign
home slash dot cube
config all right now we're going to go
ahead and deploy and uh let's see uh oh
yeah i think i have a typo in my command
here yep oh yeah i did have a typo and
so um i've got that incorrect now so
documentation is actually spelled with a
t not an s and then we're gonna go ahead
and we're going to put in the next
line which is pseudo cubic
cube ctl apply
dash f and then we're just going to
change a little bit of the
actual link here and that runs great and
now we want to be able to see all of the
parts that we have in our network and so
we're going to do that by uh writing the
command sudo qbec ctcl get pods dash all
dash dash name spaces and it should list
all of our pods we only have one
there we are there's all of our content
now we're going to so there's only one
node so let's see what we have here so
we can use the command sudo you know
cubic tl get nodes there we are just one
node so our final step is to actually go
ahead and deploy a service and so what
we're going to go ahead is deploy the
nginx service and we're going to do that
with the command sudo cubex ctl run dash
dash image equals nginx and we're going
to put this into port 80. so it's going
to be nginx
app dash dash port equals 80
environment emv equals uh ubuntu
open quotes a domain equals cluster
close quotes
and we're going to write one more
command which is sudo cube ctl expose
deployment nginx dash app dash dash port
equals 80
name equals nginx
http and once we've done this we will be
able to then run the command to actually
see our services and there'll be quite a
few of them
and our final command is sudo docker ps
dash a
and we have quite a lot of lists quite a
lot of services listed so there you are
that's the instructions on how to get
docker up and running and
with some basic commands and it it's
worth going through a few times to again
get right
but
once you actually have um the
kubernetes environment up and running
and managing your docker environment and
containers it's extremely powerful in
this section we're going to talk about
what is cloud computing and how things
were before aws and we're going to talk
about what is aws and the benefits of
aws and the products and services that
amazon offers as of now and then finally
we're going to end this session with a
project
that uh is going to help us understand
how to create
jenkins build server for continuous
integration and in this project we will
learn about how to deploy and host
jenkins an open source automation
software predominantly used for cicd
otherwise continuous integration and
continuous development so what is cloud
computing cloud computing is the
on-demand delivery of computer resources
through a cloud platform accessed via
the internet and it is a it's also a
pay-as-you-go service be it compute
capacity or database or storage in cloud
we access them through the internet and
that too on a pay-as-you-go pricing
model let's talk about how things were
before aws existed expedia as we know as
the people logistics company or the
company that helps people move around
the world with ease has a certain
problem before they decided to migrate
to aws and migrating to aws was a
solution to their problem back then
booking ticket was an unpleasant
experience compared to what it is now it
generally would take a long time to book
a ticket and sometimes it would time out
if there is a promotion or if a huge
sale announced and if the environment is
not scaled up to meet the demand and
sometimes it would time out if there is
a promotion or if a huge sale announced
and uh they could not scale up the
environment and keep up with the speed
of the promotion that's when they got
introduced to aws and with the aws power
to increase the capacity of the
environment on the fly
solved their scaling issue instead of
waiting on the new hardware to arrive
and wondering what to do with the
hardware when the promotion is over with
aws we can quickly scale up the
environment when there is a need and
scale down the environment during lull
periods now that being said let's talk
about what is aws amazon web services or
in short aws is a secure cloud service
platform offering compute power database
content delivery and other functionality
that you would need to help your
business scale and grow aws is a very
secure cloud platform and such security
cannot be imagined in on premises
without spending a fortune almost any
type of applications can be created and
deployed in the cloud which includes the
latest iot applications machine learning
artificial intelligence and so on and
the best part is we can avail the
service from anywhere as long as we have
an active internet and all this is
availed on pay as you go subscription
now let's talk about the benefits of aws
aws cloud platform is very easy to use
one needs no complicated programming or
compute knowledge to access and use this
environment even with less programming
and compute knowledge one could become a
probe in accessing and maintaining the
cloud the products and services offered
are very flexible in nature and that
provides room for us to easily integrate
the service to other services in aws and
services outside aws cloud in general is
a very reliable service and aws in
specific is very reliable cloud in
general is very reliable and when we
talk about aws it's very true a
statistic says that about 95 percent of
the cloud computing in the whole world
is run on aws due to aws reliable nature
their services in aws are scalable by
nature and most of the services provide
click button scaling services in aws are
very cost effective and it becomes very
true when you start using more services
and aws are very cost effective and it
becomes very true when you start using
more service services in aws are very
cost effective and it becomes more true
when we start using more since when we
start using more service the per unit
price drops down even further security
in the cloud is at its highest with
encryption and multi-factor
authentications and being able to audit
the logs one can be sure that when one
hosts a service in aws they are hosting
it in an environment which has been
built with enterprise security in mind
all right let's now talk about or talk
briefly about the different products and
services available in the cloud some of
the products and services available in
the cloud are compute storage database
migration services networking and
content delivery developer tools and
services available for managing the aws
environment tools needed for machine
learning development analytic tools
needed for security and identity
compliance tools needed for mobile
application services tools needed for
iot and gaming development are some of
the products that are available in aws
all right let's first talk about compute
service now compute service it enables
us to develop loy run and scale our
applications and workloads on the cloud
you might agree with me that compute
service is the fundamental of any
applications and aws provides many
options to use those compute services in
the cloud starting from ec2 which is a
vm in the cloud to lambda which is
server-less computing in the cloud to
compute service compute service also
includes container services and services
that help batch processing and deploying
applications and load balancing the
request when we run our applications on
multiple servers and services that help
batch processing and developing
applications and load balancing the
request when we run our applications in
multiple servers we're going to talk
about two compute products in specific
let's talk about ec2 ec2 is a service
with a resizable compute capacity in the
cloud that allows business subscribers
to run application programs in the
computing environment and the best part
here is ec2 is resizable anytime there
is more demand i can simply resize my
computer to meet the demand on the other
hand lambda is a serverless compute
service used to execute back-end codes
it really helps us to focus on the core
competencies like application building
the code let's talk about storage
service for a while aws storage is known
for its durability and availability with
s3 being the object storage for the
internet where users or application can
directly upload and download the content
from the internet and ebs being a
durable block storage that gets attached
to the ec2 instance and glacier being
the archival solution in the cloud and
storage gateway being the gateway for
storing data locally and having a backup
in the cloud in case of disaster let's
talk about two important storage service
products in the cloud which is s3 now s3
is an web-based cloud storage service
it's designed for online backup and
archiving of data and the best part
about s3 is that it provides level 9
durability which means once we stored
the data in s3 the chances of losing the
data is nearly zero ebs on the other
hand provides persistent and resizable
and migratable storage to the vms or
ec2s that we can run in the cloud now
let's talk about the database offerings
in the cloud beginning with rds for sql
and dynamodb for nosql and elastic cache
for web caching services and amazon
redshift for petabyte scale data
warehousing services aws database
service provides all the database
service needs we might have let's talk
about two database services in specific
rds rds is an web service that is
designed to simplify the setup operation
and scaling of the relational database
in the cloud and dynamodb is an fast and
flexible nosql database service which is
well known for its low latency and
scalability performance
network and content delivery service
contributes to the infrastructure as a
service side of the cloud it provides a
secure cloud infrastructure and connects
our physical network to our private
virtual network with low latency and
high transfer speeds and under
networking and content delivery services
vpc is virtual private cloud networking
in the cloud route 53 is the dns service
in the cloud and direct connect is a
service that connects our on-premises
with aws environment through
point-to-point cables and cloudfront is
content delivery network or caching
service throughout the world let's talk
about the vpc for a while vpc it enables
us to launch aws resources into a
virtual network that we define in the
cloud vpc resembles very similar to our
office network with the subnets
firewalls
private zones public or dmz zones and
lot more we can also create a vpn
connection between on-premises and cloud
environment through this vpc and route
53 it is a scalable and highly available
domain name system web service that
helps to route the end users to the
internet application now aws is a domain
registrar as well and here we can buy
domain names for our organization and
use them to mask the ip addresses behind
it and by the way if you didn't know
already dns is the one that translates
human readable names like www.xyz.com
into the numeric ip address let's talk
about developer tool services now
developer tool services in amazon
provides services where developers can
store an application source code and
automatically build test and deploy
applications on aws out of which aws
codestar enables us to quickly develop
build and deploy applications in aws and
code build is a fully managed build
service that compiles source code
runs tests and produces software
packages that are ready to deploy and
code deploy on the other hand is a
service that automatic that automates is
a service that automates software
developments to a variety of compute
services including amazon ec2 amazon
lambda and even instances running on
premises and aws code pipeline is a
continuous integration and continuous
delivery service for fast and reliable
application and infrastructure updates
let's talk about codestar codestar is a
service designed for developers where
they can quickly deploy build and
develop applications on aws aws codestar
provides a unified user interface
enabling us to easily manage our
software development activities in one
place with aws code star we can set up
our entire continuous delivery tool
chain in minutes allowing us to start
releasing codes faster and not only that
aws code star makes it easy for you or
your whole team to work together
securely allowing you to easily manage
access and add owners contributors and
viewers to our project and not only that
aws codestar project comes with a
project management dashboard including
an integrated issue tracking
capabilities provided by jira software
with the aws codestar project dashboard
we can easily track progress across our
entire software development process from
our backlog of work items to teams
recent code deployments so on and so
forth aws code build on the other hand
is an cloud service that enables an it
developer to build and test code with
continuous scaling now here you pay only
for the build time that you have used
now code build is an fully managed
service that helps compiling source
codes and run tests and produce software
packages that are ready to deploy aws
with aws code build we there is no need
for us to provision manage and scale our
own build servers code build scales
continuously and process and processes
multiple bills concurrently so our bills
are not left waiting in the queue
because it's processed concurrently
let's talk about
security identity and complaint services
available in amazon in general the
in amazon helps us to maintain a secure
environment in amazon by providing
services for user authentication for
limiting the access to certain set of
users on the aws environment out of
which iam or identity and access
management it's a product that enables
us to manage access to aws services and
resources that enables us to manage
access to aws resources and services in
a secure fashion using iam we can create
and manage aws users and groups and use
permissions to allow and deny their
access to aws resources on the other
hand kms or key management service is a
managed service that makes it easy for
us to create and control the encryption
keys used to encrypt our data and
cognito it lets us to add user sign up
sign in and access control to our web
and mobile apps quickly and easily and
waff or web application firewall helps
us to protect our web applications from
common web exploits that could affect
application availability that could
compromise security or consume excessive
resources and waff it gives us good
control over which traffic to allow or
block to our applications by sort of
defining customizable web security rules
we can use waft to create custom rules
that block common attack patterns such
as sql injections or cross-site
scripting and we can also create rules
that are designed for our specific
application out of all the four identity
and access management it helps us to
control access to aws services and
resources for our users with the
identity and access management i can
restrict user access or i can give a
user complete access to the environment
if it's an admin i can assign complete
access and if it is a user i can provide
some privileged access or less or
degraded or no access depending on the
role that the user plays in the
organization and kms is a service that
helps us to create and control the
encryption keys used to encrypt the data
and also we can use hardware security
model hsm to protect the security of our
data in the cloud also we can use
hardware security model to protect the
security of the key itself and let's
talk about the management the tools and
services available in amazon management
tools and services it helps us to manage
monitor and automate all the resources
running in the aws infrastructure
beginning with a cloud watch a service
which monitors the environment by
receiving logs and creating a dashboard
and sending alerts as needed and cloud
formation a service that a service
through which we can deploy new
environments using just templates and
auto scaling a product that lets us to
handle the dynamic traffic with ease by
dynamically scaling up and scaling down
the environment as needed and cloudtrail
is another product or another monitoring
tool that helps us to monitor or collect
the logs of all the api calls to our
environment and provides a searchable
tool based on keywords and timestamps
let's talk about cloudwatch a bit more
detail now cloudwatch is a monitoring
service for aws with cloudwatch we can
collect we can track the metrics we can
collect and monitor log files we can
also enable cloudwatch to set alarms and
automatically react to changes in the
aws environment cloudwatch can also
monitor aws resources such as ec2
instances dynamodb tables amazon rds
instances as well as custom metrics
generated by your application and
services and any log files your
applications would generate now we can
use cloudwatch to get a system-wide
visibility into resource utilization
application performance and operational
health we can use these insights to
react and keep your applications running
smoothly and cloud formation on the
other hand provides a common language
for us to describe and provision all the
infrastructure resources in our cloud
environment now cloudformation allows us
to set up and model all our aws
resources so that we can spend less time
in managing those resources and more
time on our application our cloud
formation is really an infrastructure as
a code service where i can build an
infrastructure based on the portable
template i might be carrying all right
in this demo session we'll talk about
how to install jenkins on amazon linux
ec2 instance and before that let's talk
about what is jenkins and what is the
purpose of it why it is used and all
that stuff now what is jenkins now
jenkins is an open source automation
server and it provides a lot of inbuilt
plugins for deploying and automating any
project in short you know it's an
continuous integration server and it is
used for many purposes used for tasks
that take care of continuous deployment
and delivery and it provides these
advantages like the developer now will
not have to focus on fixing errors
because errors are automatically handled
by jenkins and because of that it leads
to faster development environment all
right so how do we go about doing it
let's get started the first thing is to
go to our console and launch an ec2
instance actually let me walk you
through the steps through the ppt and
then i'll show it in the console so let
me first walk you through the steps in
installing a jenkins server in this lab
we're going to launch an vm or a virtual
application server to host our jenkins
installation and then we are going to
deploy jenkins on top of it and then
configure it as an build server and for
this we will need an aws account to
begin with and then a bit of experience
in jenkins and then some familiarity on
ec2 and how ec2 gets connected to vpc
stuff like that so when we're all done
this is how the architect is going to
look like you know users they get
connected to ec2 instance which is a
jenkins server and then there are slaves
build slaves that can be monitored that
can be used in deployment
by the jenkins server so let's see how
it is done all right so let's first
launch a server let it be an
amazon linux instance i'm going to pick
t2 micro because of the free eligibility
and because this is a lab that should be
more than enough and i'm going to keep
this as default you know i'm going to
stick with the default vpc and i'm going
to keep all the settings as defaults and
then i'm not going to add a storage i'm
going to keep the storage limited with
the root volume and then for security
group because we're going to access it
through the internet i would like port
80 in fact since this is a lab
environment and since i'll be tearing it
down all right after the lap is over
we're going to use all ip or we're going
to use anywhere all traffic anywhere
view
and launch and i already have a key pair
that i have created if you're not
familiar with creating keypair launching
ec2 instance you might need to spend
some time watching the aws ec2 video
that would help so i already have a key
pair that's attached to this account in
this region so i'm using that key pair
to launch the instance
all right then that's my jenkins server
all right so once that is installed
let's log into it since this being an
linux instance i'm going to use putty to
log in and then use the key pair that we
have downloaded to log in
and the key pair was
right here
all right now i'm connected to it as
first thing we will have to install the
java environment i'm going to show some
commands towards end so if you're
planning to do labs yourself you can use
those commands they will be very handy
in fact i can
show it right now as we speak
so these commands are to install java
environment
and it has two versions as we speak and
i've chosen the latest version so i've
typed two and i've chosen the latest
version in installing java environment
the second is to install apache maven
let me show you some commands that's
used to install apache mavic and these
commands vary from you know linux
version to linux version so if you're
using a different linux version just be
sure that you're using commands which
are respective to that particular
version
all right let's install apache maven
looks like some of them are already
installed and
it's doing error for some but anyway
it's an it's it's considered
unsuccessful installation and then let's
install jenkins
and the commands to install jenkins is
right here so these are to install
jenkins and i mean to download the
software and install it and then start
the jenkins and make sure the jenkins
stays
running even after a reboot so let's run
these commands
all right now jenkins should be ready or
the jenkins server is installed in our
ac2 instance and it is ready for us to
access and the default port is port 8080
so let me go to the url or ip let me go
to that and then try accessing it using
port 8080
there you go so at the moment it's
locked it requires admin password to log
in and the admin password is present in
this particular folder and this
particular file in the linux instance
so let me get that
okay one moment looks like the admin
password is not present just give me one
quick moment
okay it's just a permission issue
let me
check the password in that folder again
with the elevated permissions there you
go there's my password
all right once we're logged in we can
install all the suggested plugins
now that's going to take some time to
run and install all the selected
all the default plugins needed to run a
jenkins server
all right it's done
now as next thing it's going to ask for
the admin username and password you can
choose as an existing administrator or
you can also create an another admin
user in this case i'm going to create
another admin user
all right so the jenkins server is
installed we can use the similar but
slightly different procedure on the
jenkins nodes or the slave servers to
make them jenkins slave and respond to
the bills that we push or receive the
bills or receive the jobs that we push
through this jenkins server so we have
built this
jenkins server on amazon ac2 a similar
and slightly different procedures can be
followed to build jenkins build servers
that can contact jenkins server to
receive jobs and you know start working
if you're looking for a video that talks
and walks you through all the services
in azure then this could be one of the
best video you could find in the
internet everybody like story is it so
let's get started with the story in a
city not so far away a ceo had plans to
expand his company globally and called
one of his id personal for an i.t
opinion and this guy has been in the
company for a long time and is very
seasoned with the company's infra and he
nicely answered the questions with what
he foresaw and he said i have a good
news and a bad news for us to go global
and he starts with the good news he said
sir we're well on our way to become one
of the world's largest shipping company
and the bad news is however our data
centers have almost run out of space and
setting up new ones around the world
would be too expensive and very time
consuming now the it personal let's call
him mike now he explains the situation
from how he saw it but the ceo had done
some homework about how he was going to
do it and he answered mike saying don't
worry about that mic i've come up with a
solution for a problem and it's called
microsoft azure well mike is an hard
working honest i.t professional working
for that company but he did not spend
time on learning the latest technologies
and he asked this question very honestly
oh how does it solve a problem and the
ceo begins to explain azure to mike and
he starts with what is cloud computing
and then he goes on and talks about
azure and the service is offered by
azure and why azure is better than the
other cloud providers and what are the
great companies that uses azure and how
they got benefited out of it and then he
winds it all up with the use cases of
azure so he begins his explanation
saying microsoft azure is known as the
cloud service provider and it works on
the basis of cloud computing now
microsoft azure is formerly known as
windows azure and it's a microsoft's
public cloud computing platform it also
provides a range of cloud services
including some of them are compute
analytics storage and networking we can
always pick and choose from these
services to develop and scale our
applications or even plan on running
existing applications in the public
cloud microsoft azure is both a platform
as a service and infrastructure as a
service let's now fit their conversation
out and let's talk about what is cloud
computing azure services offered by
azure how is azure leading when compared
to other cloud service providers and
what are the companies that are using
azure let's talk about that in simple
terms cloud computing is being able to
access compute services like servers
storage database networking
software analytics intelligence and lot
more over the internet which is the
cloud with the
flexibility of the resources that we use
like anytime i want a resource i can use
one and it becomes available immediately
and anytime if i want to retire and
resource i can simply retire as a
service and not pay for it and we also
typically pay only for the services that
we use and this helps greatly with our
operating cost to run our infrastructure
more efficiently and scale our
environment up or down depending on the
business needs and changes and all the
servers and storages and databases and
networking all that are accessed through
the network of remote systems or remote
computers hosted in the internet
typically in the provider's data center
which is azure in this case
now we don't use any physical server or
an on-premises server here well we still
use physical servers and vms you know
hosted on a hardware or a physical
server but they're all in the provider's
environment and none of them sit on
premises or in our data center we only
access them remotely it looks and feels
the same except for the fact that they
are in a remote location we access them
remotely do all the work remotely and
when we're done we can shut it down and
not pay for them so some of the use
cases
some of the use cases of cloud computing
are creating applications and services
the other use cases are storing or using
cloud for storage alone
if there is one thing that ever grows in
their organization is the storage every
new day there is a new storage
requirement and it's very dynamic it's
very hard to predict and if we go out
and buy a big storage capacity up front
until we use the storage capacity fully
the empty storages you know we're
wasting money on them so instead i can
go for a storage which scales
dynamically that's in the cloud put
storage or put data in the cloud and pay
only for what you're storing and for the
next month if you have deleted or
flushed out some files or data pay less
for it so it's a very dynamic storage in
the cloud and a lot of companies are
getting benefited from storing data in
the cloud because of its uh dynamic in
nature and the cost that comes along
with it the cheap cost that comes along
with it and also they give a lot of the
providers like azure they give a data
replication for free they promise an sla
along with the data we store in the
cloud so there's an sla attached to it
and they also provide data recoveries as
well if in case something goes wrong
with the physical disk where our data is
stored azure automatically makes our
data available from the redundant or
other places where it had stored our
data because of the sla they wanted to
keep the other use case for azure is
hosting websites and running blogs using
the compute service
be it storing music and letting your
users stream the music azure is a good
place to store music and stream the
music with the benefit of
cdn content delivery network which
allows us to stream a video or audio
files with great speed you know with
that with azure our audio or video
application works seamlessly because
they are provided to the client with
very low latency and that improves the
customer experience for our application
azure compute service is a good place
for delivering software on demand there
are a lot of software's embedded
softwares that we can buy using azure
and everything on a pay as you go
service model so anytime we need a
software we can go out and immediately
buy the software for the next one r or
2r let's say and use them and then
return it back
we're not bound to any yearly licensing
cost by that azure computing services
has analytic available for us with which
we can analyze get a good visualization
of what's going on in a network be it
logs be the performance be the metrics
you know instead of looking at logs and
searching logs and trying to do manual
things over the heaps and heaps of logs
that we have saved azure analytics
services helps us to get a good visual
of what's going on in the network where
have we dropped where have we increased
or what's causing what's the major
driver what does the top 10 errors that
we get in the server in the application
stuff like that those can be easily
gathered from the azure analytic
services
now cloud is really a very cool term for
the internet a good analogy would be
looking back anytime we look at a
diagram when we do not know how things
are transferred we simply draw a cloud
right for example a male gets sent from
a person in one country to a person in
the other country a lot of things
happening in between from the time you
hit the send button and the time the
other person hits the real button right
and we that the simple and the easiest
way of putting it in a picture is simply
draw a cloud and on the one end one
person will be sending the email and on
the other end the other person will be
reading the email so a cloud is a really
cool term for the internet now that's
some basics about cloud computing now
that we've understood about cloud
computing in general let's talk about
microsoft azure as a cloud service
now microsoft azure is a set of cloud
services to build
manage and deploy applications on a
network with the help of microsoft
azure's frameworks now microsoft azure
is a computing service created by
microsoft basically for building testing
deploying and managing applications and
services through a global network of
microsoft managed data centers now
microsoft azure provides sas which is
software as a service and pass which is
platform as a service and ias
infrastructure as a service and they
support many different programming
languages tools and framework and those
tools and framework include both
microsoft specific and third-party
software now let me pick and talk about
a specific service for example
management azure automation provides a
way for us to automate the manual long
running and frequently repeated tasks
that are commonly performed tasks both
in cloud and enterprise environment it
saves us a lot of time and increases the
reliability and it kind of gives a good
administrative control and even
schedules the task automatically to be
performed on a regular basis
to give you a quick history of microsoft
azure it was launched on first february
and it was awarded or it was called
an industry leader for infrastructure
and platform as a service by a gartner
now gartner is the world's leading
research and advisory company this
microsoft azure supports a number of
programming languages like c sharp java
and python all these cool services we
get to use and pay only for how much we
use for example if we use for an r we
only get to pay for an r even the
costliest system available if we use
them for an r we only pay for that
particular r and then we're done no more
billing on the resource that we have
used
microsoft azure has spread itself more
than 50 regions around the world so it's
quite easy for us to pick a region and
it will start provisioning and running
our applications probably from day one
because the infrastructure and the tools
and technologies needed to run our
application are already available all
that we have to do is commit the code in
that particular region or build an
application and launch it in that
particular region and they become live
starting day one now because we have 50
regions around the world we can very
carefully design our environment to
provide low latency
services to our customers all right
instead of in traditional data center
let's say you know customers will have
to or their request will have to travel
all the way around the globe to reach a
data center which lives in the other
side of the planet and this adds more
latency to it and it is really not
feasible to build a data center
near
each customer location because of the
cost involved but with azure it's
possible azure already has data centers
around the world and all that we have to
do is just pick a data center build an
environment there they are available
starting day one number one and also the
cost is considerably saved because we
are using a public cloud instead of an
physical infrastructure to serve those
customers from a very local location and
these services that azure is offering is
ever increasing as of now as we speak we
have like 200 plus services offered and
they span through different domain or
different platform or different
technologies available within the azure
console portal now we're gonna talk
about that later in this section so hold
your breath till we talk about it but
for now just know that we have like 200
plus services offered by azure
let's now talk about different services
and azure starting with artificial
intelligence plus machine learning where
we have a lot of tools and technologies
so the wide variety of services
available on azure includes artificial
intelligence plus machine learning plus
analytic services to get an or to give
us a good visual of how the data or how
the application is performing or the
type of the category of data stored and
to read from the logs and variety of
compute services different vms with
different size and different operating
systems different containers available
different type of databases available a
lot of developer tools that are
available for us
an identity service to
manage our users in the azure cloud and
those users can be integrated or
federated with let's say google facebook
you know linkedin so there are some
external federation services they can be
used to integrate with our identity
system iots iot services iot tools and
technologies available and management
tools to manage the users you know
creating identity is one and then
managing them on top of it is a totally
different thing and we have tools
technologies to manage the users
cool services for data migration data
migration is now made simple tools and
technologies available for mobile
application development and i can plan
my own network in the cloud with the
networking services i can implement my
own security both azure provider and
third-party security services on azure
cloud that's now possible and a lot of
storage options available in the cloud
so these are just a glimpse of the big
list of services available in azure
cloud so that was a glimpse of what's
available in the cloud let's talk about
the services in a specific let's take
compute for example you know whenever
we're building a new application or
deploying existing ones
the azure compute service provides the
infrastructure we need to run and
maintain our application we can easily
tap in the capacity that azure cloud
service has and we can scale our compute
requirement on demand we can also
containerize our application we have the
option of choosing windows or linux via
machine and take the advantage of the
flexible options azure provides for us
to migrate our vms to azure and lot more
and these compute services also include
a full-fledged identity solution meaning
integration with active directory in the
cloud or in on-premises and lot more
let's look at some of the services that
this compute domain provides
some of the services the compute domain
provides are virtual machines and this
azure virtual machines
gives us the ability to develop and
manage a virtual computer environment or
a virtualized environment inside azure's
cloud environment that do in a virtual
private network now we will talk about
virtual private network at a later point
but as of now just
know that there are a lot of services
available in azure compute servers that
we can get benefited from we can always
choose from a very wide range of compute
options
for example you know we have an option
to choose the operating system we have
the option to choose whether the system
should be in on-premises or in the cloud
or do we want to maintain the
environment both in on premises and in
the cloud we have the option of choosing
the operating system whether we want to
use our own operating system with some
software attached to it or do we want to
go and buy the operating system from the
cloud from azure marketplace and these
are just a few of the options available
for us when we want to buy the compute
environment and these compute
environments are easily scalable meaning
we can easily scale our vm instances
from one instance to thousands of
virtual machines in a matter of minutes
or simply put in a couple of button
clicks and all these services are
available on a pay for what we use model
meaning there is no upfront cost we use
the service and then pay for the
services that we have used there is no
literal long term commitment when it
comes to using virtual machines in the
cloud and these most of the services are
built on a
pay-per-minute billing basis all right
and at no point because of the
pay-per-minute billing model at no point
we will be overpaying for any of the
services that's that's attractive isn't
it now let's talk about batch service
now batch service is always independent
regardless of whether you choose windows
or linux it's going to run fairly well
and with batch servers we can take
advantage of the environment's unique
features and not only that in short the
batch service helps us to manage the
whole batch environment and also it
helps to schedule the jobs now this
azure batch services actually runs on a
large scale parallel and high
performance computing because of that
batch jobs are highly efficient in azure
and when we run bad services this azure
batch creates a pool of computer nodes
and installs the needed applications
that we want to run and then it
schedules jobs to those individual nodes
in those pools as a customer there is no
need for us to install a cluster or
there is no need for us to install a
software that actually can use the jobs
or even to manage or even to scale those
infrastructure or the software because
everything is managed by azure and this
batch service is a platform as a service
there is no additional charge for using
this batch service except for
i mean the only charges that we'll be
paying is for the virtual machines that
the service uses and the storage that we
will be using of course and
the networking services that we will be
using for this batch service let's
summarize this bad service we have a
choice of operating system that we can
pick and use and it scales by itself now
the alternative for the batch would be
queues but in queues we'll have to
pre-provision and pay for the
infrastructure even if we're not using
it but with a batch we only pay for what
we use and this bad service helps us to
manage the application manage the
scheduling as a whole as if they are
just one thing as next thing in the
compute domain let's talk about this
fabric service now this fabric service
is actually a distributed system
platform that helps us to package
deploy and manage a scalable and a very
reliable microservice and containers and
what does it help this azure fabric
service helps us or it helps the
developers and administrators so they
can avoid the complex infrastructure
problems and they can focus only on
implementing workloads or taking care of
their development taking care of their
application instead of spending time on
infrastructure so what service fabric
service fabric it provides runtime
capabilities and life cycle management
two applications that are composed of
micro services no infrastructure
management at all and with service
fabric we can easily scale the
application to tens or hundreds or even
to thousands of machines here machines
represent containers as next thing in
compute domain let's talk about virtual
machine scale set now this virtual
machine scales that it lets us to create
a group of identical load balanced vms i
just want to mention it again it helps
us to manage a group identical and load
balanced vms the number of instances or
the number of vm instances in an
in a skill set can increase or decrease
in response to
the demand or in response to schedule
that we define you know the resources
needed on a monday morning is not the
same as that would be required on a
saturday or a sunday morning all right
and even within the day the resources
that would be needed in the beginning of
the business hour is not the resources
that would be needed at noon or you know
after eight or nine in the evening so
the demands could actually vary in the
environment and this skill set helps us
to take care of the varying demand or
take care of the different
infrastructure requirement at a
different schedule throughout the day
throughout the week throughout the month
or could be throughout the year as well
the skill set also allows us to provide
high availability to our applications
and it helps us to centrally manage
configure and update a large number of
vms as if they they are just one thing
now you might ask well virtual machines
are enough why would we need a virtual
machine scale set just like i said this
virtual machine skill set helps us with
a greater redundancy and improved
performance for our applications and
those applications can be accessed
through a load balancer that actually
distributes other requests to the
application instances so in a nutshell
this virtual machine scale set uh it
helps us to create a large number of
identical virtual machines number one
and with skill set we can increase or
decrease the virtual machines with
virtual machine scale set we can
centrally manage and configure and
update a big group of vms and it's a
great use case when it comes to big data
or container workloads as next thing in
compute domain let's talk about cloud
services now this azure cloud service is
actually a platform as a service and
it's very friendly in fact it is
designed for applications that support
scalability or an application that
requires scalability or reliability and
and on top of it you want them to be
very inexpensive to operate so azure
cloud service provides all these so
where would this cloud service run well
it runs on a vm but it's a platform as a
service vms are infrastructure as a
service and when we run applications on
vm through cloud service it becomes
platform as a service so here is how you
got to be thinking with infrastructure
as a service like vms we first create
and configure the environment and then
we run applications on top of it let's
look at the responsibility the
responsibility for us in vm is that we
manage everything end to end like uh you
know deploying new patches picking the
versions of the operating system and
making sure they are intact and all that
stuff it's all managed by us but on the
contrary with platform as a service it's
i mean it's as if the environment is
already ready all that you have to do is
deploy your application in it and manage
the platform i mean manage the platform
not as an administrator because all the
administration is taken care by azure
like you know deploying new versions of
the operating system it's all handled by
the azure so we deploy the application
and we manage the application that's it
infrastructure management is handled by
azure so what does cloud service provide
this cloud service provides a platform
where we can
write the
application code and we don't have to
worry about hardware simply hand over
the code and cloud service takes care of
it so no worry on the hardware at all so
responsibilities like patching what do
we do if something
crashes how do i update the
infrastructure how do i manage
the maintenance or the downtime in the
underlying infrastructure all that is
handled by azure it also provides a good
testing environment for us you know we
can simply run the code test it before
it's actually released to the production
i want to expand a bit on these testing
applications so this azure cloud service
it actually gives us an staging
environment for testing a new release
without it affecting the existing
release which actually reduces the
customer downtime so we can run the
application test it and anytime that's
ready for production all that's needed
for us to do to move it to production is
simply to swap the staging environment
into the production environment and the
old production environment will now
become the new staging environment where
we can
add more to it and then swap it back at
a later point so it kind of gives us
unswappable environment for testing our
applications and not only that it gives
us health monitoring alerts it helps us
to monitor the health and availability
of our application and there is a
dashboard we can benefit from when we
use azure cloud services and that shows
the key statistics all in one place and
we can also set up real-time alerts to
one when a service availability or a
certain metrics that we are concerned
about degrades as next thing in compute
domain let's talk about functions now
functions are serverless computing now
many times if you heard about azure
being serverless a lot of time they are
referencing or the person who's talking
to you is referencing to serverless
computing or azure functions which is a
serverless computing service hosted on
microsoft azure the main motive of
a function is to accelerate and simplify
application development functions helps
us to run code on demand without
we need to pre-provision or manage any
azure infrastructure so azure functions
are script or
a piece of code that gets run in
response to an event that you want to
handle so in short we can just write a
code that you need for a problem at hand
without actually worrying about the
whole application or the infrastructure
that will be running
that code and the best of all the best
is when we use functions we only pay for
the time that our code runs
so what does functions provide or what
does azure functions provide azure
functions allow users to build
applications using serverless
simple functions with a programming
language of our choice so the current
programming languages that are supported
is c sharp f sharp node.js java and php
so here we really don't have to worry
about provisioning or maintaining
servers if a code requires more resource
yes azure functions handles or it
provides the additional resources needed
by the court and the best part is we
only pay for the amount of time the
functions are running not the resources
but the amount of time the function is
running as next thing and moving to the
new domain let's talk about the
container domain in azure now the
container domain or the container
service it allows us to quickly deploy a
production ready kubernetes or a docker
swamp cluster now what's a container a
container is a standard unit of software
that packages of code and all its
dependencies so the applications run
quickly and reliably from one computing
environment to another it could be a
testing uh to staging to developing
development environment to staging to
production or from one production to
another production or on premises to
cloud or one cloud to another cloud vice
versa now imagine we had an option not
to worry about the vm and just focus on
the application well that's exactly what
containers helps us achieve so these
container instances enable us to focus
on applications and not worrying about
managing vms or not worrying about the
learning the new tools required to
manage the vms or even the deployment
and our applications that we create they
run in a container running in a
container is what helps us to achieve
all these not being able to manage or
not needing to manage the virtual
machines so these containers
they can be deployed into the cloud
using a single command if you're using
command line interface and
a couple of button clicks if we are
using the azure portal and these
containers are kept
lightweight but they are equally secure
as virtual machines let's talk about
container services next thing the
container service or
sometimes called as azure kubernetes
service it helps us to manage
the containers container is one thing
and a service that's used to manage the
container is another thing now this
kubernetes service or acs it helps us to
manage the containers so let's expand on
this a bit so this azure container
service or acs it it actually provides a
way to simplify the creation
configuration and management of a
cluster of virtual machines that are
pre-configured to run containerized
applications on top of them and
deploying them deploying these
containers might take like 15 to 20
minutes or deploying the virtual
machines that run containers in it might
take 15 to 20 minutes and once they are
provisioned we can actually manage them
by using simple ssh tunnel into them and
this acs when it runs application it
runs applications from docker images
what does that mean a docker images
makes sure that the applications the
container runs are fully portable images
are portable and acs also helps us to
orchestrate the container environment
not only that it also helps us to ensure
that these applications that we run in
containers can be scaled to thousands or
even tens of thousands of containers so
in a nutshell managing an existing
application into a container and running
it using aks or acs is really easy or
that's what it is all about to make the
application management or migration easy
now managing the container based
architecture and we discussed that
containers could be tens or even tens of
thousands of containers so managing them
is made
simple using this container services and
even training of model using a large
data set in a complex and resource
intensive environment this aks helps us
to simplify that uh environment all
right as next thing in container domain
let's talk about container registry we
spoke about registry a little bit when
we spoke about docker images so
container registry is a single place
where we can store our images which are
docker images when we use when we use
containers it's it's docker images that
we use for our image purposes so these
container images are a central registry
that can be used to ease container
development by easing the storage and
management of container images so there
we can store all kind of images like
docker swamp or the images used in
docker swamp are in kubernetes
everything can be stored in container
registry in azure now anytime we store a
container image it provides us an option
for a geo replication what that means is
that we can efficiently manage a single
registry replicated across multiple
regions
now these jio replication it actually
enables us to manage global deployments
assuming we are having an environment
that requires a global deployment so it
helps us to manage global deployments as
one entity because we are geo
replicating we would be updating we
would be editing one image and that
image gets replicated throughout
the global
replication centers we would have set up
and so just one editing would have
actually edited
the global images and those global
images would have provisioned the global
application so one edit replication and
then provisioning of the applications
global wide and this replication also
helps us to
helps us network latency because you
know anytime an application needs to
deploy it does not have to rely on a
single source which which can be reached
only through high latency network
because we have global replications
around the world anytime the application
wants to check back it would check back
uh the application which is in a very
nearby location for the application
itself
global replication means that we are
managing it as a single entity that's
being replicated across the multiple
regions in the globe as next thing in
our learning let's talk about
azure databases now these azure
databases are
rational in fact they have many flavors
in them we're going to look at different
flavors or sql nosql cache type of
database that azure offers so we're
going to learn one at a time or are we
going to learn one by one so this azure
sql database is a relational database in
fact it's a relational database as a
service it's managed by azure we don't
get to do a lot of management in it so
it's a regional database as a service
based on microsoft
sql server database engine and this
database is a high performance database
it's very reliable and
it's very secure as well and this high
reliability high performance and for
this high security really don't have to
do anything it comes along with it and
it's managed by azure and there are two
things that i definitely need to mention
about azure sql database that is it's an
intelligent service number one it's
fully managed by azure and it also has
this one good thing which is it has
built-in intelligence that learns app
patterns and adapts to maximize
performance and reliability and data
protection of the application that's
something that's not found in
many of the other cloud providers that
i'm aware of so i thought i'll mention
it so it uses built-in intelligence to
learn about
the user's database patterns and helps
improve performance and protection and
migration or importing data is very easy
when it comes to azure sql database so
it can be readily or immediately used
for analytic reporting and
intelligent applications in azure as
next thing let's talk about azure
cosmodb now azure cosmodb is a database
service that is for no sql type and it's
it's created to provide low latency and
an application that scales dynamically
or that scales rapidly
now this azure cosmodb is an
a globally distributed service
and it's a multi-model
database this can be provisioned in a
click of a button that's all we got to
do if we need to provision and azure
cosmodb in the azure it helps with
scaling the database now we can
elastically and independently scale
throughput and storage across this
database and in any of the azure
geographic regions it provides a good
throughput it provides good latency it
provides good availability and
it provides or
azure promises a comprehensive sla that
no other database can offer that's the
best part about cosmodb so this cosmodb
was built with global distribution in
mind and it's built
with the horizontal scale in mind and
all this we can use by only paying for
what we have used and remember the
difference between azure cosmodb and the
sql database is that azure cosmodb
supports nosql whereas sql doesn't all
right few other things about azure
cosmodb is it allows users to use key
value graph a column family and document
data it also gives users a number of ap
options like sql javascript mongodb and
and few others that you might want to
check the document at the time of
reading and the best part here is that
all that we mentioned we get to use only
by paying for the amount of storage and
throughput that are required and the
storage and the throughput can be
elastically scaled based on the
requirement of that r all right let's
talk about
redis cash discussion about azure
database won't be complete without we
talking about redis cache now redis
cache is a secure data cache it's also
called it's also sometimes called as
messaging broker that provides high
throughput and low latency access to
data for the applications now redis
cache is based on an a popular open
source caching product which is redis
sometimes called as that is cache now
what's the use case it's typically used
to cache uh to improve the performance
and scalability of a system that rely
heavily on backend data stores now
performance when we use zs cache is
improved by temporarily copying the
frequently accessed data to a fast
storage located very close to the
application now with redis cache this
fast storage is located in memory with
redis cache instead of being loaded from
the actual disk in the database itself
now this redis cache can also be used as
an in-memory data structure store not
only that it can be used as an
distributed non-relational database and
a message broker so there are variety of
use cases for this redis cache and by
using redis cache the application
performance is improved
by taking advantage of the low latency
and the high throughput performance that
this redis cache engine provides so to
summarize this redis cache when we use
redis cache data is stored in the memory
instead of the disk to ensure that there
is high throughput and low latency when
the application needs to read the data
it provides various levels of scaling
without any downtime or interference now
this redis cache is actually backed by
reduce server and it supports
a string hashes linked list and various
other data structures now let's talk
about security and identity services now
identity management in specific is a
process of authenticating first and then
authorizing using security principles
and not only that identity management
involves controlling information about
those principal identities you might ask
now what's a principal identity now
identity or principal identity are
services applications users groups and a
lot more the speciality about this
identity management is that it not only
helps authenticate and authorize
principles in cloud it also helps
authenticate and authorize principles or
resources on premises especially when
you run an hybrid cloud environment so
all these services and features that
this identity management helps us to get
additional level of validation like
identity management can provide
multi-factor authentication it can
provide access policies based on
condition a permit or deny based on
condition it can also monitor suspicious
activity and not only that you can also
report it it can also help generate
alerts for potential security issues and
in a way to mitigate it can send us an
alert so we can get involved and prevent
and a security accident from happening
so let's talk more about identity
management so some of the services under
security and identity management are
azure security center now this azure
security center provides
security management and threat
protection across the workloads in both
cloud and in the hybrid environment it
helps control user access and
application control to stop any
malicious activity if present it helps
us to find and fix vulnerabilities
before they can be even exploited it
integrates very well with analytic
methods that helps us to identify or it
gives us the intelligent to identify or
detect attacks and prevent them before
it can actually happen
and it also works seamlessly with hybrid
environments so you don't have to have
one policy for on premises and one
policy for the cloud it's now a unified
service both for on-premises and the
cloud the next service and security and
identity would be key vault now a key
vault is a service or a feature that
helps safeguard the cryptographic keys
and any other secrets used by the cloud
applications and the services in other
words this azure keyword is a tool for
securely storing and accessing the
secrets of the environment i mean the
secret keys now a secret is anything
that you really want to have a very
tight control access like the
certificates like the passwords stuff
like that now if i tell you what keyword
actually
solves that would actually explain what
keyword is now key vault is used in
secrets management it's helped in
securely storing the tokens the
passwords the certificates it helps in
key management you know it really helps
in creating and controlling the
encryption keys that we would use to
encrypt data it helps in certificate
management talking about certification
management it helps us to easily
provision manage and deploy public and
private ssl tls certificates in azure
and lot more so in a nutshell this
keyword it provides users the ability to
provision new walls and keys in just a
matter of minutes all that in a single
command or all that in a couple of
button clicks it also helps users to
centrally manage their keys secrets and
policies
next in the list let's talk about azure
active directory now azure active
directory it helps us to create
intelligent driven access policies to
limit resource usage and manage user
identities but what does that mean now
this azure active directory is a cloud
based active directory and identity
management service now azure active
directory combines and it's actually a
combination of the core directory
services plus application access
management plus identity protection
and one good thing about this azure in
fact there are a lot of good things but
especially when you're running hybrid
environments you might wonder well how
this azure active directory is going to
behave now this azure active directory
is built to work on on-premises and
cloud environment as well not only that
it also works seamlessly with mobile
applications as well so in a nutshell
this azure active directory it acts as a
central point of identity and access
management for our cloud environment it
also provides good security solutions
that protect against unauthorized access
of our app and the data
now that we have discussed about
security and identity let's talk about
the management tools that azure has to
offer azure provides built-in management
and account governance tools that helps
administrators and
developers that helps them to keep the
resources secure and very compliant and
again it helps both in on-premises and
in the cloud environment and these
management tools help us to monitor the
infrastructure monitor the applications
it also helps in provisioning and
configuring resources it also helps in
updating apps it helps in analyzing
threats taking backup of the resources
build
disaster recoveries
it also helps in applying policies and
conditions to automate our environment
we use azure management tools and it's
also used in cost control methods so
this azure management plays a wide role
across the azure services
and in the management tools first comes
the azure advisor now this azure advisor
it acts as a guide to educate us about
azure best practices it throws
recommendations that we can select on
the basis of the category of service and
it also provides the impact
it can have or the impact that would
happen in our environment if we follow
the recommendations given and
recommendations are
first one is the recommendations are
kind of templatized and it throws the
templatized recommendations not only
that it also provides customized
recommendations on the basis of the
configuration on the basis of our usage
patents and these recommendations are
not hard it's not like something that it
recommends and then just leaves us
hanging there these recommendations
provided are very easy to follow very
easy to implement and see results you
can think of as your advisor as an a
very personalized cloud consultant that
helps you to follow best practices to
optimize our deployments it kind of
analyzes our resources our
configurations our usage and then it
recommends a solution for us that really
helps in improving the cost
effectiveness improving the performance
improving high availability and
improving security in our azure
environment so with this azure advisor
we can get a proactive
actionable and personalized best
practice recommendations now you don't
have to be an expert just follow the
azure advisor and your environment is
going to be good it also helps in
improve the performance security high
availability of our environment and also
it helps in bringing down the overall
azure spend and the best part is it's a
free service that analyzes our azure
usage and provides recommendations how
we can optimize our azure resource to
reduce cost and reduce cost at the same
time boost the performance helps in
strengthening the security and improve
the overall reliability of our
environment
next in the list would be network
watcher now this network watcher helps
users identify and gain insights in the
overall network performance and the
health of the overall environment now
these azure watchers provides enough
tools to monitor to diagnose to view the
metrics and to enable or disable logs
which means regenerate and collect the
logs for resources in the azure virtual
network so with network watcher you can
monitor and diagnose issues in
networking without even logging into the
virtual machines with just the logs
which are real time we can actually come
to a conclusion what could be wrong in a
certain resource in a vm or in a
database you know by just looking at the
logs and not only that it's used for
analytic or to gain some intelligence of
what's happening in our network we can
gain a lot of insight to the current
network traffic pattern using the
security group flow logs that this
network watcher offers it also helps in
investigating vpn connectivity issues
using detailed logs now you might or
might not know that you know vpn
troubleshooting requires both parties or
it involves two parties another person
the network administrator on this side
and the network administrator on the
other side and they will have to check
logs in their end and we'll have to
check logs and hour and stuff like that
but with the network watcher it kind of
takes it to the next level the logs
itself we could easily identify which
side is having the issue and suggest an
appropriate fix
and the next in the list would be
microsoft azure portal now this
microsoft azure portal it provides a
single unified console to perform
various number of activities like
building not only building managing and
monitoring the web applications that we
build now this portal can be used to
organize
our environment or the appearance of the
environment or the visual of the
environment based on our work style and
using azure portal users can control who
gets to manage or access the resources
all from the azure portal and this azure
portal gives a very good visibility on
the spends that happen on each resource
right and if we can customize it we can
also identify spends based on team
spends based on days spends based on
department stuff like that so it kind of
gives us a good visual of
where the money is spending or where is
the bill consumed within the azure
environment next in the list would be
azure resource manager now azure
resource manager enables us to manage
the usage of the application resources
now we use resource manager to deploy
monitor and manage solution resources as
a group as if it's one single entity now
the infrastructure of our application is
typically made of various components
which includes virtual machine storage
virtual network web app database servers
some other third-party services that we
might use in our environment and they
are by nature separate services but with
azure resource manager we don't see them
as different components or different
entities instead we see them as related
services in a group that supports an
application now we kind of get the
relation between them instead of you
know letting them spread azure resource
manager identifies the relation between
them and helps us to visually see them
all as one or single entity not only
that azure resource manager helps or it
ensures that the resources that we
provision are deployed at a constant
rate along with the other application
it also helps users to visually see
their resources and how they are
connected and that helps in managing the
resources lot better
resource group also is used to control
who can access the resources within the
users organization kind of gives you the
fine grained control over who gets to
access and who does not get access and
the last one in the management tools
would be automation and this automation
gives us the ability to automate
configure and install upgrades across
hybrid environments
it provides a cloud-based automation and
configuration service not only that this
can be applied for non-azure
environments as well which is
on-premises
so some of the automation we could do is
process automation update management
automation configuration features
automation stuff like that and this
azure automation provides complete
control during the deployment operation
and also
during the decommissioning of the
workloads and resources
with automation we can actually automate
a time consuming or
mundane or any task that's error prone
because of human errors those things can
be automated so irrespective of how many
times you run it it's gonna run the same
way and that really helps in reducing
the overall time and also the overhead
cost because a lot of the things are
automated which means it's human
error-free which means the application
is not going to break and keep running
for a longer time with automation we can
actually build a good inventory of
operating system resources and
configuration items all in one place
with ease and this really helps in
tracking the changes and investigating
the issue let's say something happened
because we have automation because it's
logging the configuration changes it's
easy to track easy to identify easy to
identify what has changed lately that
has broken the environment go back and
fix it or kind of roll it back that
solves the problem and that actually
summarizes the azure management tools or
management services now let's talk about
the networking tools or the networking
services available in azure there are
variety of services especially
networking services that azure offers
and i'm sure it's going to be an
interesting one let's begin our
discussion with content delivery network
now the content delivery network in
short cdn it allows us to perform secure
and a very reliable content delivery not
only that it also helps in accelerating
the delivery time or in other words
reducing the delivery time also called
as low times it also helps in saving
bandwidth and increases in
responsiveness to the application let's
expand on this the content delivery
network is actually a distributed
network of servers that can efficiently
deliver
web content to users now cdns
we're going to use the word cdn here
cdns store cached content on global edge
servers also called as
pops point of presence locations that
are very close to the end users so the
latency is minimized it's like taking a
copy of the data or taking a multiple
copy of the data and storing it in
different parts of the world and whoever
is requesting it the data gets delivered
to them from a server which is very
locally to them so this cdn offers
developers a global solution for
rapidly delivering high bandwidth
content to users by caching the content
in a strategically placed location which
is very near to them so these content
delivery networks it really helps in
handling that's one advantage you get
for content delivery network that's we
can handle spikes and heavy loads very
efficiently and we can also run analytic
against the locks that gets generated in
content delivery network which helps in
gaining good insight on the workflow and
what would be the future business need
for that application and this just like
a lot of other services this is on a pay
as you go type so you use the results
first and then you only pay for what you
have used
the next one in networking would be
express route now express route is
actually a circuit or a link that
provides an a direct private connection
to azure and because it's direct it
gives low latency link to azure it gives
good speed and reliability for the azure
data transfer it could be on premises to
azure
so it gives very good speed it gives
increased reliability and low latency
for that connection let's expand on this
a bit
now this express route is an service
that actually provides and private
connection between microsoft data center
and infrastructure in our premises or in
a different co-location facility that we
might have now these express routes do
not go over the public internet and
because they don't go over the public
internet they offer a high security
reliability and speed and low latency
compared to the connections which are in
the internet because it's fast because
it's reliable because it has low latency
it can be used as an extension of our
existing data center you know users are
not going to feel the difference whether
they are accessing services from an
on-premises or in the cloud environment
because latency is minimized as much as
possible users are really not going to
see the difference
and because it's a private line and not
a public internet line it can be used to
build hybrid applications without
compromising a privacy or the
performance now these virtual private
cloud these express routes can be used
for taking backups if assume a backup
going through the internet that would be
a nightmare if you use express route for
backups that's going to be fast and
imagine recovering a data through the
internet from the cloud through the
internet to the on premises in a time of
disaster that would be the worst
nightmare so these express routes can be
used not only to backup but also to
recover the data because it provides
good speed low latency recovering the
data is going to be a lot sooner the
next product or service we're going to
discuss in networking is azure dns
now azure dns allows us to host domain
name in azure and these domain names
come with an exceptional performance and
availability now azure dns is used to
set up and manage
dns zones and records for our domain
name in the cloud now this azure dns is
a service for dns just like the name
says and it provides name resolution by
using azure's infrastructure
and by using this domain we can actually
manage the dns ourselves through the
azure portal with the same credential
imagine having a dns provider which does
not even belong in rit imagine that
environment you know we would have a
separate portal to manage the dns
environment now those are gone
and now we can actually manage the dns
in the very same azure portal where we
use the rest of the other services and
this azure dns very much integrates with
other dns service providers it uses a
global network of name servers to
provide fast response to dns queries
and these domains are having additional
availability compared to the other
domain service providers availability
promises these are going to have more
availability than the rest because
most of the servers are maintained by a
microsoft and it helps resolve sooner it
helps re-syncing let's say a server
fails it kind of helps resyncing with
the rest of the servers so all the
microsoft's environment all the
microsoft's global network of name
servers kind of ensures that our domain
names are resolved properly not only
properly but also are available most of
the time
right next in the list in networking
services is virtual network i'm sure
this is going to be very interesting and
i'm sure you're going to like it so this
networking or virtual networking in
azure it actually allows us to set up
our own private cloud in the public
cloud it gives us an isolated and highly
secure environment for our application
let's expand on this so this azure
virtual network helps us to provision
azure virtual machines and it helps us
to securely communicate with other
on-premises and internet networks it
also helps in controlling the traffic
that flows through or flows in and out
of this virtual network to other virtual
networks and to the internet now this
azure a virtual network sometimes called
as v-net is actually a representation of
our own network in the cloud it's
actually a logical isolation of the
azure cloud dedicated to our
subscription all our environments are
provisioned in a v-net that is separate
from another customer's units that way
we have that logical separation there so
this virtual network can also be used to
provision uh vpns in the cloud so we can
connect the cloud and the on-premises
infrastructure and lot more especially
in a environment where we have hybrid
environment surely we will be using
virtual network because that's going to
require a vpn for secure data transfer
in and out of the cloud and in and out
of the on-premises environment
all right so it kind of gives us an
boundary for all the resources so all
the traffic between the azure resources
they kind of logically stay in between
or logically stay within the azure
virtual network and here we can design
the network it's given over to us you
know you can pick the ip you can pick
the routing you can pick the subnet and
a lot of freedom is given or i would say
a lot of control on how the network is
designed it's not like something that's
already cooked and we only get to use it
now we can actually build the network
from the scratch we can pick the ip
address that we like we can pick you
know which subnet needs to communicate
with the other subnets stuff like that
and like i said if you are using hybrid
environment you definitely would be
requiring a virtual network because it
helps connect the on-premises and the
cloud in a secure fashion using vpn the
last product we're going to discuss in
networking is a load balancer this load
balancer actually provides application a
good availability and a good network
performance so how does it work it
actually works by load balancing the
traffic to and from the virtual machine
and the cloud resources not only that it
also load balances between cloud and
across premises virtual networks with
azure load balancer we can actually
scale our application and create high
availability for our services which
means our application will be available
most of the time if any of the server
goes dead the server does not get
traffic what happens if the server gets
traffic user is going to experience
downtime what happens if the server does
not get traffic user won't experience
any downtime the connection is shifted
to an healthy server so the user
experiences uptime all the time so this
load balancer supports inbound and
outbound scenarios and it provides low
latency it gives high throughput of the
data transfer and we can actually scale
up the flow of the tcp and udp
connections from hundreds to thousands
to even millions because we have a load
balancer now in between the user and the
application so how does it operate this
load balancer actually receives the
traffic and it load balances the traffic
to the back end pool of instances
connected to it according to the rule
and the health probe that we set that's
how it maintains high availability so
what does load balancer help it helps in
creation of high available scalable
application in the cloud in minutes it
can be used to automatically scale the
environment with the increasing
application traffic and one feature of
load balancer is to check the health of
the users application instance and it
removes or it stops sending the request
to the unhealthy instance and kind of
shifts that connection to the healthy
instance that way a user or a connection
does not get stuck with an instance
that's not healthy that's all that you
need to know about the networking
services now let's talk about the
storage services or the storage domain
in azure now azure storage in general is
a microsoft manage service providing
cloud storage which basically is highly
available secure durable scalable and
redundant because it's all managed by
azure we don't get to manage a lot of it
and these azure storages are a group of
storage services they cater different
needs and the storage products include
azure blobs which is actually an object
storage it includes
azure data lake it includes azure files
as you see it in it includes azure
queues it includes azure tables and lot
more but let's start our discussion with
azure store simple azure store simple is
an hybrid cloud storage solution that
actually lowers the cost of storage to
nearly 60 percent of how much you'd be
actually spending without using it so
azure simple storage or store simple is
an integrated storage solution that
manages the storage task between
on-premises and the cloud storage what i
really like about azure is that it's
built around a hybrid environment in
mind there are a lot of other cloud
providers that are there where running
and hybrid environment is a big
challenge you know it has some
compatibility you won't be able to find
an hybrid or a on-premises and cloud
solution for your need stuff like that
but with azure especially when it comes
to storage a lot of the things that
we're going to see it clearly is
designed with hybrid environment in mind
all right so let's come back and talk
about store simple so store simple is an
very efficient cost effective and a very
easily manageable san storage area
networking solution in the cloud i
thought i'll throw in this information
the reason why it got store simple is
really because it uses store simple 8000
series devices which are used in azure
data center and this stores simple or
simple storage it comes along with
storage steering to manage the stored
data across the various storage media so
the current the very current data is
actually stored in on-premises on
solid-state drives and data that is used
less frequently is stored in hdds or
hard disk drives and the data that
requires archived or that needs to be
archived very old data let's say less
frequently used data candidate for
archive they are actually pushed to the
cloud so you see how this storage
sharing automatically happens in store
simple and one another cool feature of
store simple is that it enables us to
create an on-demand and scheduled
backups of data and then store the data
locally or in the cloud and these
backups are actually taken in the form
of incremental snapshot which means that
they can be created and restored quickly
it's not a complete backup it's an
incremental backup and these cloud
snapshots they can be critically
important when there is a disaster and
when there is a disaster recovery
scenario because these snapshots can be
called in and they can be put on storage
systems and then they become the actual
data so recovering is faster if you have
proper scheduled backups or if you have
frequent backups and this storage simple
it really helps in easing our backup
mechanism which means it kind of eases
our disaster recovery steps or
procedures as well so this store simple
it can be used to automate data
management data migration data movement
data turing across the enterprise both
in cloud and on-premises it actually
improves the compliance and accelerates
the disaster recovery for our
environment and if there is one thing
that's increasing every new day in our
environment that would be storage and
this store simple addresses that need
and we really don't have to pre-plan or
think in deep or having a proper storage
because now we have a simple storage
available in the cloud and moreover it's
on a pay-as-you-go type so not much
pre-planning on storage is needed yes
there will be a need but not as much as
i would without the cloud or without the
simple storage and the next service
under storage that we would like to
discuss is the data lake store this data
lake store or storage it's a cost
effective solution for big data
analytics in specific so let's expand
this so this data lake storage is an
enterprise-wide repository for big data
analytic workload now that's the major
service that's dependent on this data
lake store and this data lake enables us
to capture data of any size of any type
and of any injection speed and it kind
of collects them in one single space or
in one single place for operational
efficiency i mean operational efficiency
and for analytic purpose hadoop in azure
is very dependent on this data lake
storage and this
data like store is designed with
performance for analytics in mind so
anytime you think of or anytime you're
using analytic in the cloud or anytime
you're using hadoop in the cloud in
azure we are definitely using or we will
be to the most part or the normal
procedure or the right storage to pick
would be data lake store in azure it's
designed with security in mind so
anytime we use azure storage we can be
rest assured that we are using storage
from within a data center which has or
which was built with security in mind so
this data store also uses azure blob
storage behind the scenes for global
scale durability and for performance
let's talk about blob storage now blob
storage provides large amount of storage
and scalability now this blob storage is
the object storage solution for azure
cloud let's expand a bit on blob storage
azure blob storage is microsoft offering
for object storage now this blob storage
is optimized for storing massive amount
of unstructured data which could be text
or binary data it's designed and it's
optimized for rapid reads if i explain
to you on what scenarios we would be
using blob storage that might help you
get a good understanding of what blob
storage is so it's help or its design as
of now it's being used in many idea
environments to serve images or
documents directly to the browser it
helps in storing files for distributed
access a lot of features can fetch data
from azure blob storage and it currently
helping users stream video and audio
it's currently being used for writing
log files it's currently being used to
store data as backup and restore at a
later point in times of disaster
recovery it also is used as an archiving
storage in a lot of cloud id
environments it's widely used in storing
analytic data not only storing but also
running analytic query against the data
stored in it so that's a wide use case
for blob storage not only that in
addition to all that we mentioned it
also supports versioning so anytime
somebody updates and data a new version
gets created which means at any point i
can roll back as in when needed and it
provides a lot of flexibility on
optimizing the user's storage need it
also supports tiering of the data so
based on need when i actually explore i
would find a lot of options i can pick
from that uh you know suits to my unique
storage environment or unique storage
need and like i said it stores
unstructured data and this unstructured
data is available for customers through
rest based object storage environment
the next product and storage service
would be a queue storage now queue
storage provides durable cues for large
volume cloud services it's a very simple
and a cost effective durable messaging
queue for large workloads let's expand
this queue storage for a moment now this
queue storage is a service for storing
large amount of messages that can be
accessed from anywhere in the world
through http and https calls a single
queue or a single cube message can be up
to like 24 kb in size and a single queue
can contain millions of such 24 kb in
size messages and how much can it hold
it can hold up to the total capacity of
the storage account itself so that's
kind of easy to translate how much would
it hold and this azure queue storage it
provides an messaging solution between
applications and components in the cloud
what does it help it helps in designing
an application for scale it helps in
decoupling the application so you know
it's not very dependent or sometimes
it's not at all dependent on the other
application because now we have a queue
in between which kind of translates or
which kind of connects or which kind of
decouples both the environment now we
have a queue in between both the
environment can scale up or scale down
independently the next in the storage
service would be file storage let's talk
about file storage now these azure files
provide secure simple and managed cloud
file shares now with file share in the
cloud it actually extends the user
servers on premises performance and
capacity and lot of familiar tools for
the cloud file share management can be
used along with the file storage that
we're talking about so let's expand a
bit on file storage now this azure files
or azure file storage offers a fully
managed file shares in the cloud that
can be accessed via the
smb protocol server message block
protocol now this azure file shares can
be mounted concurrently by cloud or in
on-premises deployments a lot of
operating systems are compatible with it
windows are compatible linux is
compatible mac os is compatible in
addition to all this being able to run
on on-premises and on the cloud or being
able to access from on-premises and on
the cloud it can also offer cash for
caching the data and keeping it locally
so it's immediately available when
needed so that's some additional feature
i would say that some advanced feature
that it offers compared to the other
file shares available in the market
let's talk about table storage let's
talk about table storage now table
storage is a no sql key value pair
storage for quick deployments with the
large semi-structured data sets the
difference between one important thing
to note with table storage is that it
has a flexible data schema and also it's
highly available let's expand a bit on
table storage so anytime you want to
pick a schema less a nosql type table
storage is the one we'll end up picking
it provides an key pair attribute
storage with a schema-less design this
table storage is very fast and very cost
effective for many of the applications
and for the same amount of
data it's a lot cheaper when you compare
it with the traditional sql data or data
storage so some of the things that we
can store in the table storage are of
course they're going to be flexible data
sheets such as user data for web
application address books device
information and other types of metadata
for our service requirements and it can
have any number of tables up to the
capacity limit of the storage account
now this is not possible with sql this
is only possible with nosql especially
with table storage in azure explanation
of storage really concluded the length
and breadth of the explanation this ceo
was giving his id personal but this id
personal is not done with it yet he
still has a question even after this
lengthy discussion and his question was
well there are a lot of other cloud
providers available what made you
specifically choose azure i mean from
the kind of question that he asked we
can say that he is very curious and he
definitely had asked and very thoughtful
question so his ceo went on and started
to explain about the uh other
capabilities of azure or how it
kind of outruns the rest of the cloud
providers so he started or he again
started his discussion but from a
different angle now so he started to
explain what are the capabilities or how
azure is better than the competitors so
he started with explaining the platform
as a service capabilities and i'm going
to tell you what the ceo told his id
person so this platform as a service or
in platform as a service the
infrastructure management is completely
taken care by
microsoft allowing users to focus
completely on the innovation no more
infrastructure management
responsibilities go and focus on
innovation that's that's a fancy way of
saying it when we buy platform as a
service that's what we get we can
contribute our time on innovation and
not just maintaining the infrastructure
and azure especially is uh dotnet
friendly azure supports the.net
programming language and it has or it is
built or designed or it is optimized to
work with old and the new applications
deployed using dotnet programming
framework so if your application is
a.net most of the time you would end up
picking azure i mean if you try to
compare most of the time you would end
up picking azure as your cloud service
provider and the security offerings that
azure offers is it's designed based on
the security development uh lifecycle
which is an industry leading assurance
process when we buy services from azure
it assures that the environment is
designed based on security development
life cycle and like i mentioned many
times in the past and i would like to
mention it again azure has well thought
about the hybrid environments which a
lot of other cloud providers have failed
so it's very easy to set up and hybrid
environment to migrate the data or not
to migrate the data and still run a
hybrid environment they work seamlessly
with
azure because azure provides seamless
connection across on-premises data
centers and the public cloud it also has
a very gentle
learning curve if you look at the
documentation it's picture rich and the
documentations are neat and clear would
really it would encourage you to learn
more it would encourage you to think and
imagine and try easily get a grasp of
how services work so it has a very
gentle learning curve azure allows the
utilization of technologies that several
businesses have used for years so there
is a big history behind it it has a very
gentle learning curve the certifications
the documentations the stage by stage
certification levels it's all very
gentle learning curve which is generally
missing in other cloud service providers
now this would really impress the ctos
or or people working in finance and
budgeting if an organization is already
using microsoft software they can
definitely go and avail or be bold and
ask for a discount that can reduce the
overall azure spending in other words
overall a pricing of the azure so that's
what helped or they are the information
that helped the ceo pick azure as his
cloud service provider and then the ceo
goes on and talks about the different
companies that are currently using azure
and they are definitely using azure for
a reason like pixar boeing samsung
easyjet xerox bmw 3m they are major
multinational multi-billion companies
they rely
run operate their id in azure and this
ceo has a thought that his id person is
still not very convinced unless and
until he shows him a visual of how easy
things are in azure so he goes on and
explains about a practical application
of azure which is what exactly i'm going
to show you as well all right a quick
project on building an azure app using
or building a dotnet application in
azure web app and making it connect to
an sql database will solidify all the
knowledge that we have gained so far so
this is what we're gonna do i have an
azure account open as you see logged in
and everything is fresh here let me go
to resource group there's nothing in
there it's it's kind of fresh all right
i'm logged in and this is what we're
going to do so we're going to create an
application like this which is nothing
but an to-do application
to do list application
which is going to run from the web app
get information from us and save it in
the database that's connected to it so
you can already see it's a two-tiered
application web and db all right so let
me go back to my azure account the first
thing is to create an resource group
let's give it an a meaningful name let's
call it azure simply learn alright and
it's going to be a free trial and the
location
pick one that's nearest to you or you
know wherever you want to launch your
application now for this use case i'm
going to pick central us and create
it's going to take a while to get
created there you go it's created it's
called azure simply learn now what do we
need we need an web app and and a
separate sql database let's first get
our web app running so go to app
services and then click on add
it's not the web app plus sql that we
want we want web app alone for this
example so let's create and web app
give it a quick name let's call it uh
azure
simply learn
the subscription is free trial and i'm
gonna use my existing resource group a
resource group that we created some time
back it's gonna run out of windows and
we're gonna publish the code all set we
can create it all right while this is
running
let me create my database
right sql database
create a database
give it a name let's call it azure
simply learn db
put it in our existing resource group
that we created it's going to be a blank
database all right and it's going to
require some
settings like
the name of the server
and the admin login the password that
goes along and in which location this is
going to be created the server name is
going to be azure simply learn db that's
the server name and the admin login can
be
what can be the admin login name let's
see
so let's call it simply learn that's my
admin login name
and let me pick a password
click on create so what have we done so
far we have created an web app and we
have created and
a database in
the resource group that we have created
so if i go to resource group it's going
to take some time before things show up
so if i go to my resource group i only
have one resource group as of now azure
simply learn and there i have a bunch of
resources
being created and not still being
created right in the meantime
i have my application right here that's
running out of
or that's in visual studio as of now
right so once
the infrastructure is set and ready in
the azure console we're going to go back
to visual studio feed these inputs in
the visual studio so the code knows what
the database is the the credentials to
log into the database and stuff like
that so we're going to feed those
information in visual studio by that
we're actually feeding it into the
application and then we're going to run
it from there
deploying this application takes quite a
while
we really got to be patient right now we
have all the resources that we need for
the application to run here's my
database and here is my app service
there's one more thing we need to do
that is
create and firewall exception rule so
one more thing needed is to create and
firewall exception uh rule right so the
application is gonna run from my local
desktop and it's going to connect to the
database right so let's add an exception
rule by simply adding the client id it's
going to pick my ip the ipf laptop i'm
using as of now and it's going to create
an exception to access the
database so that's done now we can go
back to our visual studio i already have
a couple of
apps running or a couple of
configurations pushed from
a visual studio i'm going to clean that
up if you're doing it for the first time
you may not need to do this
all right so let's start from the
[Music]
this is very similar to
how you would be doing
uh in your environment all right so
we're gonna
select an existing azure app service now
before that i have logged in as you can
see i have logged in
with my credentials so it's going to
pull few things automatically from my
azure account so
in this case i'm going to use an
existing azure app so select existing
and then click on publish
all right if you recall these are the
very
same resources that we created a while
back
all right we have clicked on save and
it's
running kind of validating the code
and it's going to come up with an
url now initially the url is
not going to work because we haven't
mapped the application to the database
so that would be the next thing
all right so the app has been
published and it's running from my
web app as of now
it's going to throw an error
like you see
it's throwing an error that's because we
haven't mapped
the app and the db together so let's do
that
all right let's do that so let's go to
server explorer
this is where
we're going to see our
databases that we have created now let's
quickly verify that
go back to
the resource group
all right appropriate resource group
which is right here
and here i have my
database azure
simply learn
database
all right it has some issues connecting
to my database give me a quick moment
let's fix it
all right so
we'll have to map
the database into this application
all right so let's go to the solution
explorer click on
publish
and a page like this gets shown and from
here we can go to configure
here is our web app all right with all
its credentials let's validate the
connection
number one
all right and then click on next
this is my db connection string right
which the app is going to use to connect
to my db
now if you recall rdb was a
azure simply learn db and that's not
being shown here
so let's fix that
right so let's fix that
click on configure and here
uh let's put our db servers uh url now
before that let's change this to sql
server
all right and then in here
put the
db's url so go back to azure
here is my
db or
server's name
put that here
right
the user name to connect to the server
that's right here
put that in
and the password
to connect to the server let's put that
in
all right it's trying to connect
to our azure
portal or the azure infrastructure and
here is my
database if you recall it's azure
sldb that's the name of the database
let's test the connection
connection is good click on ok
so now it's showing up correctly azure
simply learn db that's the name of the
database
that'll be created
now it's configured
all right let's modify the data
connections
right let's map it to the appropriate
database again
all right so our name of the database is
azure simply learn db
and then
it's going to be
sql
server that's the data source
the
username is simply learn
and the password is
what
we have given in the beginning
all right let's validate
the connection it's good click ok
now we're all set
and ready to publish
our application
again now the application knows how to
connect
to the database we have educated it with
the
the correct connection strings the dna's
name
the username and the password for the
application to connect to the database
so visual studio is building this
project
and once it is up and running will be
prompted with an url
to connect and
anytime
we put or we give inputs to the url
that's going to
receive the input and save it in the
database
all right so here is my to-do list app
and i can start
creating to-do list for
myself all right so i have items already
listed
i can create an entry and these entries
get stored in
the
in the database i can create another
entry
you know take the doc for a walk that's
gonna get stored i can create another
entry uh book tickets for
a scientific
exhibition
and that's going to receive and put that
in the database and that concludes our
session so through this session we saw
how i can use azure services to create
web app and
connect that to the db instance and how
those two services which are
decoupled by default which are separate
by default how i can you know use the
connection strings to make connection
between the app server and the database
and be able to create and working app
so what is google cloud platform it has
a set of cloud computing services
provided by google that runs on the same
infrastructure that google uses
to and for its end user products like
youtube gmail and so on
let's learn about benefits of google
cloud platform
such as high productivity
working from anywhere
quick collaboration high security
fewer data stored on vulnerable devices
reliable resources which can be used
across organization across geographical
regions across countries
very flexible which allows organizations
to scale up and down as
the demand rises or as the demand
declines
and cost effective solutions for various
use cases these are some of the benefits
and
if we look into different services which
google cloud platform offers
we could look into detailed benefits
which each service offers in a different
use case which basically helps
organizations
working in different domains handling
different kind of small mid or larger
businesses and with different business
goals
when we talk about google cloud platform
services here is a list of
services or i could say high level
domains or categories of services so you
have compute related services you have
storage and database
you have networking
big data
developer tools identity and security
management
internet of things cloud ai management
tools and also data transfer solutions
when we talk about google's
infrastructure
google has one of the most powerful
infrastructure in the world the
infrastructure is available in two
levels the physical and the abstract
layers you have physical infrastructure
and then you have the abstract
infrastructure
physical infrastructure consists of data
centers
extensive development of high efficiency
back-end data centers
you have a very strong backbone network
which is used by google itself and also
offered
as services to customers via gcp
platform services so
you have global meshed redundant
backbone network
points of presence when we talk about
google it has 110 plus edge points of
presence in more than 200 countries and
when we talk about edge caching
edge caching platform at periphery of
their network
so this is
what defines the physical infrastructure
of google now there is much more to it
rather than just these four points when
we talk about abstract infrastructure
that is divided in global
regions and zones
when we talk about
zone a zone is roughly equivalent to a
data center
and a single point of failure so you
could have your compute engine
which is within a zone or you could say
compute engine is a zonal resource
you have regions which are geographical
areas which contain multiple zones
so you could have a region for u.s
central or
europe central europe west and so on and
within a region you would have one or
multiple zones and zones basically would
allow high availability of resources
so you have cloud load balancer is an
example which is regional resource
then you have global resources and they
are available and shared across the
planet
so you have various global resources
such as network
which could be even your ip addresses
and so on
now let's do a quick comparison of aws
with azure wes
gcp and let's look at what each cloud
provider offers
later we will also look into different
services
in detail when it comes to google cloud
platform
what each service does
what you can benefit from which service
should you use in what case we will
learn about those in later slides
if i compare
your different cloud providers
when we talk about amazon
and its cloud offerings that is amazon
web services or aws as we will know it
amazon web services has 69 availability
zones within 22 geographical locations
and soon it will have 12 more in future
so this number keeps growing based on
the spread of the services which a
particular cloud provider offers
here we are talking about availability
zone specific information when we talk
about microsoft's azure it has 54
regions worldwide and is available in
140 countries across the globe
when we talk about google cloud gold
cloud platform is available in 200 plus
countries across the globe
when we talk about virtual servers
amazon's ec2 that is elastic compute
cloud it is a web service which
basically helps to resize your compute
capacity where you can run your
application programs on a virtual
machine so using ec2 service you could
launch virtual instances that could have
any distribution of linux
windows you could have different
specifications when it comes to ram or
cpu cores or disk you could also decide
on
what kind of storage a particular
instance should use
whether the storage should be local to
the instance or whether that should be a
elastic file system or even an object
storage
when it comes to azure or microsoft's
offering as your virtual machine
that is infrastructure as a service
gives a user the ability to deploy and
manage a virtual environment inside a
virtual network on the cloud
and this virtual network on the cloud
would be managed by cloud provider
google cloud or
the offerings from google cloud platform
that is gcp vm instances enables users
to build deploy and manage virtual
machines in order to run different kind
of workloads on the cloud now when we
talk about compute engine here it would
be good to discuss a little bit more
about compute engine and what are the
different options which
google cloud offers so when you talk
about your compute engine
you have scalable high performance
virtual machines
compute engine delivers configurable
virtual machines which run in google's
data center with access to high
performance networking infrastructure
and block storage and you could select
vms for your needs that could be general
purpose or workload optimized and when
we talk about workload optimized you
have predefined machines or you have
custom machine sizes you can integrate
compute with other google cloud services
such as ai or ml and go for your data
analytics
you have when we talk about your gcp vm
instances just to expand on that you
have general purpose
instances which we call as n2
which provide a balance between price
and performance and they are well suited
for most workloads including line of
business applications web servers and
databases
google cloud also offers compute
optimized instances which we call as c2
instances which offer consistent
high-end virtual cpu performance which
are good for aaa gaming eda
hpc and other applications
now when we talk about compute optimize
your general purpose how would we leave
memory optimized instances those are m2
machines which google offers so these
offer highest amount of memory these vms
are well suited for in-memory databases
such as sap hana real-time analytics and
in-memory caches
so if i would summarize this when we
talk about
different instances aws
also offers different kind of instances
which are memory or compute
or
disk optimized you have general purpose
and each
category of machines has a different
pricing model you can always go to an
aws website look for the pricing models
and that will give you an idea of
on-demand instances or dedicated
instances reserved instances and so on
similarly if you talk about google cloud
google cloud also has instances with
various options
which become the key features of why
customers would choose google cloud
platform such as live migration for vms
so compute engine
within your gcp can live migrate between
host systems and when i say live migrate
it basically means without rebooting
which keeps your application running
even when the underlying host systems
require maintenance you also have
preemptable
virtual machines wherein you can run bad
jobs and fault tolerant workloads on
pre-emptible vms to reduce your virtual
cpu and memory cost by up to 80 percent
while getting the same performance so
these are your preemptive or preemptable
virtual machines the only the minute is
these can give you a really cost
efficient
resource usage however can be taken off
the shelf anytime and that's why we call
them preemptable virtual machines you
also have sole tenant nodes which are
physical compute engine servers
dedicated explicitly or exclusively for
users use case
and
when we talk about sole tenant nodes
these are usually good when you are
dealing with or when you're working with
your applications which we call as bring
your own license applications so sole
tenant nodes give you access to same
machine types and virtual machine config
options as regular compute instances
so there are different options which
google cloud offers when it comes to
these instances which we are talking
about and it takes care of different use
cases in comparison to other
cloud providers which are also offering
these services such as you can have
predefined machine types you can have
custom machine types preemptable vms as
i said
live migration of vms
you can use persistent disks which could
give you durable high performance block
storage you have local ssds you also
have gpu accelerators which can be added
to accelerate computational
intensive workloads such as machine
learning simulation medical analysis and
so on and you have features such as
global load balancing which
makes google cloud a unique choice
when we talk about platform as a service
amazon has
platform as a service offering which we
call as elastic bean stock
among one of its services it's an
orchestration service for deploying
applications and helping in maintaining
these applications
azure cloud service
provides a platform to write the user
application code without worrying about
the hardware resources
google app engine is a service used by
developers for building and hosting
applications on google's data centers
when we talk about server-less computing
so amazon's aws lambda is a serverless
compute service it is used to execute
backend code and scales automatically
when required when we talk about azure
you have something called as functions
which allow users to build applications
using server-less symbol functions with
a programming language of their choice
when we talk about google cloud
gcp has cloud functions which is easiest
way to run your code in the cloud and it
is highly available and fault tolerant
so in these days when we are talking
about microservices architecture which
organizations are preferring when we are
talking about organizations which can
scale which can dynamically change their
underlying architecture
organizations would be interested in
server less computing where they do not
have to have a infrastructure setup
a planned in advance before going for
their use case and this is where
monolithic applications
are really not a preferred choice
a lot of organizations are decomposing
their applications into microservices
based on
business capability or decomposing based
on subdomains we can learn about
microservices architecture later but
just to know that serverless computing
which basically helps any organization
if for example if you have a web
application that receives
non-linear traffic and you cannot keep
an eye on your server always
it would be good to have someone to auto
scale your application serverless is
basically a computing model where cloud
service provider is responsible for
managing the piece of code without the
developer having to bother about
infrastructure setup
management maintenance and so on
now when we talk about applications
being serverless or benefiting from
serverless computing
one of the key things would be zero
administration so deploying application
without any provisioning and management
auto scaling capability that is let the
service provider worry about
scaling the application up and down
you have paper use model which any
customer would want to benefit from
that is pay only for the resources that
you have used or that you are continuing
to use
right
shorten the time between
idea implementation and employment and
this is something which any organization
would want that
you would want
a faster
bring to the market solution timeline in
comparison to getting entangled with
deployment management and maintenance of
your underlying infrastructure when your
applications are facing a high demand
so when we talk about serverless
it is a function as a service
because each part of your application is
divided as functions and can be hosted
over multiple service providers
you have serverless apps which are
usually divided as separate units or
functions based on functionalities or
domains and so on so serverless
computing is getting quite popularity
these days
in comparison to the traditional
three-tier architecture
where you had a presentation layer you
had an application layer you have a
database layer now that kind of
infrastructure is not really preferred
in today's modern times when
organizations are working on different
kind of newer
applications when we talk about object
storage amazon has simple storage
service that is s3 it provides object
storage which is built for storing and
recovering information or data from
anywhere over the internet azure comes
up with blob storage that is binary
large objects storage offers large
amount of storage and scalability it
stores the object in the tiers and
depending on how often the data is being
accessed now same thing applies to even
s3
which is from amazon so s3 also has
different kind of storage classes which
can be selected when a user or
organization intends to use a storage
service and when i speak about storage
classes it basically means having a
frequent access storage or a infrequent
access storage or what we call as
just an archival solution
google cloud has cloud storage and it
provides unified object storage for live
or archive data the service is used to
store and access data on gcp
infrastructure
when it comes to advantages
amazon web services
has enterprise friendly services easy
access to resources
increase in speed and agility and that
too on demand and takes care of your
security and reliability of resources
which are offered
when it comes to azure it has better
development operations strong security
profile provides a lot of cost effective
solutions and
operation execution friendly
when we talk about google cloud one of
the key features here is better pricing
than competitors
live migration of virtual machines which
really interests a lot of organizations
would want to
modernize their infrastructure without
having any kind of disruption in their
existing services
improved performance redundant backups
and so on
when it comes to disadvantages in aws
you have limitations when it comes to
ec2 service well there are different
options in the kind of machines which
you can choose which you can work on
you have a technical support fee
which is incurred network connectivity
and then also downtime which might be in
case when you're migrating azure it has
different code base for cloud and
premise
platform as a service ecosystem is not
really as efficient as infrastructure as
a service
poor management of gui and tools
integrated backup
when we talk about google cloud support
fee is quite hefty it depends on what
kind of solution or support you would or
organization would be interested in it
has a complex pricing schema
although it has different use cases for
which
any user or any organization can benefit
from
downloading data from google cloud
services is an expensive option storage
might not be however uploading data or
downloading data would be an expensive
option
when we talk about domino's pizza use
case now while we were discussing about
these features i would really want to
spend more time in
discussing each of these features or
services in detail such as you have
compute engine
you have storage
you have big table you have data proc
and so on so there are huge list of
services now before we get into your
domino's pizza use case let me show you
this page on google cloud where you can
look at different services so if you go
to
cloud.google.com and if you look at
get started option under dock so here
you can find build solutions look at
different use cases learn from basics
of what is your google cloud what are
cloud basics
then you can look at different cloud
products so here you have products in
different categories such as ai and
machine learning api management compute
containers data analytics databases
developer tools and so on and you can
always click on
any one of these to look into different
solutions which are being offered what
are the different use cases what are the
best practices when it comes to
migrating vms to compute engine or
operating containers or building
containers and so on you can always look
at featured products and that gives you
a quick snapshot of what are the
different products such as you have
compute engine you have cloud run
bigquery which is a data warehouse you
have cloud sql
which is a managed mysql or postgres you
have cloud storage to basically push in
any kind of data there you have security
key enforcement ai and machine learning
and so on so you have different feature
products now if you scroll down
to the lower end of this page
you can again look at
different solutions and that would be
really interesting to read and learn
from so you have infrastructure
modernization
you have application modernization you
have data management and so on so if i
look at
infrastructure modernization
you could basically look at the
solutions which google cloud offers
and what it does when it comes to
having your
infrastructure modernized or benefiting
by
integrating with cloud and having
immediate benefits of infrastructure
modernization you can look at different
use cases what they are doing
how google cloud really helps when it
comes to
migrating the workloads to a cloud
and how your different cloud solutions
such as vm migration you have sap on
google cloud vmware as a service and so
on and you could learn from these
different solutions which are offered
you can also look at application
modernization so not only infrastructure
modernization but organizations would
also be interested in re-looking at
their applications re-looking at how
these applications
could be moved from monolithic to
microservices architecture or how
applications can benefit from
modernization
and cloud computing offerings so you
have again different use cases here
which talks about different ways in
which google cloud can help how you can
modernize your applications how you can
use different solutions which google
cloud is offering now when you talk
about cloud computing services you can
always go into
cloud.google.com
if you have created a free account then
you can just login and every user by
default gets a 300 free credit
so when they can try out different
products where they can use different
services so here if i click on console
where i'm already logged in with my
gmail account or my google cloud account
wherein i have
300 free credit out of which some is
being used you have a google cloud
console
and here from the hamburger menu you can
click and you can look at different
services within different domains so you
have compute domain which has different
services such as app you have compute
engine and that basically allows you to
use your vm instances which we were
talking about previous slides different
instance groups create your templates
use sole tenant nodes
create snapshots or backup of your data
use different zones you can go for
kubernetes which is containerized based
engine you have cloud functions
you have cloud run
and then you have storage related
different options such as big table you
have data store firestore file store
storage and so on and for each of these
services you can read about from the
google's documentation or anyways i will
be explaining that later
you can also look at networking related
operation related and other tools which
are offered by google cloud so these are
huge list of services which google cloud
platform offers in different ways for
different use cases
now let's look at this domino's pizza
use case and see what it helps us learn
about so you can always access this page
by going to this link which talks about
customers and then which shows you
different use cases
so domino's increasing monthly revenue
by six percent with google analytics
premium google tag manager and google
bigquery
so this is basically when domino's
started using gcp and what was the
result of that
now let's look further into this
so we all know
that domino is most popular pizza
delivery
chain operating across the globe but how
was that possible let's take a look so
the challenges were they wanted to
integrate marketing measurement across
various devices
connecting crm and digital data to
create a clear view of customer behavior
to make cross-channel marketing
performance analysis easy and efficient
now for these challenges which dominos
was facing the solution was using google
analytics premium
google tag manager and bigquery which
were used to integrate digital data
sources and crm data
reporting was made easier and more
efficient by implementing google
analytics premium because it had the
ability to access a single google
analytics account
to evaluate web and app performance
by using the new google tag manager
implementation dominus were able to act
fast
they were able to connect crm data with
digital analytics which basically
provided domino with greater visibility
on customer behavior what was the result
there was an immediate six percent
increase in monthly revenue
eighty percent of costs and ad serving
and operations were saved
increases
agility with streamline tag management
they obtained easy access to powerful
reporting and customized dashboards now
that was just one simple use case before
we go on to hands-on we can also talk a
little bit
back about these services which google
cloud offers
as we discussed and some of these
services which can really make you think
why not google cloud platform so when we
talk about your different cloud platform
services
let's learn about some of these services
in brief in what each service is what it
does and how it can help us in handling
our use cases or working with different
products so let's learn briefly about
different services which google cloud
platform offers now one of the domains
is compute and then let's look at the
compute services which gcp offers now
here i can log into the console and this
hamburger menu on the top left corner i
can click on this one and go into the
compute engine section so this is the
compute domain which has app engine
kubernetes engine cloud functions and
cloud run so these are your different
services which are offered within the
compute domain and here we can get into
compute engine by clicking on this one
and then basically going to vm instances
so before we see how we can use this
compute engine let's understand about
some of the features of compute engine
which basically offers scalable high
performance virtual machines which are
configurable and which runs in google's
data center with access to high
performance networking infrastructure
and block storage so from here you can
select vm for your needs for your
general purpose or workload optimized
predefined or custom machines now here
you can integrate compute with other
google cloud services such as ai ml and
other data analytics services you have
different machines which are offered
here such as general purpose
which provide a balance between price
and performance which are well suited
for most workloads including line of
business applications web services and
databases you also have compute
optimized machines which offer
consistent high-end virtual cpu core
performance and which are mainly good
for gaming eda high process computing
and other such applications apart from
general purpose compute optimized you
also have memory optimized machines
which offer highest amount of memory and
these vms are basically well suited for
in-memory databases such as sap hana
real-time analytics and in-memory cache
now we can see these options here you
can click on vm instances while you're
logged in into your google cloud console
here you can even create an instance
template which can be used to spin up
instances for example if i click on new
vm instance from a template there are
some templates which i have already
created for my usage now here i can
basically use one of these templates or
what i can do is i can go back i can go
into instance templates and this
basically allows me to create a template
so you can click on create instance
template which basically allows you to
create templates which can be used to
spin up different instances we can give
a name to the template for example we
can say template
instance now here i can choose machine
configurations and this is where you
have different options so you have
general purpose as i mentioned which
provide a balance between price and
performance you have memory optimized
which are large memory machine types for
memory intensive workloads you also have
compute optimized which basically give
you high performance machine types for
compute intensive workloads so you can
choose any machine configuration which
is available here based on your
requirements now if you click on general
purpose that has different options here
so you look into the series where you
have n1 series you have e2 which are cpu
platform selection based on availability
you have n2 and n2d so let's just have
n1 selected now you also have here which
talks about machine types and here we
can choose the configuration which we
are interested in depending on the
applications which will run within the
machines we can choose a machine so by
default it shows one virtual cpu core
and 3.5 gigabyte of memory or ram you
could choose a higher end machine so as
of now i'll just say n1 standard
now that basically allows me to choose
these machines so there are different
features which your compute offers such
as you have live migration for vms you
have preemptable virtual machines you
have sold tenant nodes and all those
options can be seen here now in this
machine for my boot disk i can select a
distribution which i would be interested
in for example i could be going for
public images and i can choose for
example ubuntu and then i can choose a
version so it shows me 16.04
and you also have latest versions such
as ubuntu 20. you can choose one of
these and here it asks you to choose the
boot disk type so that could be standard
persistent disk which is hdds which are
low in performance and
you can say low in cost in comparison to
ssds so ssds give you better performance
but then they are little expensive than
using standard persistent disk we can
choose this and we can give a disk size
for example 20 gigabyte and i can click
on select before clicking on select i
can click on custom images and that
shows me if you have any other images
created in your project you could use
those you could also learn about images
by clicking on this link so we'll click
on public images we have chosen this
distribution let's do a select and now
here you have identity and api access
management so let this be default you
can say allow default access and what
you need is depending on the services we
can choose it allows http and https
traffic now we would also need some way
to connect to these machines so when you
set up an instance by default you can do
ssh into it using the google cloud
console or from cloud shell you can also
give a private and a public key so here
you have the option where you can give
all these details so when it comes to
management it tells you what would you
want to go for reservations and you can
say automatically use created
reservation you could also say no you
would not want to use a reservation you
can also set up or provide a startup
script which you would want to give
whenever your machines come up and here
you have the options of preemptability
so compute offers preemptable virtual
machines so that is mainly when you
would want to run bad jobs and fault
tolerant workloads on these machines and
you can benefit with a reduced
cost for your virtual cpu and memory by
80 percent so these are virtual machines
which would be lasting less than 24
hours now by default this is off and it
purely depends on your workload what you
would want to run on these instances i
could just go ahead and select
preemptable being on that and use this
feature of compute you also have on host
maintenance which talks about what would
be happening with this compute engine
instance so when compute engine performs
periodic infrastructure maintenance it
can migrate your vm instances to other
hardware and this is one of the features
which compute engine offers which we
call as live migration for vms here your
compute engine can live migrate between
host systems that is the underlying
systems on which these vm instances are
based on without rebooting which will
keep your application running even when
host system require maintenance and here
it says migrate vm instance recommended
and let that be as it is you can also
say that if there is a maintenance
happening you can terminate the vm
instance now it also talks about
automatic restart which is on which
basically means compute engine can
automatically restart vm instances if
they are terminated from non-user
initiated reasons so these are all the
settings which are available in
management and it also tells us the
different features which we have there
is also a feature called sold tenancy
which basically means sold tenant sold
tenant nodes which can be chosen so you
can have physical compute engine servers
dedicated
exclusively for your use and this is
usually good when you're talking about
bring your own license applications so
sole tenant nodes give you access to
same machine types and vm configuration
options as regular compute instances
however these might be a little
expensive we can choose this one we can
also look into networking which
basically shows the default setup which
goes for auto subnet you can also choose
a particular ip if that is required but
that would cost more you can click on
disks which talk about what do you want
to do with the boot disk when the
instance is deleted what is the
encryption mechanism you would want to
use and here finally you have security
so basically as i said you can ssh into
instance using the cloud console option
and you can also provide a public ssh
key so one way of doing that if you
intend to use an external ssh client
such as putty to connect you can create
a key
so for example i can go into puttygen
and here i can say generate just move my
cursor over here and that will create a
key i can give a name to this one so
i'll say sdu will be user name i'll give
a simple password which i will use to
login to this machine and then i can
save this private key which will get
saved so let's say hdu new key and this
gets saved in a dot ppk file which is
usually used when you use an external
ssh client to connect so save this one
and that saves a ppk file on your
desktop what you can also do is you can
copy this public key content from here
and this is what we would want to give
in our instance here so so that the
public key gets stored on the instance
and private key is what we will use to
connect so once i paste it here it
resolves the name to htu and we have
given the public key now in certain
cases you may want to use a software
which uses ssh to connect to the machine
and that software might not be such as
your putty so in that case you may want
a pem file or a private key which is
saved as a dot pem file so you can also
do that by going to conversions and do a
export open ssh key and then save it so
i'll say hdu new key but then this one
will be saved as a pem file on my
machine so you have ppk file which
allows you to use putty to connect to
the instance you have a pen in case a
software needs directly ssh to these
machines you also have the public key
which we have already provided in the
machine now once this is done i can
close puttygen i can go back to this
page where i'm creating an instance
template and then i can just click on
create so this has created an instance
template which i can use to spin up my
instances any number of instances using
the same template only thing which i
would have to do is change the region
where i would want the instance to run
so now that we have created instance and
that's my this one the third option i
can go back to vm instances now i can
click on create and here i can either
create an instance from scratch by
giving all the details again or i can
just use my template so i can click on
new vm instance from a template choose
my template click on continue and once
this is done i can give my instance name
so let's say c1 i can choose the region
so i will choose frankfurt and then rest
everything is auto populated based on
the template what you have given and you
click on create now this basically
allows you to spin up an instance and
you can create any number of instances
using your template you could have
already created a new instance right
from scratch now once the instance is
created this has a public ip and a
private ip private ip will not change
unless
you would want to set up a new machine
but public ip will change every time you
stop and start the machine now this is
what we need to connect to this machine
i can also do a ssh from here by doing
this in open in a browser window let's
click on this so this is an internal way
of connecting to your instance using ssh
let's wait because it would be
transferring the ssh keys to the vm it
establishes a connection and i'm
connected to my machine what we can
easily do is to confirm if we are in the
right machine we can just do a ls
to look at the file system what we can
also do is we can basically log in as
root by doing a sudo su and that allows
you to get into the machine as root and
from here i can switch to hduser which
will have a dot ssh directory in home
and that basically has authorized keys
and if we would want to see if this one
contains my public key i can just do a
cat dot ssh and then look into
authorized keys and this shows me the
public key which we had initially added
to our instance so this confirms that we
are logged into the machine which we
created now i can close this
and what i can also do is i can copy
this public ip so let's do a copy to
clipboard now go to putty and here i
will say hostname where i'll say hdu
give my public key i'll click on ssh and
in ssh i'll go to authentication now
here we need to give our ppk file so the
ppk file was sdu new key select this one
come back here come to the session give
it a name for example c1 save it and
then you can just say open and say yes
and you are logged in to your machine
now once you're logged in you can always
do a minus ssh and that shows you the
file so this is how you have just used
the compute engine to spin up an
instance but we used a template which
basically allowed me to create this
instance and then i can connect to this
instance and then i can start working on
this so when we talk about features of
compute engine it has predefined machine
types as we saw so compute engine offers
different predefined virtual machines
and this they have configurations for
every need from small general purpose
instances to large memory optimized
instances with up to 11.5 terabytes of
ram you can have fast compute instances
optimized up to 60 virtual cpu cores you
also have custom machine types so you
can create a vm that best fits your
workload and by tailoring a custom
machine type to your specific need you
can realize significant savings there
are preemptable vms which we saw there
is also a facility which allows you to
take the benefit of live migration for
vms you have durable high performance
block storage for virtual machine
instances in the form of persistent
disks where data is stored redundantly
for integrity flexibility and to resize
storage without interruption and you
could be choosing hdds or sdds for your
instances
now you also have option such as gpu
accelerators so for example if i just
click on create instance and i can look
into that so here let the instance name
be instance 1 and what i would be
interested in looking at this one which
says cpu platform and gpu so cpu
platform configuration is permanent you
can also do add gpu so gpus can be added
to accelerate computationally intensive
workloads like machine learning
simulation medical analysis and virtual
workstation applications so you can add
and remove gpus to a vm when your
workload changes and pay for gpu only
while using so these are some of the
features which basically compute engine
offers and we already know that google
bills in second level increments so we
only pay for the compute time now there
are different savings which are possible
so you have commitment savings which
basically means you can save up to 57
percent without upfront cost per
instance type login you have container
support so you can basically run manage
and orchestrate docker containers or
compute engine instances so here when we
are setting up our instances there is an
option which basically allows you to use
or deploy docker images now that can be
done you can also benefit from sustained
use savings that is sustained use
discounts which are automatic discounts
for running compute engine resources for
significant portion of the billing month
you can create a reservation for vm
instance in a specific zone which is
basically seen under your management
section here and you can ensure your
project has resources for future
increases in demand and if no longer
needed delete the reservation so these
are some of the features of compute
engine what we have done is we have
created compute engine using the console
now you can go back you can also do that
using cloud shell and you can click on
this one which activates cloud shell you
could also have the cloud sdk support on
setup on your machine which can be used
now i can just open this in a new window
and from here i can start giving
commands if i would be interested in
setting up an instance from my command
line so here you have different options
now to begin with you can just do a
gcloud and just hit enter and that will
show you different options which are
available which can be used so you have
gcloud compute here which shows
an option to create and manipulate
compute engine resources now i can just
do a queue to quit i can do
compute and that basically will again
show me different options which are
available if you would be interested in
setting up instances from the command
line so here i can say g cloud compute
and then go for instances
and if you do not know the commands you
can just hit enter that will show you
all the different options which we have
so here we have different options such
as list or create or start or update for
example i can just do a list here to see
what instances i have and the instance
which we just created shows up here it
says that status is running i can just
stop this instance i can delete this
instance i can even create an instance
by using a create command here and you
can just do a create help which will
show you what are the different options
you can give so it says instance name
is what you need you can choose an
accelerator you can choose the boot disk
and various other options so i can just
say create and then i can give a name
for example c2 and once i click on this
one it says did you mean europe west 4
zone so it is asking me for the region
and the zone and i can say yes and these
settings are coming from my default
profile i can always change those by
changing the metadata so now we have
created an instance it says running if
we do a list again to see we see two
instances created one was in europe west
three one was only europius west four
both of them have internal and external
eyepiece
now you can do a
describe to look at the different
options here so gcloud basically allows
you different commands which you can use
to work with your instance to create
instances to change the metadata if you
would want to change the region if you
would want to add a startup script all
those options are possible from the
command line which we can learn in
detail in later sessions so this is your
compute engine as a service now that we
have learnt about the compute domain and
g
compute services which is offered by gcp
let's also learn about storage and
databases that's again within the
storage domain and the services which
are offered by google cloud platform now
you can go back to console and here you
can click on this one and here you can
just scroll down to see what are the
different options in storage so you have
options such as big table you have data
store firestore file store you have sql
based services you have storage which is
object storage and then you have other
options which are available so google
cloud platform offers different storage
based services out of which storage
which is your object storage is quite
popular one click on storage
and that basically shows you an option
which talks about storage
browser so this is your google cloud's
object storage
so when we talk about object storage it
is basically
a storage where you could store any kind
of data and when we talk about object
storage it is a bunch of bytes which we
address
wherein every object will have a unique
key these unique keys are in the form of
url which allows you to access the
object so cloud storage is comprised of
what we call as buckets which are used
to store and hold your storage objects
these storage objects are immutable and
every change creates a new version now
you can also have control access via iam
that is identity access management or
via access control list so there is also
an option called object versioning which
basically says if it is on every time
you try to store the same object a new
version of the object would be created
otherwise newer option will override old
one as we cannot archive the old version
so let's see how we work with this
object storage so here you can click on
create bucket
now once you click on create bucket it
needs a name so let's say test bucket
and here
i can just give say number one so that
says this is the name of my bucket now i
can directly click on continue or it
would be good to look at different
options which are available here
so when you click on choose where to
store your data
so
it already gives me an option it says
the bucket name is already taken so let
me give it a unique name so let's say
test buck and let's call it
aua so that should be unique now here it
says choose where to store your data
so this one gives you location type so
you can have region specific buckets
which give you lowest latency that is
fastest response time within a single
region however it does not make your
storage highly available you can make a
dual region which is basically allowing
your bucket or storage to be accessible
across regions you can also make it
multi-region which is highest
availability offered as of now we can
choose region specific and now it asks
you to choose a location now as
always i will choose
frankfurt now i can click on continue
and rest all the rest let all the
storage options be default or you can
click on a default storage class now
that tells you
based on your storage class there are
variant costs when it comes to storing
retrieving or doing any kind of
operations so you have a standard
option which says best for short-term
storage and frequently accessed data you
can also go for cold storage such as
near line which is best for backups and
data access less than once a month you
can go for freezing storage such as cold
line best for disaster recovery and data
accessed
less than once a quarter or you can go
for archiving where the data is accessed
less than once a year let's go for
standard as of now and now you can
choose how to control access to objects
so you have fine grained or uniform let
it be fine grained wherein you can give
additional permissions
at bucket level using iam or object
level permissions using access control
list
in advance settings you can choose the
encryption and you can also choose a
retention policy so a retention policy
to specify the minimum duration that
this buckets objects must be protected
from deletion or modification after they
are uploaded
you can always learn about this more by
clicking here now once i have chosen all
the relevant options i can click on
create and that basically will create a
bucket by the name i have given i can
click on overview to basically see
brief details about my bucket such as
region what is the default storage class
and it also shows you the link url which
can be used to access your bucket it
also gives you the link for gsutil now
gsutil is a command which can be used in
your cloud shell to basically work with
your buckets you can click on
permissions to basically see what kind
of permissions are already in place and
you can then make changes you can
basically add members you can view by
different roles so for example here by
default it shows
other services such as data proc or your
bucket owner or bucket reader related
permissions which have been already
granted now once i have looked at my
bucket i can start using it i can drag
and drop and push in files here so as of
now there are no live objects in my
object storage that is in my bucket what
i can do is i can click on upload files
and then
i can choose a location from my machine
for example i'll go into data sets and
what i can do is i can choose
some of the files here
in any format let's choose csv or text
and just to open so this one will
basically upload my data sets here now
once i've uploaded the files i can
basically close this one i can look into
options here which says edit permissions
and edit metadata if you would want to
download it if you would want to copy
move or rename it if you would want to
export to a different service called
cloud pub sub which is publish
subscribing messaging system you can
scan the data now you can click on a
particular file and that basically shows
you the url which basically allows you
to access this file you can try copying
this you can click on download and
download this file you can even try
accessing this from public and that
basically shows you the content of this
file based on the permissions so this is
basically your object storage which is
one of the service which is offered what
you can also do is you can create
folders and within folders you can then
upload your data so this is your google
cloud
storage option which is for your
object storage that is you can add
different items you can give different
permissions and you can use this google
cloud platforms storage service offering
now you also have other options such as
big table and we can go into that by
clicking here and click on big table so
big table is one of the service which
kickstarted nosql databases today in
market we see different nosql databases
such as cassandra hbase mongodb
couchdb
neo4j and many others so you can
basically use bigtable which was the
pioneer when it comes to your no sql
databases or not only sql databases so
the problem initially faced by google
was that of the web indexes
behind search engine were taking too
long to build so company wanted to build
database that would provide real-time
access to petabytes of data and that's
where bigtable began so big table powers
different other google services such as
gmail google maps and other services and
in 2015
it was launched as a service for
customers so when it comes to
scalability with use of bigtable you can
increase your machine count without any
downtime and you can handle admin tasks
like upgrades restarts and so on which
are basically taken care by the cloud
provider data present in cloud bigtable
is encrypted and you can use im roles to
specify access so data written to or
from big table is through data service
layers such as managed virtual machines
hbase rest servers java services hbs
client and so on here if i would want to
use bigtable i can click on create
instance and that basically tells me
cloud bigtable instance is a container
for your clusters now here you can give
an instance name so for example i will
say aua and then say for example
test and let's say big table so that
will be the name of instance this will
be permanent you can choose the storage
type again you can go for lower latency
more rows red per second typically used
for real time serving use cases or you
can go for sdds which have higher
latency for random reads good
performance on scans and typically used
for batch analytics so let's go for ssds
as of now here you have cluster id which
is auto populated you can choose a
region so let's go for our favorite one
here
where i can say europe west 3 i can
choose a zone here and i can then choose
how many nodes
would i want to use for my big table so
when you talk about big table service it
will have a cluster underlying which
will have various nodes which will
control your data throughput storage and
rows read per second so as of now let it
be just one node and that's enough for
our demo when we talk about performance
it basically tells you based on the
current node and storage type it tells
you how many reads can happen at
milliseconds so it says 10 000 rows per
second at six millisecond you have
rights which are 10 000 rows per second
or you have scans which are 220
megabytes per second storage which is
taken care here would be 2.5 terabytes
and i can then basically click on create
now there is also some option called
replication guidance which basically
says replication for cloud table big
table copies your data across multiple
regions enabling you to isolate workload
and increase the availability and
durability of your data depending on
your use case you can have big table
which can be used to have your data
across regions now you can click on
create
with all your specifications chosen and
that's going to set up a cluster or you
can say a fully managed nosql database
which will give you low latency and
replication for high availability now
once we have a new instance you can
connect to it with the cbt command line
tool and for instructions you can click
on learn more here you can just click on
this instance id to see the details
again if you would want to look into
your big table setup so it tells me here
that we have one instance what is the
cpu utilization time how many rows for
read or written what is the throughput
and this is
auto populated based on your usage you
can click on monitoring and that
basically will give you different
widgets which will display information
for your cpu utilization what is your
hottest node depending on how many nodes
you have system errors automatic
failovers storage utilization and so on
you can click on key visualizer which
will allow you to look into your table
if you have already created some data
here and you can click on tables to see
how many tables you have added here so
that's in brief about your big tables
which is
one thing which we need to remember is
it's not good for
all use cases
so should be used for low latency access
that is fast access and good if at least
data is greater than one terabyte for
smaller amount of data the overhead is
too high so big tables performance will
suffer if you store individual elements
larger than 10 megabytes
if you want to store bigger objects such
as images video files then go for object
storage and that would be a better
option so always remember bigtable is
not a relational database it's a nosql
database and when you talk about
multi-row transactions or online
transaction processing bigtable is not
the right choice
so it can be used for wide range of
applications especially when you talk
about your olap that is online
analytical processing so it is designed
to store key value pairs and there can
be different use cases so for example if
you are using something like cloud data
flow or cloud data proc
where you would want mapreduce kind of
operations bigtable can act as a good
storage because it has very high
throughput and scalability and the best
thing is that it supports hbs api thus
allowing easy integration with apache
hadoop and spark clusters which you can
bring up using one more service which
google cloud platform offers which is
called cloud data proc
so bigtable is good for real-time
analytics
it's commonly seen in financial services
iot and others and if you are thinking
of
running interactive sql then
bigtable would not be the right choice
but the other choice would be bigquery
you should also remember that this
has a cluster running and you would be
charged if this cluster kept on running
so you have to be very careful in your
free account when you're using such
services now we have clicked on this one
so i can select this one and basically i
can look at the permissions i can look
at the labels i can look at inherited
permissions here i can also
click on my instance
which we created and either you can edit
or you can just do a delete so as of now
we will just delete this which needs you
to given that name so we'll say aua test
b d
and then click on delete so whenever you
are trying out different services the
first approach should be setting up
these different services seeing how they
work basically trying connecting to them
and once you are satisfied with the
initial test then you can plan your
actions and come back and use the
service for a longer duration now that's
your big table which is one of the
offerings we can go back into storage
and here you have other options which
are available so for example we were in
big table you also have an option such
as cloud data store now that's one more
service which is offered by google cloud
platform when it comes to storage domain
so google added software on top of big
table which supports more than simple
key value pairs
when you talk about secondary indexes
instead of just having one primary index
when you talk about asset properties for
reliable transactions such as sql query
like language
so these
features or these services were added to
or on top of your bigtable which gave
birth to a new service which was
released as cloud data store so this is
where you have cloud data store and you
can select a client cloud firestore mode
so you can go for a native mode enable
all cloud firestores features with
offline support or you can go for clouds
data store system on top of clouds
firestore so these are different options
here and here we look at the api or
scalability engine support how many
rights it supports and so on you can
choose one of these and then you can
choose where to store your data so for
example if i click on this one then it
choose asks me to choose a location so
it says the location of your database
affect its cost availability and
durability choose a regional location
lower right latency lower cost or
multi-region location here i can
basically choose for example europe
and then i can go ahead and create a
database so it says initializing cloud
firestore in datastore mode services in
eu3 this usually takes a few minutes you
will be redirected to your database once
it is ready so if we compare the pricing
structure between cloud data store and
cloud bigtable always remember cloud
data store you pay for monthly storage
which is also in the case of big table
however here you are paying for monthly
storage for reads and rights
but in case of big table you are paying
for cluster when it is running so cloud
data store is a good option for small
data
infrequent access and it acts cheaper
when you talk about large amount of data
or big data and frequent access then you
are talking about cloud bigtable so
bigtable is cheaper when you talk about
larger amount of data so here it says
since your database is empty you can
still switch to cloud firestore in
native mode to get more features you
could do that you could learn you could
say query by gql
as of now we don't have any data here
let's look at the dashboard which says
since your database is empty you can
still switch to cloud firestore in
native mode to get more features so this
is your cloud data store and it has many
features
which help you to work with your data
however some features are important
features of rdbms were still missing and
that's where google created yet another
big table based service called cloud
spanner now we can continue working on
cloud data store which basically gives
you one option to work with your data
you can create an entity
here by clicking on create entity and
that basically gives you
options such as default namespace you
can give a kind you can give numeric id
and you can start adding properties but
to learn more about data store we will
learn about this in further sessions so
as of now i'm going to click on cancel
i'm going to go back to my data store
and this basically
let's go to data store option
or i can go into admin here which
basically says if you have entities you
can import or export them so let's go
back and let's again look into storage
options
so as of now we were in data store let's
click on this one
so as i mentioned your cloud data store
which basically gives you some
additional features on top of your big
table but what google also did was it
realized that there was a need for rdbms
feature support that is there were a lot
of features now here we have created a
data store and it says your data base is
ready to go just add data you can create
entity start putting in data and then
you can go ahead and query this so if
you would want to learn more about your
data store you can just click on this
one and that takes you to the complete
documentation of native mode and data
store mode what is firestore in native
mode what is in data store mode what are
pricing and locations how you choose a
database mode what are the feature
comparisons what you can do what you are
allowed to do here what programming
languages can be used different regions
pricing and so on as of now we'll click
on this one and let's look at one
advanced service which google cloud came
up with when it comes to
your additional features of rdbms so
google created yet another big table
based service called cloud spanner now
that you might not see here but if you
scroll down you should be able to see
your cloud spanner
in the options here
or did we miss it on the top so let's
again look here yeah so it is here and
you can click on spanner so cloud
spanner was released in 2017 it
basically supports relational schema so
it offers strong consistency for all
queries
which can be sql based you can have
multi-region deployment
now when it comes to massive scalability
requirement and strong consistency cloud
spanner is a good option so it says
cloud spanner is a managed mission
critical globally consistent and
scalable relational database so if you
would want to use this then you will
have to enable this api which shows you
an option here it says try this api so
it's a managed
service
so it is one of the google's most
expensive database services
there is also one more database service
which is cloud sql which can be used so
when we talk about your cloud spanner it
is fully managed relational database
service it is massively distributed you
can have millions of machines across
hundreds of data centers with support
automatic sharding and synchronous
replication it gives you low latency and
schema updates without downtime making
data high availability and reliability
so we learn about cloud spanner
with more details
later in other sessions now we can also
go back to storage and we can look at
the different options which we have here
so you have object storage you have
spanner you also have your sql based
service which is yet another managed
service offered by
cloud or google cloud i would say so
that's called cloud sql so this is
basically a service which allows you to
have fully managed relational mysql
postgres and sql server databases google
handles replication patch management
database management and other things
which are related to this managed or
fully managed database service
it can allow you to handle terabytes of
storage capacity with 40 000
iops with huge amount of ram per
instance so you can click on create
instance here and then you can choose
one of the database which you would want
to use so cloud sql is a managed service
you can choose one of your mysql or
postgres and sql server say for example
i choose mysql now that basically tells
me what is the instance id it
sets up a password you can always change
the password you can change the region
you can choose your database version and
then you can also look at other
configuration options which talk about
machine type which will be used what is
about your backup and recovery
maintenance and all that and if you
click on create this will basically
create a fully managed sql service which
can allow you to straight away start
using mysql on cloud thus allowing you
to store your relational data when we
talk about storage options how can we
not talk about a data warehouse solution
or basically an option which allows you
to run your queries by directly updating
data so you can
use a data warehouse service which
google cloud platform offers and that's
called bigquery
so basically you can be looking into
the
big data section here and here you have
an option called bigquery so this
basically brings ease of implementation
and speed so building your own data
house can be expensive time consuming
and difficult to scale so with bigquery
you just load data and pay only for what
you use so it when it comes to features
you have
features such as capability to process
billions of rows in seconds and if you
would want to do real-time analysis of
streaming data that is also possible
here so here we have clicked on bigquery
which basically shows you the option
where you can start typing your query
and test your data access for example if
i have uploaded some data so
it shows me there are some queries which
are saved here now i can schedule your
query i can basically choose the format
of a particular query by clicking on
this more
here i have an option which says add
data so i can pin it to a particular
project i can explore public data sets i
can create a connection so if i click on
explore public data sets then it takes
me to a page from where you can get
different kind of data sets which are
already available which you can put into
your bigquery and start querying your
data by default it shows that it is
aligned to my project and i don't need
to worry about it i can look at saved
queries if i have already saved a
particular query i can look at job
history i can look at transfers
scheduled queries and reservations so
bigquery basically
initially had its own version of sql
which was slightly different from
standard sql but in 2016 bigquery 2 was
released that supports sql 2011 standard
you can always select standard sql now
bigquery when it comes to pricing we
need to remember that the storage is
where the storage cost is very less here
approximately 0.02 cents per gb per
month
it is almost similar to near line where
you can also have low cost that is 0.01
cents per gigabyte per month there is no
charge for reading data from storage
when it comes to querying and that's
where the cost is incurred so one
terabyte per month is free and after
that it costs few cents per gigabyte so
this is mainly for high volume customers
there is a flat rate by pricing which
can be used so when you talk about
querying you can save your query results
you can create data set to store the
results now results are put in a temp
table in cache and after you're done
with that you can delete data set and
delete all the data
so when you talk about loading data into
bigquery you can get the data from cloud
storage google drive cloud data store
stack driver stack
driver other options you have cloud
bigtable or
other web interfaces so you can download
from url such as csv json avro you can
create data set create table and create
from source by doing a file upload
so 10 megabyte or less files can be
uploaded using web interface as an
option you can also use command line and
then you can start working with
your bigquery
so
here you can also work with streaming
data by basically pushing in streaming
data into your bigquery which allows you
to add one record at a time now you
could use something like cloud data flow
which
allows you to use a particular pipeline
about cloud data flow we will learn
later so you can benefit from different
features of bigquery and thus use
google's offering to work on your
structured data or i would say data
which suits well in data warehouses
now these are some of the storage
related services which google cloud
offers
although we will learn about using
bigquery and running
or uploading some data by creating add
data set here
by say creating connection or
using a public data set so as of now i
have this you can also access the
command line to work with this but we
will learn in detail about bigquery in
later sessions now here you can scroll
down and you also have an option within
big data space and that is your data
proc so when you talk about data proc
this is
again a managed service which allows you
to run spark or hadoop jobs so
especially if you are interested in big
data workload so for big data processing
for machine learning you can always use
cloud data proc this uses compute engine
instances under the hood but takes care
of management
of these instances so it's say it's a
layer on top to spin off clusters it's a
managed service it's cheaper pay when
the jobs are running only it's fast
because it is integrated with other
google cloud services you have open
source components pre-installed and data
proc is integrated with yarn to make
cluster management easier when you talk
about data proc you can click on create
cluster and that basically allows you to
set up your cluster by choosing a
particular region which you would want
to use for example i'll choose euro
paste 4. here it tells what kind of
machines you would want to use and by
default it has populated
as
the machine here which is 4 cpu and 15
gigabyte now since you might be using a
free account let's not go for the
high-end machine let's go for n1
standard 2 and then you can scroll down
it says what is the primary disk what is
the disk type and this one was for your
master machine that is machine which
will have the master processes running
then you have your
worker node configuration which tells
this will be let's choose a lower end
machine and we can choose how many
worker nodes you would have so it says
minimum 2 you can choose the ssds and
their capacity it talks about yarn cores
and yarn memory which will be allocated
and here we have
then option of clicking on create
so once you click on create this will
basically spin up a cluster wherein you
can
straight away start submitting jobs to
this
you can basically go ahead once your
cluster is ready you can go into the
cluster you can submit a job you can
choose a type which is spark or any
other application which you would want
to run and then basically you can use
this fully managed service which allows
you to run your big data clusters you
can obviously control access via roles
or access control list and you can have
access
as it is at project level or based on
your data proc cluster or even at your
worker notes
so we'll learn about data proc in later
sessions so as of now you see here the
cluster is getting created it says
the cloud storage bucket which it is
using is this one now i can click on
this and open link in a new tab it still
takes me into console but now it is
showing me the bucket which is being
used by your data proc cluster
this is the bucket which is being used
and it is being used for underlying
metadata which gets stored here so you
look at the cluster related folders you
can click in these folders and then it
can see what is the script output what
it is doing and so on now i can come
back here to my bucket
which will basically show me what kind
of buckets have been created so you see
data proc service automatically created
some buckets which will be holding some
data you also have some other buckets
which were created based on other
services which we used the access
control is fine grained in all cases
plus it also shows r bucket so
underlying it is using compute instances
it is basically using let's go here and
let's go to compute engine and let's
look into vm instances
so data proc which has spun up a cluster
is also using the vm instances which we
see here are running it is using the
buckets and it has made a cluster ready
to use so you can click on this cluster
and that shows me my cluster related
details if there are any jobs running
what are vm instances what kind of
configurations it has used
and you can look at different details
here you can look at the logs you can
click on jobs and that will show you if
you have
basically run a job on this ready to use
cluster so it says there is this
particular job which was run
which was a spark job you can click on
submit and this one tells you what is
the job id what is the region you would
choose for example we will again choose
for example europe quest 4 it tells what
is the job type so you can run all these
type of jobs in this cluster such as
hadoop spark pi spark hive pig presto
you can give your jar file so if you are
packaged your application is a jar you
can mention that here you can pass in
some arguments you can also say some
other jar files add some properties and
then click on submit which will run your
job on this ready to use cluster now
since we have tested it i can basically
go ahead and do a delete i don't want to
incur any cost on these manage services
which are running so there are a lot
more information about using these
services which google cloud platform
offers and we can continue learning
about these services
as we explore your google cloud console
or even your command line option now we
can come out of this one
by clicking on this menu and then we
have other options such as kubernetes
you have cloud functions you have your
networking related services monitoring
related services different kind of tools
what you have you have other big data
specific services which you can learn
about and for each of these servers
google has a very good documentation
available for example when you talk
about publish subscribe messaging system
it is a real-time managed service which
basically is a pioneer which was used
and now you have a famous service such
as kafka which is being used for your
publish subscribing or messaging system
kind of requirements
so to conclude about
google cloud platform services you can
always go to cloud.google.com
and look into the document section now
here you have list of different featured
products you also have list of your
different domains and services which
google cloud offers and you can learn
about all the different services which
are offered by google cloud here you can
click on featured products and that
basically shows you compute engine cloud
run cloud storage you have cloud sql
bigquery vision ai you can scroll down
and look at your artificial intelligence
and machine learning related services
platform and accelerators api management
so google cloud platform offers
different services in mainly in your
compute storage and databases you have
networking related services
big data specifics developer tools cloud
ai
identity and security
iot management tools api platform
and so on so basically learn about the
gcp services which google cloud platform
offers and in detail you can play around
with different services which are
offered by creating a free account and
as i demonstrated you can use any one of
these services quick start them
basically connect to them put in your
data or use a managed service to manage
your data and benefit from google cloud
platform thus
having modernized infrastructure for
your different use cases
thank you all for watching this video
tutorial on devops and cloud computing
full course if you have any questions
please feel free to put them in the
comments section of the video stay safe
and keep learning
you